PREPARED TO PRESENT. SB THIRTY
NINE. WE WILL ALLOW YOU TO DO
THAT AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR. YES WILL GET TO.
GIVE ME MEMBERS ON THAT OKAY-
GOOD AFTERNOON IN RESPONSE TO
THE SCOLDED NINETEEN EMERGENCY
AND THE PURPOSE AND TEND TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC LEGISLATORS
EMPLOYERS MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING AND
FACE COVERING GUIDELINES AND
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICE
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE
ACCESS. TO THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS TO ALLOW THE PUBLIC
ACCESS WE HAVE A MINUTE MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC TO TWO HEARING
ROOMS. TO THE EXTENT THAT
SOCIAL DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS
ALLOW AND WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE FOR
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY TODAY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT. THE PROTESTS TO
PRINT TOLL FREE NUMBER AND
ACCESS CODE IS POSTED ON OUR
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. IT WILL BE
DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN AND I
WILL ANNOUNCE IT NOW TODAY
TODAY'S PROTESTS ABOUT NUMBER.
IT'S COLD. EIGHTY FOR ME.
844-291-6364. 844-291-6364 AND
THE ACCESS CODE IS. SIX FIVE
FOUR TWO EIGHT NINE SEVEN.
AGAIN. SIX FIVE FOUR TWO EIGHT
NINE SEVEN. FOR DOUBT
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THE
TELECONFERENCES TO WORKS PLEASE
REFER TO THE SENATE AND FOR
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. WHEN WE
MOVED TO PUBLIC COMMENT YOU
WILL BE PROMPTED BY A MODERATOR
TO DIAL ONE THEN ZERO FOR
SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION. PRESS
THIS ONLY ONE TIME AND WAIT
PATIENTLY FOR THE OPERATOR TO
ASSIGN YOU A LINE NUMBER. THIS
CAN BE A SHORT WAIT ONCE YOU
RECEIVE YOUR LINE NUMBER YOU'LL
WAIT IN QUEUE. FOR THE
MODERATOR TO CALL YOUR LINE
NUMBER. AT THAT TIME YOU WILL
BE ON MUTE IT AND YOU'LL NOW BE
READY TO ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE.
PLEASE NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR
US TO HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND
AVOID ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK. YOU
MUST MUTE THE DEVICE YOU ARE
WATCHING THE HEARING ON PRIOR
TO GIVING TESTIMONY. OVER THE
PHONE IT IS IMPORTANT THAT WE
HEAR YOU HEAR FROM YOU AND WE
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE. I
WILL MAINTAIN DECORUM TO THE
BEST OF MY ABILITY DURING THIS
HEARING AS CUSTOMARY. AND ANY%
INDIVIDUAL WHO IS DISRUPTIVE
MAY BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
MEETING SERVICE GRAB THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. WHILE EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HEARING PROCESS
AND CONDUCT OUR HEARINGS IN AS
CLOSE. TO THE SAME MANNER AS
CUSTOMARY AS IT IS CUSTOMARY
THERE MAY BE SOME BIG LACK
TIME. FOR PARTICIPANTS WHO ARE
JUSTIN TO THE NEW USE OF ONLINE
TO AND TECHNOLOGIES. HE PLEASE
BE RESPECTFUL AND PATIENT SO
ALL INTERESTED PARTIES CAN BE
HEARD- WE HAVE EIGHT ITEMS ON
TO DEFINE OUR AGENDA TODAY- S.
B. TWO FOUR THREE BY CENTER
WINNER IS ON CONSISTENT SENT.
AND BEFORE WE HEAR THE
PRESENTATIONS ARE I BELIEVE WE
ARE NOW ABLE TO ESTABLISH A
QUORUM. CAN WE CALL THE ROLL.
BRADFORD HERE REDFORD HERE A
TRAVEL BUG. THE TURBO CARE COM
LONGER. YOU'RE HERE COME HERE
HERE SKINNER WIENER WIENER HERE
CORMS ESTABLISHED VERS BIG WARM
HAS BEEN ESTABLISHED. NO NO. OF
AN INCH IS A TIE CAN WE GET A
MOTION ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
IT'S BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR
WIENER OCEAN THE CONSENT
CALENDAR S. B. TWO FOUR THREE.
CONSULTANT WE PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
FIVE HI HELLO. THIS IS NOT A
PROBLEM HI. I'M A TERRIBLE GUY
COME LONGER KAMLAGER AYE
SKINNER AND WIENER. WIENER HI
THE GUN CALL FOR SENATOR
SKINNER SHOULD LEAVE IT ON CALL
FOR SENATOR SKINNER. THAT ITEM
AS FOR VOTES WILL LEAVE IT ON
CALL FOR THE ABSENT MEMBERS
OKAY NOW WE'RE READY FOR OUR
FIRST AUTHOR AND NOW WELCOME
AGAIN SENATOR GROWTH YOU MAY
PRESENT SB. THIRTY NINE. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR. INVESTOR
BURKE AND MEMBERS AT FIRST I'D
LIKE TO THANK THE COMMITTEE
STAFF AND THE CHAIRMAN FOR
WORKING WITH ME ON THIS BILL
AND LET ME START BY SAYING THAT
ALL EXCEPT THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS AS DRAFTED AND SO WE
CAN MOVE THIS BILL FORWARD IT
IS UNFORTUNATE HOWEVER THAT WE
HAVE TO OMIT THE COUNTY JAILS
FROM SB THIRTY NINE AS IT WAS
INCLUDED IN THE STATE AUTHORS
ARE TRIGGERS REPORT
RECOMMENDATIONS. MY HOPE IS
MOVING FORWARD THAT THE
LEGISLATURE TO EVERYTHING THAT
THEY CAN TO ELIMINATE AS MUCH
PRIDE AS POSSIBLE IN THE EDT
SYSTEM. SB THIRTY NINE WILL
STRENGTHEN PROTECTIONS AGAINST
FRAUDULENT CLAIMS FILED WITH
THE EMPLOYMENT DEVELOPMENT
DEPARTMENT. OR UNEMPLOYMENT
BENEFITS AND PREVENT THESE
BENEFITS FROM GOING TO
INELIGIBLE RECIPIENTS THAT ARE
INCARCERATED. FOLLOWING THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT'S RESPONSE
TO COPE IN NINETEEN IN MARCH OF
TWENTY TWENTY. CALIFORNIA TASK
THE E. D. D. WITH DISTRIBUTING
THE CHARISMATIC FRIENDS.
THROUGH THE NEWLY CREATED
PANDEMIC EMPLOYMENT ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM. EVER DESPITE HAVING
BEEN WARNED BY THE US
DEPARTMENT OF LABOR ABOUT THE
POTENTIAL RISK OF FRAUD DDT WAS
NOT PREPARED TO PREVENT AND
ADDRESS THE FRAUDULENT CLAIMS
FILED WITH THE DEPARTMENT. TO
MAKE MATTERS WORSE- A STATE
AUDIT REVEALED THAT THE EDT WAS
TOLD ABOUT THE POTENTIAL
PROBLEM BACK IN TWO THOUSAND
AND SIXTEEN AND DIDN'T DO MUCH
TO PREVENT IT. THEIR FEET THEIR
FAILURES- TO TAKE ACTION
ALLOWED RAMPANT FRAUD TO TAKE
PLACE IN TWENTY TWENTY AND IT
STILL CONTINUES TODAY. IN THE
FRAUD WAS SO PROLIFIC WITHIN
THE EDT THAT THEY'VE PAID OUT
ALMOST THEY PAID OUT BILLIONS
OF DOLLARS TO FRAUDULENT
CLAIMS. SOME ESTIMATES PUT THE
TOTAL AMOUNT AND CLOSE TO
THIRTY BILLION DOLLARS. IN THE
AND IT'S RISING THANK YOU. AND
IT'S RISING THESE BENEFITS WERE
GIVEN TO PRISONERS WHO WERE ON
DEATH ROW INCLUDING WELL KNOWN
CONVICTED MURDERS LIKE SCOTT
PETERSON. WHO KILLED HIS WIFE
AND UNBORN CHILD OTHER EXAMPLES
OF CONVICTED CONVICTED KILLERS
WHO RECEIVED MULTIPLE BENEFITS
INCLUDE ROYAL CLARK HE WAS
CONVICTED OF KILLING TWO YOUNG
GIRLS AND ASSAULTING ANOTHER.
AND SUSAN EUBANKS WHO SHOT HER
FOUR SONS AGES FOUR THROUGH
FOURTEEN. IN THE HEAD AFTER A
NIGHT OF DRINKING AND DRUGS.
ADDITIONALLY A PRISON INMATE
FRAUDULENT FILED UNDER THE NAME
AS SENATOR DIANNE FEINSTEIN. AN
INMATE USES SO SECURITY NUMBER
OF ONE TWO THREE FOUR FIVE SIX
SEVEN EIGHT NINE TO GET
BENEFITS. THIS IS UTTERLY
RIDICULOUS. SO WHILE THIS FRAUD
WAS GOING ON SINGLE MOMS AND
FATHERS IN INDIVIDUALS WHO HAD
WORKED HARD AND WERE ENTITLED
TO BENEFITS. WERE FORCED TO
DRAIN THEIR SAVINGS TO TAKE
CARE OF THEIR FAMILIES AND PUT
FOOD ON THE TABLES AND WAIT
MONTHS FOR A RESPONSE FROM THE
EDT. CALIFORNIA WAS ONLY AS
ONLY ONE OF FIFTEEN STATES THAT
FAILED TO CROSS MATCH
UNEMPLOYMENT CLAIMS OF PRISON
ROLES. WE CAN WE CAN ALL DO
BETTER AND WE MUST DO BETTER
FOR OUR STATE. MILLIONS OF
CALIFORNIANS HAVE BEEN- LEFT
HIGH AND DRY IS THE EDT IS
FAILED TO PROVIDE ADEQUATE
SERVICE. AND WE'VE ALL HEARD
ABOUT IT FROM OUR CONSTITUENTS
I KNOW THAT MY PHONE AND I'VE
TALKED TO SEVERAL OF THE FOR OF
MY COLLEAGUES. THAT'S ONE OF
THE MOST- COMMON CALLS THAT
COMES INTO OUR DISTRICT OFFICE.
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA HAS A
RESPONSIBILITY TO ENSURE THAT
FUTURE FRAUD DOES NOT TAKE
PLACE. MILLIONS OF CALIFORNIANS
HAVE LOST THEIR JOB AT NO FARK
FAULT OF THEIR OWN BECAUSE OF
THE RESPONSE TO CODE NINETEEN.
IN CALIFORNIA MESTI BETTER
THERE'S NO THERE'S NO ROOM FOR
NOTHING LESS. SB THIRTY NINE
ENJOYS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND
IS SUPPORTED BY NUMEROUS
ORGANIZATIONS. AND CORPORATIONS
ORGANIZATIONS LAW ENFORCEMENT
ORGANIZATIONS A SHERIFF'S
OFFICERS AND DISTRICT ATTORNEYS-
FOR ALL THESE REASONS I ASK FOR
YOUR VOTE I ON SB THIRTY NINE
AND JOINING ME TODAY TO TESTIFY
BY PHONE IS IN DECEMBER THE
KERN COUNTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB
THIRTY NINE. YOU WERE GOING TO
FORWARD ALL YOUR PRIMARY
WITNESSES BOTH IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION TO MINUTES SO IF. D.
A.'S EMRS PREPARED- WE'LL TAKE
YOUR TESTIMONY I AM. I AM
MISTER CHAIRPERSON- GOOD
AFTERNOON MR NATE MISTER
CHAIRPERSON AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. HI MY NAME IS
CYNTHIA ZIMMER. AND I AM A KERN
COUNTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY. I'M
JOINING YOU THIS AFTERNOON.
SHARE MY EXPERIENCES REGARDING
PANDEMIC UNEMPLOYMENT
ASSISTANCE FRAUD. THE PANDEMIC
HAS HAD A NEGATIVE EFFECT ON
PUBLIC SAFETY IN CALIFORNIA. IN
KERN COUNTY WHERE WE HAVE HAD
THE HIGHEST HOMICIDE RATE PER
CAPITA IN CALIFORNIA FOR
SEVERAL YEARS RUNNING. WE ARE
DEADLIEST YEAR ON RECORD. IN.
TWENTY TWENTY WITH ONE HUNDRED
TWENTY FIVE HOMICIDE. TWENTY
TWENTY ALSO BROUGHT US THE MOST
SIGNIFICANT BROAD ON TAXPAYER
FUNDS. IN CALIFORNIA HISTORY
WIDESPREAD EDT FRAUD. WE SAW
THIS BROUGHT IN OUR COMMUNITIES
IN THE JAIL AND IN STATE PRISON.
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF LOCAL AND
STATE INMATES ARE INVOLVED.
KERN COUNTY HAS BEEN
PARTICULARLY IMPACTED BY EDT
FRAUD BECAUSE OUR COUNTY HAS
FIVE STATE PRISONS MORE THAN
ANY OTHER COUNTY IN CALIFORNIA.
MANY PROSECUTORS AND
INVESTIGATORS IN MY OFFICE HAVE
BEEN REASSIGNED FROM OTHER
UNITS WITHIN THE OFFICE TO WORK
EXCLUSIVELY ON EDT FRAUD IT IS
A KURD AND ALL OF OUR KERN
COUNTY PRISON. THE LOSS TO
TAXPAYERS ASSOCIATED WITH EDT
FRAUD CAN YOU. AS WE LEARN MORE
ABOUT THE FASTEST OF THE BUTTE.
S. SENATOR GROW STATE ESTIMATE%
THE AMOUNT WHAT CALIFORNIA AT
THIRTY ONE BILLION DOLLARS. IF
CALIFORNIANS DON'T FIND IN
EIGHT DENNIS ADDED ON THE STRIP
I DO AND IT CERTAINLY MAKES IT
HARDER THIRTY. I AM IT'S NOT
HEY. UNLESS CROSS MATCHING
REQUIREMENTS LIKE THOSE
PROPOSED YOUR ART ALMOND.
CALIFORNIA REP MAKING THIS
MISTAKE THAT LEFT MILK AND-
POCKETED BY CRIMINAL INTENT ON
PRESS IT WILL. AS I DO HERE IS
A PUBLIC FUNDS WE ALL OWE A
DUTY TO FOR THAT TAXPAYER
DOLLARS ARE PROTECTED FROM IT
AND ALL. AND I URGE YOU ALL TO
SUPPORT S. B. THIRTEEN I VOTE
RIGHT THANKS SO MUCH MISTER
CHAIRPERSON FOR THE COMMITTEE
FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU D.
A.'S ARMOR. DO WE HAVE
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
OF SB THIRTY NINE. CAN THE
MODERATOR. WELL FIRST LET ME
LOOK INTO THE GALLERY HERE AND
ROOM FORTY TWO OLD THREE. I SEE
NO WITNESSES HERE. AND CAN WE
NOW GO TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY AND
SEE IF THERE'S ANY WITNESSES
AND SUPPORT. OF SB THIRTY NINE
CENA WITNESSES THERE. WE WILL
NOW MOVE TO WITNESSES ARE WHO
ARE TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT VIA
TELECONFERENCE. MODERATOR WOULD
YOU PLEASE PROP INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF SB THIRTY NINE. THANK YOU IF
YOU WISH TO COMMENT IN SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. OR TO WIDE FORTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. YOUR TURN
MEMBERS SO HE WANTS TO LEAVE
SHOT ON BEHALF OF THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS HAS KERN COUNTY IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. MODERATE
CAN YOU TELL US HOW MANY CALLS
WE HAVE IN Q. AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU I CURRENTLY HAVE
THREE MORE THANK YOU. THE
CALLER. RIGHT TWENTY TWENTY TO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MISTER MEMBERS
CORY SALTILLO RD THE CALIFORNIA
STATE SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. FIND SIXTY
TO PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON TERRY MEMBERS MY NAME
IS MICHELLE THOMAS SHOT ALAMEDA
COUNTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S
OFFICE IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ARRIVE ONE
FORTY TO PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
LIEUTENANT WILLIAM CAMERINO
TERRACE REPRESENTING SHERIFF
MCMAHON WILL DEPART. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I'M GOING TO FIND
PLEASE GO AHEAD. AND YOUR
EMPLOYEE ON BEHALF OF THE
INTERNET ASSOCIATION. PLEASE TO
SUPPORT WRITER. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I AM ONE FIFTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE ONE ONE
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. BYE THANK
YOU MY NAME IS WHERE IS THE
RESIDENT. CONTRA COSTA COUNTY
AND I GREW. THANK YOU FINAL
VOTE ALL FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
KEYSTONE IS THE DISTRICT
ATTORNEY KINGS COUNTY WE TO
HAVE THREE PRESENT I FELT
INORDINATELY IMPACT AND URGE
THE COMMITTEE TO SUPPORT. THE
BILL. THANK YOU THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT ONE TWENTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ONE ONE TWO NINE THREE
FOUR HAS. LET ME. YES PLEASE
CALL HELLO MY THROUGH MY BAD
SORRY- MY NAME IS DABNEY FROM
SAN FRANCISCO- AND I'M CALLING
AT THE PORT OF SB EIGHTY TO.
EIGHTY NINE. YOU'RE RIGHT
NINETY THREE FISCAL ASK. BOB
FOR MULTIPLE- LEVEL I AM ON THE
BOARD OF THE- FROM. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I HAVE NO FURTHER
WIND Q. CAN YOU CHECK ONE MORE
TIME S. IS THERE ANY ADDITIONAL
CALLERS IN SUPPORT OF SB.
THIRTY NINE. THANK YOU IF YOU
WISH TO COMMENT IN SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
APPETITE. I HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENT THANK YOU AT THIS TIME
THANK YOU MODERATOR. NOW I
HAVEN'T HEARD FROM ALL THE
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT ARE THERE
NOW WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION SB.
THIRTY NINE. CAN YOU Q. THOSE
CALLS IN OPPOSITION ARE WHAT
FIRST BEFORE WE GO TO THOSE
CALLS IN OPPOSITION ARE GO TO
THE CHAMBER HERE AND A ROOM
FORTY TWO ALL THREE I SEE NO
WITNESSES AND OPPOSITION. OF SB
THIRTY NINE. CAN WE NOW GO TO
ROOM TWENTY FORTY. FOR
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. I SEE
NO WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. IN
ROOM TWENTY FORTY OKAY NOW WILL
MOVE TO THOSE WITNESSES ARE VIA
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
MODERATOR CAN YOU Q. THE CALLS
FOR OR WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
OF SB. THIRTY NINE. THANK YOU
IF YOU WISH TO MAKE A COMMENT
IN OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE
DO HAVE ONE IN HERE ONE MOMENT.
FIND ONE FIFTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YES THIS IS GREGORY HOTEL WITH
MISTER JUSTICE IN OPPOSITION
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. BY ONE
TWENTY. PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON DENICO DHAMAAN BEHALF
SAN FRANCISCO PUBLIC DEFENDER'S
OFFICE IN OPPOSITION. THANK YOU.
LET ME BACK UP FOR ME AND I
APOLOGIZE TO WE HAVE KATIE
DIXON WHO'S A PRIMARY WITNESS
IN OPPOSITION MODERATORS. THIS
KATIE DIXON TO AVAILABLE
TESTIFY. YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YES
I AM- ONLINE I APOLOGIZE. WHEN
YOU'RE PREPARED MISTER GENERAL
YOU'RE RAMPART THANK YOU SO
MUCH YEAH COMMITTEE MEMBERS OF
MY. MY NAME IS K. I'M A
COMMUNITY ORGANIZER PART. I'M
PROFIT THAT ADVOCATE. WORKERS
UNFORTUNATELY I HAVE TO HOLD.
ARE THEY BREAKING BOTTOM UNDER
PARTLY OPERATIONAL. I MEAN A
MONTH CURRENTLY TALK ABOUT.
COOPER BASIN PRODUCT ABSOLUTELY
HERE GOING HERE IT REPRESENTS
THE PROBLEM HERE FOR ME ONLY.
FOUR WHEELS AND ENGINE. THANKS
FOR MY YOUNG ALREADY KALRA
KEEPING ON WITH NO LOOK INTO
PLAN. IT WILL COME BEEN A- FOR
ALL BOB PART CALIFORNIA. NEED
TO RETHINK THAT THE PROBLEM
LARGE AND- UNEMPLOYMENT
EXISTENCE. EDT ITSELF AT EIGHT
O'CLOCK. ALL RETAINING ONE YOU
WAIT FOR A DDD HAS ALSO THAT
ITS OWN OUT. LEFT IN. TO
VARIOUS SETS OF BAD ACTORS TO
IT IT. WE HAD AND CHLOE. THE
REQUESTED FUNDING NET. IF YOU
LIKE KERN WITH. ARAU AT HAND-
RENDON FIVE. IT COMMONLY KNOWN
AS THE STATE CRIMINAL RECORDS
INCLUDING EIGHT. BAYTODAY THAT
MIGHT ACT. EXCLUDING SAME
AIRPORT. THE COMMISSION MISSING
AND- COMPLETE. WELL ACCORDING
TO A I'VE BEEN SAYING BOB EVER
PROJECT BUT I'M TRYING ALL OF
THE BIGELOW AT. YEAH. ALL OF
THE REC REC ARE MISSING IF THEY
CAN'T. THEY NEED TO BE
AGGRESSIVE OR ALLOW BURKE
BECAME AN- WE'RE GOING. AT A
PERFORMING. KNOW THAT WE ARE.
WHAT WE SUFFER UNITY AND AMITY
BRING. WELL ARE OTHER CALL IT
BY AT YEAH. IT WILL DOWN FUNNY
WE BE WELL I PROBABLY LEAD TO
THE WALL WITH THE KNIFE OF THE-
ALREADY BOTTLED. THANK RESPECT
OKAY DOWNTOWN. THANK THANK YOU.
MODERATOR WILL MOVE TO- CALL IN
Q. AND OP OF S. B. NINE ARE
THERE A CALL IN OP OF US
THIRTY. THANK YOU ISSUE A LIKE
TO MAKE COMMENT OPTED PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AND WE'RE TO ONE FIFTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE FIVE
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. I HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENT THANK YOU AT
THIS TIME THERE'S NO FURTHER
CALLS IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME
MODERATOR. CORRECT OPPOSITION
OKAY THANK YOU. BY YOU SEE NO
FURTHER. CALLERS IN Q. AND
OPPOSITION I BRING IT BACK TO
THE CAN A COMMITTEE ARE THERE
ANY QUESTIONS BY THE COMMITTEE
CENTER WINNER. VETERANS AFFAIRS
A QUESTION THE AUTHOR AYE AYE
CORRECT ME IF I'M IS HEARD YOU
BEFORE. I THINK I HEARD YOU SAY
THAT THERE WERE DEATH ROW
INMATES THAT WERE APPLYING. FOR
IT PERCENT THAT SAID I DID I
HEAR THAT CORRECTLY YES BASED
ON THE EDT REPORT IN THE
DISTRIBUTORS REPORT THEIR DEATH
ROW INMATES LIKE SCOTT PETERSON
THAT WERE OF RUNNING FOR
MINUTES AND NOT ONLY JUST
APPLIED SIR BUT RECEIVED
BENEFITS OUT. MY UNDERSTANDING
WAS THAT. IT WASN'T NECESSARILY
DOES OR WASN'T DOES THE CONDUCT
PRO BUT WHAT I'VE SEEN AS IT
WAS IN THOSE. INMATES ON DEATH
ROW GOT APPROVED PEOPLE
FRAUDULENTLY APPLYING AND THEIR
NAMES ARE TO BE NO TO SCOTT
PETERSON HAS TO GET THE MONEY.
OR THE SOMEONE WHO PRESENT
BECAUSE ALSO SOMEONE WHO.
APPLIED IN CENTER FIND SCIENCE
AND. REYES SO WASN'T. I'M NOT.
SAYING THERE WAS FRAUD COMING
FOR PUT IN THE- BUT THERE WAS A-
PEOPLE WERE. IN PEOPLE'S. COULD
DO LIKE COMMENT ON THAT. YES SO
AND YOU ARE CORRECT THAT SOME
PEOPLE WERE APPLYING IN OTHER
PEOPLE'S NAMES OBVIOUSLY
SENATOR FEINSTEIN DID NOT APPLY
FOR BENEFITS. BUT A PRESENT OR
FORMER ACTUALLY STATE EMPLOYEE
DID APPLY. A WITH HER NAME IN
AND THEN OTHER PEOPLE USING
DIFFERENT SOCIAL SECURITY
NUMBERS. THE DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S ASSOCIATION THE
CALIFORNIA DISTRICT ATTORNEYS
ASSOCIATION AND SPECIFICALLY MY
DISTRICT ATTORNEY BECAUSE WE
HAVE. A LARGE NUMBER OF PRISONS
IN OUR COUNTY- HAVE- DEPLOYED
FORENSIC INDIVIDUALS TO MONITOR
PHONE CALLS- IN THE PRISON
SYSTEM S. SO THAT THEY COULD
IDENTIFY. A PEOPLE THAT WERE
TALKING ABOUT THESE EDT
BENEFITS AND THEY'VE AND
COVERED A TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF
FRAUD. AND THE TOTAL NUMBER
FRAUD DOLLARS AFFRONT IS GONNA
ESTIMATED AT THIRTY ONE BILLION
DOLLARS. IN KERN COUNTY I
BELIEVE IT'S AT TWO ELEVEN
BILLION. RIGHT I TOTALLY AGREE
WITH A LOT OF FRAUD GOING ON
AND WE CAN GET A WHOLE SEPARATE
CONVERSATION ABOUT YOU D. G.
AND ITS FAILURES WHICH ARE YOUR
AND MY STAFF PROPOSED BY
DEALING WITH. EVERYDAY SINCE
THE PANDEMIC. BEGAN ITS
ANNOYING ON A LOT OF PEOPLE GET
HARMED. BY NOT GETTING
BENEFITS. BUT IN TERMS OF THE
DEATH ROW INMATE'S. CARI CENTER
PARK DEATH ROW INMATES ARE
RECEIVED AS OPPOSED TO HAVING
OTHER PEOPLE FLY IN THEIR
NAMES. BECAUSE THIS WAS MY
UNDERSTANDING IT'S POSSIBLE I'M
WRONG. SO IT IS POSSIBLE THAT
THERE ARE AND IT IS POSSIBLE I
DON'T HAVE THE EXACT NUMBER OF
INMATES THAT D. ON DEATH ROW IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA THAT
DID RECEIVE THE BENEFITS ON
THEIR BEHALF- BUT I DO HAVE
SOME OF THE NAMES THAT WERE
FILED AND I DID NOT. SEE I DID
NOT GO AND DO THE RESEARCH TO
FIND OUT IF THEY ACTUALLY DID
RECEIVE THE BENEFITS AND THEIR
FAMILIES RECEIVE THE BENEFITS.
OR IF THEY SOMEONE JUST FILED
IN THEIR NAME. I DID THAT I
MADE AN ASSUMPTION WITH SENATOR
DIANNE FEINSTEIN THAT IT'S NOT
LIKELY. THAT SENATOR FEINSTEIN
WOULD FOUGHT FILED FOR THESE
BENEFITS AND THAT WAS PROVEN
LATER ON THAT. THAT AN EMPLOYEE
DID SO I DID I APOLOGIZE TO IN
HAVE AN ANSWER FOR YOU. WHAT I
CAN'T IS THAT. THE INDEPENDENT
AUDITOR TO DOING TO. AND FOUND
THAT THERE IS ABOUT THIRTY ONE
BILLION DOLLARS IN FRAUD. IN
THE PRISON SYSTEM THAT WAS
FRAUDULENT ACCUMULATED OR
RETAINED BY. INDIVIDUALS IN THE
PRISON SYSTEM WITH EDT AND IT
IS. THIRTY ONE BILLION CHAU I
THOUGHT THIRTY ONE BILLION WAS
THE GLOBAL NUMBER TOLERATE
STILL I'VE NEVER. THE TOTAL
NUMBER AND A LARGE PERCENTAGE
OF THAT CAME FROM THE PRISON
SYSTEM. AND THAT'S WHY A SIMPLE
SOLUTION THAT THE AUDITOR
RECOMMENDED WOULD BE SB THIRTY
NINE WHICH. THAT'S OKAY WHAT DO
YOU DO WE KNOW WHAT PERCENTAGE
OF THE STATE OF THE AND I AM
THIRTY ONE BILLION WAS ALSO. I
KNOW THERE WAS A RANGE WE STILL
DON'T KNOW THE EXACT NUMBER
BUT- LET'S ASSUME IT WAS A
THIRTY ONE BILLION- DO WE KNOW
WHAT PERCENTAGE OF THAT WAS
RELATED TO. PEOPLE APPLICATIONS
EITHER BY OR ON BEHALF OF
PEOPLE IN THE PRISON SYSTEM NO
I JUST KNOW THAT THE AUDITOR
HAD RECOMMENDED THIS THIS
MEASURE TO TAKE PLACE TO
ELIMINATE THAT FRAUD FROM
HAPPENING. AND I THINK IT'S
BECAUSE US AS LEGISLATORS AND
IN. INDIVIDUALS AND CONTROL OF
TAXPAYER DOLLARS THAT WE DO
EVERYTHING WE CAN TO PREVENT
FRAUD WITHIN THE SYSTEM. IS
JUST ONE MEASURE ABSOLUTELY BUT
I'M TRYING TO FIGURE OUT IN
TERMS OF. WITH THIS LIKE A BIG
PART OF THE PROBLEM OR A SMALL
PART OF THE PROBLEM. SO I DON'T
KNOW I'D BE GLAD TO GET THAT
INFORMATION BACK TO YOU AND I
DO APOLOGIZE I DON'T HAVE THE
ANSWER FOR THAT FOR YOU.
LECTURE MIGHT HAVE A RESPONSE
TO YOUR QUESTION A SENATOR
WARNER IF YOU'RE- HOW MUCH OF
THIS ANSWERS YOUR QUESTION BUT
I BELIEVE HERE IT STATES THAT.
WHILE THE EXACT TOTALS BY KNOWN
OR UNKNOWN IN MAY TO STATE
PRISONS ALONE HAVE BEEN
ESTIMATED TO COMPRISE AT LEAST
FOUR HUNDRED MILLION. IS THAT
YOUR- OF THE THIRTY OF THE
THIRTY ONE BILLION I THINK
THAT'S A COMMITTEE ANALYSIS SIR
YES YEAH THAT WOULD BE ABOUT
ONE LITTLE OVER 1% IS A TALKER.
AND I APPRECIATE YOUR
QUESTIONS- FOUR HUNDRED MILLION
IS STILL FOUR HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS IT'S A TREMENDOUS
AMOUNT OF MONEY. INTERCOM WATER.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I AM.
ALSO HAD SIMILAR QUESTIONS I
KNOW IN THE AUDIT REPORT THAT
WE LOOKED AT MY UNDERSTANDING
WAS THAT THE THEM. LARGE END OF
THAT NUMBER THIRTY ONE BILLION
WAS THE GLOBAL AMOUNT OF FRAUD
NOT NECESSARILY THE FRAUD
COMMITTED BY INCARCERATED
PERSONS AND I TOO WAS CURIOUS-
IF YOU HAD DATA- THAT SHOWS THE
AMOUNT OF MONEY THAT
INCARCERATED PERSONS RECEIVED
WHO WERE INTENTIONALLY-
COMMITTING THE FRAUD VERSES THE
AMOUNT OF MONEY. THAT WAS-
FRAUDULENTLY COLLECTED BY FOLKS
USING THE IDENTITY OF
INCARCERATED PERSONS- TO
RECEIVE BENEFITS BECAUSE I
THINK THERE'S A DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN FOLKS WHO ARE
INCARCERATED WHO ARE ACTIVELY
ENGAGED IN DEFRAUDING THE
SYSTEM AND THEN THOSE THAT ARE
ALSO VICTIMS OF IDENTITY THEFT.
SO I AGREE I AM I CAN JUST TELL
YOU- MESCAL MARKET THAT I
SENATOR CALAMARI DEBT AM I JUST
BASE THIS PIECE OF LEGISLATION
ON THE AUDITOR'S
RECOMMENDATIONS AND THE
RECOMMENDATION FROM THE
INDEPENDENT AUDITOR WAS TO
CROSS REFERENCE- LIKE MOST
STATES IN THE STATE IN THE
NATION ONLY FIFTEEN STATES
DON'T INCLUDING CALIFORNIA
DON'T CROSS REFERENCE. THERE SO
SECURITY NUMBERS- NGUYEN ET D.
PAYMENTS ARE ARE GIVEN TO THOSE
THAT ARE INCARCERATED AND SO I
DID IS I TOOK THIS BE SOLUTION
LEGISLATION BASED ON THE
AUDITOR'S RECOMMENDATIONS WE IS
AN INDEPENDENT AUDITOR THAT
MADE THE RECOMMENDATION TO DO A
PIECE LEGISLATION TO PREVENT
FRAUD. HAS HAS EIGHTY D. GIVEN
YOU ANY INDICATION ABOUT THEIR
ABILITY TO. ACCOMPLISH THIS
GIVEN THEIR CURRENT CHALLENGES.
M. NOBLE ET DE AT ONE OF THE
KEY CHALLENGES THAT WE THAT-
THAT WAS ADDRESSED WAS IT WOULD
BE DIFFICULT TO DO IT AT A
LOCAL COUNTY JAILS AND SO
THAT'S WHY WE TOOK THE
COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS TO ONLY
DO AT THE STATE LEVEL AT THIS
AT THIS TIME. AND LIKE I SAID
WE'RE JUST ONE OF FIFTEEN
STATES THAT HAVE IMPLEMENTED
THIS AND IT WOULD PREVENT A
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF FRAUD
WHETHER FOUR HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS AS THE ESTIMATE IS. IS
MINIMAL TO SOME PEOPLE OR
SIGNIFICANT. AND THEN MY FINAL
QUESTION MISTER CHAIR HAS THE-
ACCEPTED. AMENDMENTS REMOVED
OPPOSITION FROM INITIATE
JUSTICE LEGAL AID AT WORK I
HEARD THE PUBLIC DEFENDER'S
OFFICE ON THE PHONE BUT HAS IT
REMOVED THE OTHER OPPOSITION DO
WE KNOW. SO NOT THAT I KNOW OF
NO ONE IS CONTACTED MY OFFICE
TO REMOVE THAT OPPOSITION- AND
AGAIN. IN AN IN THE REAL WORLD
I GUESS I WOULD SAY IS HOW
EXPLAIN IT I'M A BUSINESS OWNER
AND- WE EMPLOYEE. 40% OF THE
PEOPLE THAT WE EMPLOYER SECOND
CHANCER IS WHAT WE CALL SECOND
CHANCE THERE'S THOSE THAT HAVE
BEEN INCARCERATED AND WANT TO
COME OUT AND HAVE A BETTER
LIFE. AND WE'VE HAD A LOT OF
THOSE PEOPLE COME UP HERE AND
TESTIFY AND CERTAIN BILLS SO
THIS ISN'T AN ATTACK ON PEOPLE
THAT- AND- ARE. IN THE SYSTEM
OR THAT ARE TRYING TO GET OUT
OF THE SYSTEM AND HAVE BENEFITS
AFTER THEY GET OUT WHEN THEY
BEEN GAINFULLY EMPLOYED. THIS
IS JUST A MECHANISM TO TRY TO
LIMIT THE FRAUD BECAUSE THIS
FRAUD THAT IS BIGGER THAN WILL
BE SUSTAINED BACK IN TWO
THOUSAND AND EIGHT IS GONNA
FONG ON THE BACKS OF A LOT OF
OUR SMALL BUSINESSES AND ARE
BUSINESS OWNERS. THAT HAVE BEEN
STRUGGLING TO THE PANDEMIC
BECAUSE IT'S 1100% EMPLOYER
FUNDED SO THE MORE FRAUD THAT
WE CAN ADDRESS TO REDUCE THAT
THE BETTER. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS BY COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
PICTURE BOOK HERBAL CONCERNED
THANK YOU AS CHAIR STRATFORD I
AM JUST REALLY QUICK IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING AND JUST RECEIVED
SOME CLARIFICATIONS ABOUT FOUR
HUNDRED MILLION WAS ACTUALLY AT
AN ESTIMATE BACK IN NOVEMBER
DECEMBER SO MIGHT BE A LITTLE
HIGHER NOW- IN THE OTHER NOTE-
THAT WAS I THOUGHT WAS
INTERESTING WAS THAT AT THIRTY
FIVE STATES ALREADY CROSSMATCH.
NORI PRACTICES- IN IN THEIR OWN
STATE SO I ACTUALLY- I'M
GRATEFUL THAT SENATOR GRAHAM
HAS TAKEN THE INITIATIVE IN
BRING IT IS FOR THE- AND
ANYTIME WE HAVE ANY STATE
AGENCY WHERE WE SEE A LOSS OF
TAXPAYER MONEY WE SHOULD BE
PROACTIVE IN ADDRESSING THE
ISSUE ESPECIALLY IN THIS CASE
WILL HAVE MANY FAMILIES WHO ARE
NOT GETTING THE BENEFITS THAT
THEY NEED AND RIGHT NOW
ESPECIALLY WITH THE- AS-
DOWNTURN IN OUR ECONOMY AND
ACCEPT. YEARS IT'S BE US AND
IT'S OUR RESPONSIBILITY TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE PROTECT OUR
TAXPAYERS IT IS WITH THAT- WITH
THAT NOTION AND UNDERSTANDING
THAT I AM PROUD I'M A PROUD CO
AUTHOR OF THIS BILL. AND I
MOVED THE MOTION WHEN AT THE
TIME IS APPROPRIATE. YOU CINA
MORE QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS BY
THE COMMITTEE SENATOR GROW WHAT
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE JUST
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
SIR THANK YOU AND I WOULD JUST
LIKE THAT IT'S NO DOUBT THAT WE
NEED TO ADDRESS- FRAUGHT. ANY
LEVEL THAT HAS TAKEN PLACE OVER
THE LAST YEAR WITH EDT BUT I
TOO AM CONCERNED WITH- JUST
BECAUSE IT'S AN MH NAME DOESN'T
MEAN HERE SHE ACTUALLY ACTUALLY
PARTICIPATED BECAUSE THEY TOO
FELL VICTIM OF IDENTITY THEFT
SO I APPRECIATE YOU TAKING THE
AMENDMENTS THAT WILL NARAL THIS
BILL DOWN AND LEAVE IT TO OUR
STATE PRISONS AND NOT AS MUCH
TORQUE COUNTY JAIL POPULATION
AND I DO UNDERSTAND YOU HAVE
ACCEPTED AMENDMENTS YES SIR WE
HAVE A MOTION IT TO PASS AND IT
WILL BE REFERRED TO REFERRED
TO. THE COMMITTEE ON LABOR- IF
THAT IS THE MOTION WE ARE WILL
NOT I MEAN WE DO HAVE A MOTION
AND- MEMBERS SELL PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. SB THIRTY NINE TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO LABOR PUBLIC
EMPLOYMENT RETIREMENT BRADFORD
ON RED FOR DIET CHAU BOGUE I
HAVE A GUY COME LONGER. NOT
VOTING COMMON UP VOTING SKINNER
WIENER. FIFTY TWO VOTES DESPITE
MEASURE AS TO VOTES WILL LEAVE
IT ON CALL FOR THE ABSENT
MEMBERS THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
THANK YOU HAJDUK'S UP WE HAVE
SENATOR RUBIO WITH S. B. TWENTY
THREE AND BEFORE WE GET TO
CENTER RUBRIC RUBIO I WOULD
JUST WANNA MAKE AN OPTION FOR
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
CALLING AND- MAKE SURE YOUR
DEVICES ARE MUTED- THAT YOU'RE
LISTENING TO- THE HEARING ON
BECAUSE WE'VE BEEN HAVING
TERRIBLE FEEDBACK. AS IT
RELATES TO BEING ABLE TO HEAR
YOU SO- WHEN IT'S YOUR TURN AND
PLEASE MUTE YOUR DEVICE THAT
YOU'RE LISTENING TO THE HEARING
ON. CENTER RUBIO WHEN YOU'RE
READY WE'RE ALL HERE S. B.
TWENTY THREE. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE. TODAY BEFORE I
BEGIN I WANTED TO FIRST OF ALL
THANK YOU- CHAIR BRADFORD AND
THE COMMITTEE FOR WORKING SOLD
DILIGENT MEET WITH ME TO TRY TO
COME TO. AN AGREEMENT SO I WILL
BE ACCEPTING OF THE AMENDMENTS
OFFERED TODAY I'M HONORED TO
PRESENT SB TWENTY THREE WHICH
IS AN IMPORTANT BALLOT THAT
WOULD STRENGTHEN PROTECTIONS
FOR VICTIMS OF REVENGE PORN. SB
TWENTY THREE CHANGES THE
STATUTE OF LIMITATIONS FOR
REVENGE PORN SO THAT VICTIMS
POP CAN TO SEEK JUSTICE DOESN'T
START UNTIL AFTER THEY
DISCOVERED THE PRINT THAT THE
PRIVATE IMAGES HAVE BEEN CAUGHT
I'M SORRY THEY'VE GONE PUBLIC.
THIS STRAIGHTFORWARD APPROACH
IS NEEDED BECAUSE THE CURRENT
STATUTE OF LIMITATIONS STARTS
THE CLOCK AS SOON AS THE
PERPETRATOR MAKES THE IMAGES
PUBLIC AND- FAR TOO OFTEN THE
VICTIMS DON'T GET TO SEE THAT
OR FIND OUT THAT IT'S
CIRCULATING TWO YEARS LATER.
AND WHAT HAPPENS AT TIMES NOT
ONLY OUR CAREER OPPORTUNITIES
RENT BUT ALSO FAMILY
RELATIONSHIPS THIS HAPPENED
RECENTLY TO A VICTIM AND TULARE
COUNTY WHEN PROSECUTORS WERE
UNABLE TO HELP HER BECAUSE HER
PHOTO HAPPENS SHARED LONG
BEFORE SHE DISCOVERED THE
VIOLATION. AND THE STATUTE OF
LIMITATION EXPIRES BEFORE
EXPIRED. BEFORE SHE COULD SEEK
JUSTICE. AS EARLIER REVENGE
PORN HOW DAVIS LONG LASTING
EFFECTS ON ON VICTIMS. AND
SOMETIMES IT'S PERSONAL AND
SOMETIMES IT'S PROFESSIONAL.
NONETHELESS WE WANT TO BE ABLE
TO HELP SUPPORT THESE VICTIMS
AND ENSURE THAT THEY GET THAT
THEY GET THE JUSTICE THEY
DESERVE. SO THANKFULLY THERE
IS. WIDESPREAD SUPPORT FOR THIS
ISSUE. AND SO TODAY I AM
HONORED TO IT TO HAVE SOME
FOLKS TO TESTIFY ON THIS
MEASURE. BUT BEFORE I DO I
WANTED TO SHARE THAT OTHER CO
SPONSORS ARE MARCH AGAINST
REVENGE PORN. AND IT'S ALSO
SUPPORTED BY A DIVERSE
COALITION INCLUDING VICTIMS
ORGANIZATIONS LAW ENFORCEMENT
GROUPS AND THE INTERNET
ASSOCIATION. IF I MAY I WOULD
LIKE TO INTRODUCE MY GUEST
SPEAKER HERE TODAY TULARE
COUNTY DEPUTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY
ERICA GONZALEZ. WHICH AND ALSO
MARCH AGAINST REVENGE PORN
FOUNDER AND EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
HE LEAH JULIETT THANK YOU.
THANK WERE GOING TO ALLOW TWO
MINUTES FOR THE BOTH THE
PRIMARY WITNESSES- MADAM JUST
TURNING WHEN YOU'RE READY YOU
MAY BEGIN YOUR TESTIMONY. THANK
YOU A GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRED BY
CHAIRED MEMBERS. MY NAME IS
ERICA GONZALEZ I AM A
SUPERVISING DEPUTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY WITH THE TULARE COUNTY
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S OFFICE
COSPONSORED SB TWENTY THREE.
THIS BILL MAKES IT COMMONSENSE
CHANGES TO THE CURRENT LAW AND
WOULD GIVE VICTIMS OF REVENGE
PORN MORE TIME TO SEEK JUSTICE
AGAINST THOSE WHO VIOLATE THEIR
PRIVACY. UNDER EXISTING LAW THE
CRIME OF REVENGE PORN MUST BE
PROSECUTED WITHIN ONE YEAR FROM
THE DATE THAT THE IMAGE WAS
DISTRIBUTED HOWEVER SIMILAR
BASED OF CRIME SUCH AS WHEN A
PERSON USES A CONCEALED CAMERA
TO PHOTOGRAPH ANOTHER PERSON
WITHOUT THEIR KNOWLEDGE OR
CONSENT TO CAN BE PROSECUTED
WITHIN ONE YEAR FROM THE DATE.
OF DISCOVERY. RECENTLY AND
TULARE COUNTY A HIGH SCHOOL
TEACHER DISCOVERED THAT SOMEONE
SHE DATED PRIOR TO STARTING HER
CAREER AT THE TEACHERS TO
GREATLY POSTED PRIVATE PHOTOS
OF HER ON THE INTERNET. SHE DID
NOT DISCOVER THIS UNTIL THREE
YEARS AFTER HE HAD POSTED THE
PHOTOS. AND ACT HE ADMITTED TO
DOING DURING THE INVESTIGATION.
THE INDIVIDUAL WHO POSTED THE
PHOTOS WAS EMPLOYED IN A
POSITION OF TRUST AND
UNFORTUNATELY BECAUSE OF
EXISTING LAW. OUR OFFICE COULD
NOT PROSECUTE HIM FOR THE CRIME
HE COMMITTED. THE VICTIM WAS
NOT ABLE TO SEEK JUSTICE
AGAINST THE PERSON WHO VIOLATED
HER PRIVACY. SHE LIVES IN FEAR
THAT OUR STUDENTS SCHOOL ONE
DAY DISCOVER THE PHOTOS SHE'S
AFRAID OF THE CONSEQUENCES OF
HIS ACTIONS AND HER NAME BEING
REVEALED. SHE WANTED TO
PERSONALLY ADDRESSED THE
COMMITTEE TODAY BUT WAS UNABLE
TO DO SO BECAUSE SHE COULD NOT
GIVE HER STATEMENT ANONYMOUSLY.
UNDER EXISTING LAW WE ARE ABLE
TO FILE A CASE WITH THE VICTIMS.
INITIALS TO PROTECT THEIR
PRIVACY. THIS MAKES A TECHNICAL
CHANGE THAT ALLOWS A CRIME OF
REVENGE PORN TO BE PROSECUTED
FROM THE DATE OF DISCOVERY
pTHIS CRIME. THE MILLER TO OTHER
INTENTIONAL VIOLATION OF
PRIVACY CRIMES. ON BEHALF OF
THE TULARE COUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE WE ASK THAT
YOU STAND WITH VICTIMS OF
REVENGE PORN AND SUPPORT THIS
BILL. THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. LEAH JULIETT HELLO MY
NAME IS JULIA JULIE ACT I AM
THE FOUNDER AND EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF MARCH AGAINST
REVENGE PORN WHEN I WAS A YOUNG
TEENAGER FOR NUDE PHOTOS OF
MEANING IT WILL CULTURE ON THE
INTERNET AND CIRCULATED AROUND
THE WORLD WITHOUT MY CONSENT.
RIGHT HIGH SCHOOL I BECAME
DEEPLY AWARE OF THE IMPACT OF
PUBLIC SHAMING. AND HUMILIATION
BUT AT THE TIME I DID NOT KNOW
THAT WHAT'S HAPPENING TO ME
WITH THE CRIME. POLITICALLY TO.
AND SUICIDAL I TOLD NO ONE WHAT
WAS HAPPENING TO ME OUT OF THE
MEN'S FEAR AND SHAME. BUY PHOTO
CIRCULATED ON THE AFTER FIVE
YEARS BEFORE I HAD THE
KNOWLEDGE RESOURCES AND COURAGE
TO SPEAK UP AND TELL MY STORY.
BY THE TIME I BROKE UP WITH MY
STATUTE OF LIMITATIONS HE
DIDN'T AND I HAD NO MEANS OF
GETTING JUSTICE FOR HOLDING THE
MAN WHO A GOVERNMENT. ACCOUNT.
I TRIED TO ACT. AND FOUNDED
AGAINST. CORN AND THAT MEANS OF
DEALING MYSELF. NOW THERE ARE
WORK. WE HOPE THAT AND THINK
YOU KNOW EVERY DAY. BILL MAKE
SURE THAT NOPE CAN GO WITHOUT
THAT AND BY DID. A LOT IN THE
CONFINES OF THE INTERNET AND-
OF FEAR. WITHIN CORN IS AN
AWFUL TRAUMATIZING CRIME AND
THAT MANY. PREVENT THEM FROM OR-
EXPENSE THE TAX OF LIMITATIONS
WILLING ACROSS. JUSTICE VICTIM
OF THE FIGHT MAKE SURE THAT
REVENGE PORN SB SIX ABUSE ANTI
CORRECT. OR THING OF THE- THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBER.
NINE THANK YOU. NOW WE MOVE
BACK TO THE ROOM FORTY TWO-
THREE WE ARE. AND SEE IF
THERE'S ANY MEMBERS. HERE IN
THE OR IN THE GALLERY WISHING
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. OF AS
TWENTY THREE. SCENE NINE WILL
MOVE TO NOW ROOM. FORTY AND
IT'S NOT NOTICING ANY WITNESSES
THERE AND SUPPORT OF. SB TWENTY
THREE. MODERATOR CAN WE GO TO
THE PHONE LINES AND SEE IF
THERE ARE WITNESSES IN Q.
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF S. B. TWENTY THREE. THANK
YOU IF YOU WISH TO MAKE A
COMMENT IN SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
EVERLANE ONE FIFTY SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU SHARE
MEMBERS DOLLARS TOWARD THREAT
CRITICS BEING ON BEHALF OF WE
TO HELP SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK
YOU ARE YOU CAN TELL US THE
NUMBER OF CALLS YOU HAVE QUEUED.
THANK YOU I CURRENTLY HAVE
SEVEN Q. THANK YOU NEXT CALL.
VITAL PLAN THIRTY THREE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. SURE MEMBERS LUNCHEON
I SURE FOR PATIENTS SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MEXICO THANK YOU
RIGHT WHEN SHE FOR PLEASE CALL
AHEAD. NINE ONE SIX FOUR FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE ONE FIFTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. I DON'T
OPEN UP THE INTERNET
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF THE
S. B. TWENTY. THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT ONE SIXTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON SHERRY
MICHELLE FROM THE SHOP THAN THE
ALLEN COUNTY ATTORNEY'S OFFICE
AND THE CALIFORNIA ATTORNEYS
ASSOCIATION WE ARE PROUD CO
SPONSORS AT THE TWENTY THREE
AND EARNED YOUR SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT ONE NINETY SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MISTER MEMBERS CORY
STOSSEL ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU LINE
ONE FIFTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ONE ONE FIVE FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. JUST AS A REMINDER IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT
THIS TIME AND WE'RE TRYING TO
ALL FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. YOUR
TURN MEMBERS WILL BE A POLICE
ON BEHALF OF THE CITY AND
COUNTY OF SAN FRANCISCO IN THE
OFFICE MAYOR PRE. RECORD THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. I HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENT THANK YOU AT
THIS TIME. MY RELIGIOUS MIND
CHECKING MAKING AN OUNCE TO ONE
MORE TIME TO SEE IF THERE'S ANY
ADDITIONAL CALLS THAT MIGHT BE
WILLING TO OUR INTERESTS AND
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT. OF SB
TWENTY THREE. THANK YOU IF YOU
WISH TO COMMENT IN SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. I CURRENTLY HAVE
NO COMMON THANK YOU AT THIS
TIME THANK YOU BALLOTS MOVED
OPPOSITION. WE HAVE A PRIMARY
WITNESS LESLIE CALDWELL HOUSTON-
MODERATORS. LET'S SEE HOUSTON
PREPARE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION OF SB. TWENTY THREE.
GOOD AFTERNOON OF THIS IS MARCO
GEORGE I'M SUBSTITUTING IN FOR
LESLIE CALDWELL TO STAND ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION WE WANT
TO THANK SENATOR RUBIO AND THE
COMMITTEE FOR THE AMENDMENTS
AND THAT THIS TIME WILL WITH
CRYING OUR OPPOSITION SO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU.
MONTEREY COUNCIL FLOOD FIRST
MOVED TO THE ROOM- HERE IN
FORTY TWO OH THREE DO WE HAVE
ANY WITNESSES HARRISON AND
TESTIFYING AND OPPOSITION OF
THIS THREE TWENTY THREE. SHE
NINE LET'S MOVE NOW TO ROOM
TWENTY FORTY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION OF S. B. TWENTY
THREE. ST NINE NOW WE WILL MOVE
THE MODERATOR TO OUR PHONE
LINES ARE THERE. CALLERS IN Q.
AND A RESIDENT TESTIFYING IN
OPPOSITION OF S. B. TWENTY
THREE. THANK YOU IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO MAKE A COMMON IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONCE
AGAIN FOR OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. TWO OF ONE EIGHT ZERO
JUST BE ONE MOMENT. THAT RYAN
DID DROP I HAD CURRENTLY HAVE
NO COMMENT THANK YOU AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU. I'M GOING TO
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS BYE
COMMITTEE SENATOR CALM WATER.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I HAVE A
FEW- SO I APPRECIATE THAT
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION. REMOVE THEIR
OPPOSITION- YEAH I'M NEW TO
THIS COMMITTEE- IS THAT THE
ONLY OPPOSITION THAT WAS LISTED.
IT WAS OKAY- CAN YOU CONFIRM
CENTER RUBIO THAT THIS OFFENSE
IS A MISDEMEANOR OR WOULD IT BE
A FELONY. I WILL HAVE MY- MY
GUESS ANSWER THE QUESTION THANK
YOU OKAY GREAT AND THEN THE
SECOND QUESTION WAS I KNOW THAT
THE ORIGINAL- LANGUAGE HAD
FIFTEEN YEARS- AND I WAS
WONDERING HOW THAT NUMBER WAS
DETERMINED. WELL IT WAS A JONI
TO DEPENDING ON SOME OF THE
CASES THAT WE HAD DONE
INTERVIEWED AND DISCUSS BY UP
BASED ON THE COMMITTEE'S
RECOMMENDATION WE DECIDED TO
GOAL BASED ON OTHER CRIMES MAKE
IT EQUITABLE TO OTHER SIMILAR
CRIMES HAVE STATED BY ONE OF
THE WITNESSES. AND SO THAT'S
WHERE THE SIX YEARS NOW COMES
FROM I WOULD A RECOMMENDATION
OF THE COMMITTEE OKAY AND THEN-
I APOLOGIZE MISTER CHAIR WHAT
CONSTITUTES THE DATE OF
DISCOVERY OF THE OFFENSE
BECAUSE I WAS CONFUSED IF IT
WAS. WHEN THE PHOTOS WERE TAKEN
OR WHEN THEY WERE RELEASED OR
WHEN THEY'RE SORT OF WHEN
THEY'VE GONE VIRAL AND I
DIDN'T- I. DIDN'T HAVE AN
ANSWER FOR THAT THANK YOU LAW
INITIALLY UP ONCE. CURRENTLY
RIGHT NOW WHEN THE PERPETRATOR
POST THE PICTURES ONLINE SOLD
THERE'S DOCUMENTATION ANALYSIS
DONE NOW WHEN THE VICTIM TO
COME FORWARD WHEN SHE DISCOVERS
HE OR SHE DISCOVERS THAT THEY
FOUND THE PICTURES ONLINE AND
CAN GO DIRECTLY TO. AND SO WHEN
IT'S WHEN THE VICTIM DOES
WHATEVER IS THE PICTURES ONLINE
DISCOVERS THE PHOTOS OR IMAGES
OR WHAT IMAGES CORRECT. AND
THEN MY FINAL QUESTION SORRY IS
DOES THIS INCLUDE ALL
CIRCUMSTANCES WERE IMAGERY FOR
LACK OF A BETTER WORD WAS
TAKEN- ARM. OR DOES THIS ALSO
INCLUDE CIRCUMSTANCES WHERE
IMAGES WERE TAKEN WITH THE
VICTIM'S CONSENT OR IS IT JUST
WHEN IMAGES WERE TAKEN WITHOUT
THAT PERSON'S KNOWLEDGE. IT'S
ANY IMAGE WITH CONSENT OR
WITHOUT CONSENT- AS WE KNOW IF
I MAY SHARE- YOU KNOW SOMETIMES
PEOPLE IN A RELATIONSHIP FOR IT
WHAT'S A PRIVATE MOMENT AND
LATER IT'S DONE WITH MALICIOUS
INTENT AND I WANTED TO SHARE A
LITTLE BIT FURTHER I MEAN THEIR
STUDIES THAT HAVE BEEN DONE
THAT SHOW THAT 50% OF THE
VICTIMS. HAVE SUICIDAL THOUGHTS
ON WHETHER IT'S CONSENT OR NOT
IT'S STILL EXTREMELY
TRAUMATIZING USUALLY AS I
BELIEVE WE HEARD FROM THE
WITNESS SHE WAS A TEENAGER AND
IT COULD HAVE LONG LASTING
EFFECTS ON PEOPLE THERE
SOMEONE'S DAUGHTER SOMEONE'S
MOTHER AND DEPENDING ON THE
TIME LINE AT SOMEONE'S
GRANDMOTHER'S CELL. EVEN WITH
CONSENT IT IS SOMETHING THAT
SHOULD NOT BE DONE AND VICTIMS
ARE REALLY STRUGGLING. AND
SUFFERING THE CONSEQUENCES OF
THAT TRAUMA. SO THEN IF. I FOR
EXAMPLE OF I'M IN A
RELATIONSHIP WITH SOMEONE AND
WE DID. YOU KNOW ENGAGED IN
SOME ACTIVITY WHERE WE'RE
TAKING PHOTOS- AND IF I SHARE
WITH CLOSE FRIENDS I CAN DO
THAT BUT THEN IF THE PARTNER
SHARES WITH FRIENDS. THE THEY
CAN'T DO THAT OR IT COULD BE
CONSIDERED WELL IN ADVANCE I AM
I MEAN I HEAR WHERE YOU'RE
YOU'RE GOING WITH THIS BUTIT'S
INTENDED TO REALLY PROTECT
THOSE PRIVATE MOMENTS THAT
PEOPLE HAVE WITH THEIR-
INTIMATE PARTNERS AND TYPICALLY
THOSE ARE THE ONES THAT HAVE
LONG LASTING EFFECTS ON. ON
INDIVIDUALS YOU KNOW EITHER AT
THE RELATIONSHIP ENDS OR THEY
FIND THAT THE FOUND ANY
RELATIONSHIP AND THAT'S WHAT'S
CALLED A REVENGE PORN IT'S
MEANT TO TAKE REVENGE AND READY
TO DAMAGE THE REPUTATION OF AN
INDIVIDUAL. I THINK CONSULTANT
KENNEDY WANTED TO ELABORATE ON.
THE I WAS JUST GOING TO HELP
CLARIFY THE IT IS UPON
DISCOVERY AND THEN THE MEMO WAS
DISCOVERY OR SIX YEARS AT THE
SEVEN YEARS AFTERWARDS. THEY
HAVE TO DO IT WITHIN ONE YEAR
OF DISCOVERY BRING ACTION
WITHIN ONE YEAR OF DISCOVERY.
AND THE DISCOVERY IS WHEN THE
PERSON REALIZE IT'S BEEN SHARED
WITHOUT PERMISSION. AND IN YOUR
SCENARIO WHERE THEY SHARE WITH
THEIR FRIENDS IF THE FRIEND
SHARED. THEN THAT WOULD BE
WITHOUT PERMISSION. SO YOU CAN
SHARE PICTURES OF YOURSELF WITH
SOMEONE BUT THEN ONCE THEY GO
BEYOND THAT IS ONE IT'S- THE
REVENGE PORN. BUT I SURE I CAN
DO THAT IF I SHARE WITH MY
FRIENDS AND THEY DO THAT THEY
CAN'T DO THAT IF I SHARE WITH
MY PARTNER AT THE TIME AND WE
CONSENT TO SHARE BUT THEN WE
BREAK UP AND THAT'S NOT
PARTNER SHARES THAN THAT WOULD
BE THE VIOLATION. THE
MISDEMEANOR THAT'S AT THE
EXISTING LINE MISTRESSES
CHANGING THE STATURE
LIMITATIONS. TWO ONE YEAR AFTER
DISCOVERY OR AT THE MAX SIX
YEARS THEIR DEFINITION. THAT
DEFINES AND DELINEATES WHAT
REVENGE IS AND HOW THAT'S
CONSTITUTED. I DON'T THINK
THERE HAS TO BE INTENT BEHIND
IT. I'M JUST ASKING BECAUSE YOU
KNOW WHAT I THREE SLOPE. AND
THEN YOU KNOW I DO I JUST LIKE
TO HAVE ADDITIONAL INFORMATION
WHEN WE'RE WINNING MOTION IS
INCLUDED. AND THIS IS JUST AN
EXTENSION OF EXISTING LAW
ALREADY BECAUSE THE LAW IS
ALREADY IN PLACE FOR ONE YEAR
SO IT'S TAKING THAT ONE YEAR
THAT'S ALREADY IN PLACE AND
JUST GIVING VICTIMS A LITTLE
BIT MORE TIME. SAME SITUATION
JUST LONGER BUT BASED ON THE
COMMITTEE'S RECOMMENDATION IT
CAN'T GO ON FOREVER THERE'S A
CAP IT SIX YEARS SELL LET'S SY
THE VICTIM CLAIMS TO HAVE FOUND
OUT SEVEN YEARS LATER. IT'S NO
LONGER APPLICABLES. IT'S
REFERRED TO AS REVENGE PORN BUT
THAT'S NOT REFERRED TO IN THE
STATUTE IT'S A PERSON
INTENTIONALLY DISTRIBUTES AN
IMAGE OF THE INTIMATE BODY
PARTS OF ANOTHER. OR THE PERSON
DEPICTED IN A SEX ACT UNDER
CIRCUMSTANCES IN WHICH THE
PERSON AGREED OR UNDERSTOOD
THAT THE IMAGE WOULD REMAIN
PRIVATE. AND THE PERSON KNOWING
KNOWINGLY DISTRIBUTED IT
KNOWING IT WAS SUPPOSED TO BE
PRIVATE. SEVEN IMAGES SHARE
WITH JUST A FRIEND OR JUST A
PARTNER THAT THEN GET SHARED
BEYOND THAT. K. CENTER TOLD
VOGUE. SENATOR REID THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR BRINGING THIS ISSUE
TO THE FOREFRONT AND HAVING
THESE DISCUSSIONS I APPRECIATE
THE EFFORT AS A MOTHER OF
DAUGHTERS AND A SON AND
UNDERSTANDING THEIR FRIENDS AND
THEIR ENVIRONMENT IN WHICH OUR
CHILDREN ARE GROWING UP IN-
SPECIALLY WITH SOCIAL MEDIA- I
IT'S IMPORTANT TO UNDERSTAND
WHAT THE LIMITS ARE SPECIALLY
WHEN THERE IS ILL INTENT AND
THAT IN THAT ENDEAVOR SO WITH
THAT IN MIND I WILL BE HAPPILY
SUPPORTING YOUR BILL. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I WANT TO BE CLEAR
THAT- THIS IS NOT ONLY APPLY TO
WOMEN APPLIES TO MEN AS WELL SO
WE CAN BE A SIGN OF FATHER OR
GRANDFATHER BECAUSE THAT'S
CORRECT IN YOUR PRESENTATION
YOU. JUST PREFER TO. FEMALE SO
JUST WANT TO BE CLEAR FOR THE
GENTLEMAN YOU'RE COVERED HERE
AS WELL. GOOD POINT SENATOR. AT
THANK YOU FOR THAT
CLARIFICATION YES- OKAY- THE
NOTE SENATOR RUBIO WHICH LIKE
TO CLOSE I HAVE WELL I'M SORRY
I'M SORRY CENTER SKINNER- FIVE
BYE BOTH APPRECIATE THE
EXPANSION OF THE TIME PERIOD
BUT I ALSO APPRECIATE THE
AMENDMENT BECAUSE I THINK THAT
THESE ARE- IT CAN BE DIFFICULT
TO PROVE ONCE TIME GETS OFF TO
MUCH PAST HOWEVER WITH SUCH A
SHORT PERIOD AS THE EXISTING
STATUTE WAS HAS INDICATED THE
TESTIMONY. YOU CAN ALSO NOT BE
ABLE TO- ACT ON IT IN THERE SO
MANY REASONS WHY YOU MAY NOT
DISCOVERED RIGHT AWAY OR YOU
MAY BE INTIMIDATED. BY THE
INDIVIDUAL OR ANY NUMBER OF
THINGS SO I THINK THAT WE'VE
REACHED A GOOD OF A MIDDLE
GROUND ON WHAT THE APPROPRIATE
YEARS ARE AND- I'M HAPPY TO
SUPPORT WITH THAT. THANK YOU.
NOW SENATOR RUBIO WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE ON S. B. TWENTY
THREE YES WELL FIRST OF ALL
THANK YOU FOR A FOR THIS
DISCUSSION I KNOW IT'S
IMPORTANT TO REALLY GET INTO
THAT WE CAN UNDERSTAND THE BILL
BUT- I JUST WANTED IT ALSO JUST
REITERATE THE BURDEN OF PROOF
IS STILL THERE YOU CAN'T JUST
MAKE ALLEGATIONS WE STILL HAVE
TO. TRUTHDIG OUR OUR CASE OR IN
THIS CASE THE VICTIM'S CASE-
AND I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
CONSIDERING THIS AND JUST
REALLY QUICK I'LL SHARE YOU
NOT. AS AND WHEN I WAS A
TEACHER AND I HAVE FIFTH
GRADERS AND- AND SOME OF OUR
CHILDREN ALREADY TAKING
INAPPROPRIATE PICTURES AND
CELL. I THINK THIS JUST HELPS.
YOU KNOW- INFORM THE DISCUSSION
AND HAVE A LARGER DISCUSSION
ABOUT. YOU KNOW IF WE CAN AVOID
IT AND MAKE SURE THAT. YOU KNOW
INDIVIDUALS AND ALL THAT WHAT
COULD HAPPEN I JUST THINK IT
ONLY HELPS AS IT MOVES FORWARD
WITH TECHNOLOGY BEING SO.
PREVALENT OUR CAMINO EVERYTHING
IS ONLINE SO WE JUST WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT IT'S- THAT WE
INFORM THE PUBLIC OF WHAT IT IS
AND WHAT CAN POTENTIALLY HAPPEN
SO I APPRECIATE YOUR TIME AND I
WANT TO THANK YOU. FOR YOUR
AMENDMENTS AND WITH THAT I ASK
FOR YOUR- VOTE THANK YOU. I
THINK YOU WERE LOOKING FOR A
MOTION IT SHOULD DO PASSED TO
BE. RE REFER TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE AND UNDERSTAND THAT
SENATOR RUBIO HAS TAKEN
AMENDMENTS. THE COMMITTEE
AMEND. THE MOVED. HAS BEEN
MOVED BY SENATOR CHOI BALK.
PLEASE CONSULT AND PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL ON TWENTY TWENTY THREE
AT THREE TWENTY THREE DO PASS
AS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
BRADFORD. BRADFORD AYE AND
CHOKE HI JOE BOAKAI COM LONGER.
A AYE SKINNER BY INNER AYE
WIENER. WIENER HI FIVE ZERO.
THROUGH THE MEASURES OUT FIVE
ZERO GRADUATIONS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU. NOW MOVING ON.
ALL. ZERO OTHER. SENATOR
SKINNER ARE YOU PREPARED TO
PRESENT. SB. EIGHTY ONE. YES.
30% WHEN YOU'RE READY WE ARE
ALREADY WONDERFUL. THANK YOU-
CHAIRED MEMBERS SB EIGHTY ONE-
I HAD THE GREAT PLEASURE OF
SERVING FOR THE LAST YEAR ON A
COMMITTEE THAT THE GOVERNOR
ESTABLISHED THE COMMITTEE ON
THE REVIEW OF CALIFORNIA'S
PENAL CODE AND CONDUCT
COMMITTEE WERE- A NUMBER OF
JUDGES. SOME LEGISLATORS- DEAN
OF CALIFORNIA WERE PREEMINENT
LAW SCHOOL THE UC IRVINE AND A
NUMBER OF OTHER- EXPERTS IN
ADVOCATES WITHIN OF THIS SPACE-
AND WE HELD A SERIES OF
MEETINGS OVER THE COURSE OF THE
YEAR WITH LOTS OF STAKEHOLDERS
AND WHAT WE WERE DOING IS
LOOKING AT CALIFORNIA'S PENAL
CODE IN THE LAST THIRTY THIRTY
FIVE YEARS HAS GROWN
TREMENDOUSLY WE HAVE A- NEW
CRIMES IN NEW CATEGORIES OF
CRIMES A NEW ALL KINDS OF
THINGS. FOR EVERYTHING UNDER
THE SUN AND THERE WAS THE SENSE
BY OUR FORMER GOVERNOR GOVERNOR
BROWN AND OTHERS THAT WE REALLY
NEEDED TO RE LOOK AT IT IN A
KIND OF COMPREHENSIVE WAY SO
THAT'S ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
WE WERE DOING. AND IN AN ISSUE
THAT CAME BEFORE US WAS THE
ISSUE OF WHAT'S CALLED SENTENCE
ENHANCEMENTS NOW SENSING
HANSON'S ARE NOT ELEMENTS OF A
BASIC CRIME. SO YOU COMMIT A
CRIME. SENATE HARASSMENT RATHER
OUR EDITION CIRCUMSTANCES THAT
A PROSECUTOR CAN ARGUE FOR. AND
THEN INCREASE THE PENALTY THAT
THE PERSON WHO. WOULD BE IN BE
ADDED TO THE PENALTY THAT IS
ASSOCIATED WITH THE UNDERLYING
CRIME. CURRENTLY IN
CALIFORNIA'S PENAL CODE THERE
ARE OVER A HUNDRED AND FIFTY
ENHANCEMENTS. AND OVER 80% OF
THE PEOPLE CURRENTLY SERVING IN
OUR STATE PRISONS ARE HAVE HAD
DEER BASED SENTENCE OF THE
SENTENCE BASED ON THE FOR THE
ORIGINAL OR THE CRIME THAT THEY
COMMITTED. BLANK SENT DUE TO
ENHANCEMENTS AND RESEARCH SHOWS
AND WE HAD LOTS OF- THERE WAS
LOTS OF DATA PRESENTED TO US
THERE'S A VARIETY OF
RESEARCHERS WHO'VE BEEN
COLLECTING DATA ON OF ON
VARIOUS THINGS RELATED TO
CALIFORNIA'S PENAL CODE.
RESEARCH SHOWED THAT THERE'S AN
INCONSISTENCY IN THE
APPLICATION OF THESE
ENHANCEMENTS SO FOR EXAMPLE
CALIFORNIA HAS A GANG LAST.
THAT CAN BE REFERRED TO FOR
WHEN SOMEONE ADDS A GANG
ENHANCEMENT BUT IN THAT GAME
CAL GANG REPORT. OF OVER FOUR
HUNDRED FORTY FIVE THOUSAND IN
THE DATABASE. ONLY
APPROXIMATELY THREE THOUSAND OF
THOSE INDIVIDUALS ARE CAUCASIAN.
NOW THERE ARE A GOOD NUMER OF
WHEN WE LOOK AT THE DEFINITION
OF GANGS GANGS THAT ACROSS THE
BOARD GANGS OF THAT ARE
PRIMARILY CAUCASIAN PEOPLE
GETTING SORT OF PRIMARILY.
BLACK INDIVIDUALS GANGS THAT
ARE PRIMARILY FLAT NEXT GAMES
THAT ARE PRIMARILY API HOWEVER.
THE GANG REPORT. IS DOMINANTLY
DOMINANTLY NON CAUCASIAN NOW ON
AVERAGE THE ENHANCEMENTS UNDER
PENAL CODE. AND THAT THEN GET
APPLIED CAN MORE THAN DOUBLE
THE ORIGINAL SENTENCE OF THE
WHATEVER THE BASE CRIME WAS
COMMITTED. AND IF WE THINK
ABOUT. OUR PURPOSES OF
INCARCERATION. YES PART OF IT
IS TO HAVE A PENALTY FOR A
CRIME COMMITTED BUT INITIALLY
WE ARE TRYING TO CREATE SOME
REHABILITATION. AND THE LONGER
A PERSON SERVICE NUMBER ONE
IT'S A GREAT COST TO US OUR
COSTS FOR INCARCERATION HOURS
UPWARDS TO EIGHTY FIVE THOUSAND
PER PERSON. AND IT HAS HUGE
IMPACTS ON THE FAMILIES OF THE
INDIVIDUAL BECAUSE YOU'VE
REMOVED A POTENTIAL EARNINGS
EARNED- PERSON THAT COULD EARN
WAGES FROM THE HOUSEHOLD YOU'VE
ALSO. REMOVED POTENTIALLY
APPARENT FROM CHILDREN AND
SOCIAL IMPLICATIONS SO WE WANT
TO IT IS SMART FOR US TO RELOOK
AT OUR PENAL CODE AND LOOK AT
OUR WE APPROPRIATELY SENTENCING.
SO WHAT- DURING THAT COMMITTEE
THAT I SERVED ON WE HAD A
VARIETY OF DA'S TESTIFY AND SO
FOR EXAMPLE SANTA CLARA DA JEFF
ROSEN'S IN TESTIMONY TO US
ABOUT ENHANCEMENTS SAID THAT IT
IS QUITE COMMON NOW DUE TO THE
NUMBER OF ENHANCEMENTS IN OUR
PENAL CODE THAT THE ENTIRE
TRIAL AND ALL OF THE PRE TRIAL
NEGOTIATIONS END UP SOLELY
ABOUT THE ENHANCEMENTS AND NOT.
THE CRIME ITSELF. NOW MANY
STATES HAVE BEGUN TO REFORM
THEIR ENHANCEMENT PROCESS SEES.
WHAT THIS BILL DOES SB EIGHTY
ONE IS IT DOES NOT ELIMINATE
ANY ENHANCEMENT THEY ALL STAY
ON THE BOOKS RATHER IT GIVES
MORE GUIDANCE TO OUR JUDGES IN
HOW TO APPLY THEM. SO THAT
THERE IS SO THAT WE CAN AS MUCH
AS POSSIBLE REMOVE THE KIND OF
ARBITRARINESS OF APPLYING
ENHANCEMENT BECAUSE THERE ARE
OBVIOUSLY SOME CIRCUMSTANCES
WHERE AN ENHANCEMENT IS
APPROPRIATE AND THAT'S WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO ENSURE IS THAT
WHEN THE ENHANCEMENT IS APPLIED
IT'S APPLIED APPROPRIATELY. SO
WHAT IT DOES IS. GIVE THE JUDGE
SOME OF FRAMEWORK SO THAT
THEY'RE APPLYING AN ENHANCEMENT
WHEN THERE'S CLEAR AND
CONVINCING EVIDENCE THAT TO NOT
APPLY IT YOU WOULD BE
ENDANGERING THE PUBLIC. SO YOU
WOULD FOR EXAMPLE. YOU WOULD
USE MORE DISK NOT LESS
DISCRETION ANOTHER WORDS MORE
AND MORE CLARITY IF THAT WAS A
NONVIOLENT OFFENSE FOR EXAMPLE
IF IT WAS AN OFFENCE CONNECTED
TO A MENTAL HEALTH ISSUE. IF
THE ENHANCEMENT WAS BASED ON A
CONVICTION THAT WAS PRIOR TO
FIVE YEARS AGO AND THERE HAD
BEEN NO CONVICTIONS IN THE MEAN
TIME OR IF THE DEFENDANT WAS A
USED. BY JUVENILES WHEN THEY
COMMITTED THE OFFENSE- SO
THAT'S THE THAT THAT IS SOME OF
THE GUIDANCE THAT SB EIGHTY ONE
IS TRYING TO PUT INTO STATUTE
SO THAT. THERE'S LESS
ARBITRARINESS TO THE USE OF
ENHANCEMENTS AND OUR JUDGES CAN
FEEL MORE CONFIDENT BECAUSE
RIGHT NOW IT IS LEFT. DEAD IT
IS VERY- THERE'S NOT CLEARED
FOR WHEN TO APPLY THEM SAROD
LIKE TO NOW HAVE MY- A WITNESS
WHO IS ONE OF THE PERSONS WHO
SERVED ON THE COMMISSION WITH
ME AS DID ANOTHER COLLEAGUE
HERE ON THE COMMITTEE- AND THAT
IS JUDGE PETER ESPINOSA. AND
JUDGE ESPINOZA WAS APPOINTED TO
THE BENCH BY OUR GOVERNOR
FORMER GOVERNOR PETE WILSON.
BUT HE SERVED ON THE THIS PENAL
CODE REVIEW COMMITTEE AND-
HEARD ALL THE TESTIMONY AND OF
COURSE OBVIOUSLY AS A JUDGE HAS
BEEN SUBJECT TO VARIOUS OF MANY
MANY MANY MANY TRIALS WHERE
ENHANCEMENTS TO OUR FUTURE. SO
IF WE COULD TURN OUT TO JUDGE
ESPINOZA. THANK YOU FIRST
WITNESS AB TWO MINUTE. I THINK
HE'S MY ONLY WITNESS- CENTER
BRADFORD SO. THIS IS. YOU'RE
ASKING FOR MENTAL YOU MAY NOT
NEED FOR HOURS BUT IT IS NOT.
HOPEFULLY HERE JUST FROM THOSE
ARE YOU PREPARED. ARE ON THE
LINE. MODERATOR DO WE HAVE.
MISTRESS FOR THOSE WITH. YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE JUST I MEAN
IF YOU'RE AT ALL. THAT'S MY
FAULT I TEND TO SPEAK
FREQUENTLY WHILE I'M ON MUTE
CAN YOU HEAR ME. YES WE CAN
HELLO. YES OKAY GREAT MY NAME'S
BEEN ARRESTED ALSO HAS
INTRODUCED BY SENATOR SKINNER I
SPENT TWENTY FIVE YEARS ON THE
L. A. COUNTY SUPERIOR COURT.
INCLUDING TWO YEARS OF
SUPERVISING JUDGE OF THE
CRIMINAL DIVISION- I WAS PROUD
TO SERVE WITH HER ON THE PENAL
CODE REVISION COMMITTEE- WHERE
WE- TRY TO BRING SOME CLARITY
TO THE PENAL CODE AS SHE
INDICATED. CREATES SOME
ALTERNATIVES TO INCARCERATION
AND LOOK AT THE PENAL CODE TO
RACIAL JUSTICE LANDS. FROM.
ROUSE SB EIGHTY ONE FOR- I'M
HERE TO SPEAK ON. SEND YOUR
SKINNER. ON THE TRYING NOT SURE
MUCH OF WHAT SHE HAS ALL SAID
A- PETITION THE NEW. THE PEOPLE.
INTO HAS A ONE AND FIFTY
ENHANCE. 80% OF PEOPLE AND CDC
ARE CURRENTLY SERVING A TERM
LINCOLN BY AN ENHANCEMENT. MORE
THAN 25% OF PRISONERS OF HAVE
THEIR SINCE THE STANDARD BY
WHICH WE ARE MORE ANTIOXIDANTS.
THAN ON AVERAGE THE ENHANCEMENT
DOUBLES A PERSON SENTENCE.
INSTEAD PRISON. I THINK IT AND
CALM WHEN DEALING WITH US.
ENHANCEMENT THROUGH EQUITY LET.
TEMPOR TO NOTE NINETIES PER OF
PEOPLE SERVING. PRISON SENTENCE
FOR GAINING HIM OR OF. 89% OF
PEOPLE SAY A PRISON SENTENCE
THE GUN- PEOPLE COLOR. 75% NON
BY AGAINST- PEOPLE COLOR. AND
SEVENTY SEVEN. PERCENT OF PER
SHARE MISSILE BE OF COLOR COLOR.
WE HER ON THE ISSUE OF
CONSENTING TWINS FROM A NUMBER
OF WHAT IN. FORMER GOVERNOR
JERRY BROWN SANTA CLARA COUNTY
DISTRICT ATTORNEY JEFF ROSEN
THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY GEORGE GASC ON AND ALL
OF THEM IN VARIOUS WAYS- JUST
TO LOOK AT THE USE OF
SENTENCING ENHANCEMENTS. THAT
APPLIES TO THE CALIFORNIA STATE
PRISON SYSTEM. WE LOOKED AT A
LOT OF EMPIRICAL RESEARCH AND
DATA AND OTHER STRUCTURAL
SENTIMENTS AMONG RESEARCHERS
THE LONG SENTENCES HAVE LITTLE
OR NO IMPACT ON PUBLIC SAFETY.
YEAH STUDIES SHOWN THAT A
PERSON'S CRIMINAL INVOLVEMENT
TENDS TO BE LIMITED TO A PERIOD
OF LESS THAN TEN YEARS. WHEN
THEY TEND TO REACH OUT. OF
THEIR CRIMINAL BEHAVIOR TO ALL
STATES ALREADY HAVE CUT OUT
DATES ARE WASHOE PROVISIONS
AFTER WHICH CRIMINAL HISTORY.
AND NOT BE USED TO EXTEND THE
SENTENCE INCLUDING ARIZONA
FLORIDA ILLINOIS IN THE STATE
OF WASHINGTON. IT'S IMPORTANT
TO UNDERSTAND THAT ALL OF THE
WORK THAT WE DID ON THE PENAL
CODE REVISION COMMISSION WAS
DONE THROUGH. NOT ONLY THE
RACIAL EQUITY LOUNGE- BUT A
PUBLIC SAFETY LANDS. IN
HANSEN'S CAN ALREADY BE
DISMISSED BY JUDGES BUT THE
CURRENT STANDARD IN FURTHERANCE
OF JUSTICE THE SENATOR SKINNER
HAS INDICATED HIS WAY.
CALIFORNIA SUPREME COURT HAS
RULED TO THIS. HAS REFERRED TO
THE STANDARDS AND MORE FOR THIS
CONCEPT. THE GOAL SENATE BILL
EIGHTY ONE IS TO GET A JUDGE'S
MORE GUIDANCE ON WHEN THEY
SHOULD DISMISS- ENHANCEMENTS BY
ESTABLISHING A PRESUMPTION THAT
THE TOO SOON TO SELL. UNDER
CERTAIN CIRCUMSTANCES. AGAIN
THE CONSIDERATION OF PUBLIC%
SAFETY REMAINS THE OVERRIDING
CONCERN IN A JUDGE CAN QUITE
EASILY MAKE A RECORD THAT CLEAR
AND CONVINCING EVIDENCE. CHOIRS
AND ENHANCE WOULD BE USED IN A
SENTENCE BLANCA BY THE USE OF
THAT ENHANCE. WELL I'M I'M
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
BUT- THAT'S MY STATEMENT IN
SUPPORT OF. THANK YOU. NOW
COMING BACK TO THE ROOM TO WE
HAVE ANY WITNESSES HERE IN
FORTY TWO OLD THREE INTERESTED
IN SUPPORTING SPEAKING IN
SUPPORT OF S. B. EIGHTY ONE.
SIGNON LET'S NOW MOVE TO ROOM
TWENTY FORTY. ANY WITNESSES
THERE IN SUPPORT OF THE S. P.
EIGHTY ONE. CENA AND THEIR
MODERATOR DO WE HAVE WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT CUED UP TO TESTIFY
ON S. B. EIGHTY ONE. THANK YOU
IF YOU WISH TO MAKE A COMMENT
IN SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND WE'RE
CURRENTLY AT ABOUT TWENTY FIVE
IN THE QUEUE AT THIS TIME. OKAY
LET'S GET STARTED AND REMEMBER
WITNESSES RURAL STATE YOUR NAME
IN YOUR POSITION. THE
ORGANIZATION. THANK YOU OF MY
NINETY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS MIKE THAT DOCTOR OFF ON
BEHALF OF THE ACLU OF
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. YOU YOU'RE RIGHT TO
THIRTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON GOING BACK AS
FOR ELLA BAKER CENTER FOR HUMAN
RIGHTS AND DRUG POLICY ALLIANCE
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
I'M SIXTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THE MINISTER ON BEHALF OF THE
PROSECUTORS ALLIANCE OF
CALIFORNIA AND MARK JUSTICE
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU RYAN ONE NINETY SIX PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTER HEARING
CENTERS MY NAME IS ANTHONY
DIMARTINO AND ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIANS FOR SAFETY JUSTICE
WE ARE PROUD CO SPONSOR OF SB
EIGHTY ONE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ABOUT A LINE OF TWO TWENTY.
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. NOT SURE
HERNANDEZ ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ATTORNEYS FOR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE WE ARE CO
SPONSORING ATHLETES SUPPORT.
THANK YOU NEXT ON THE LINE OF
TO TEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. PARGO
GEORGE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION AND STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU AN EXTRA
LINE OF ONE FIFTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. DEALT WITH INITIATE
JUSTICE STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU AND NEXT OVER A
LINE OF FORTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. PINE FORTY FIVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. AND WE'LL MOVE ON TO
THE NEXT LINE OF LINE TO ALL
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
CANACCORD ARE NOW ON BEHALF OF
THE SAN FRANCISCO PUBLIC
DEFENDER'S OFFICE IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU SO THE LINE
OF FORTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. YOUR SHEER OF THE
CALIFORNIA RELIGIOUS ACTION
CENTER OF REFORM JUDAISM
CONSTRUCTION WORK. THANK YOU
MEXICO LINE OF NINETY YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON TURN
SENATORS MY NAME IS EDDIE
COMING OFF AND I'M CALLING IN
STRONG SUPPORT FOR SB EIGHTY
ONE ON BEHALF OF PROJECT
KINSHIP BASED OUT OF THAT AND
THEN THE COUNTY OF ORANGE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MEXICO LINE OF
FIFTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU I'M THIS IS BORING
PTI- THE AGENT BECAUSE OF
SUPPORT COMMITTEE I'M CALLING
SUPPORT SB EIGHTY ONE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MXR A LINE OF FIFTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. SHE'S
AFTERNOON THIS IS CATHERINE
LEVINE ON BEHALF OF SHIELDS
FAMILIES AND STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU THE NEXT
TO GO LINE OF ONE TWENTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS PRISCILLA
MARTINEZ ON BEHALF OF BREAD
NOBODY NEEDLE. IN STRONG
SUPPORT FOR SB EIGHTY ONE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU ANNEX OF THE
LINE OF SEVENTY SIX YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. AT THE INSURANCE
SENATORS MY NAME IS KEVIN
MCCARTY I'M CALLING IN STRONG
SUPPORT FOR SB EIGHTY ONE ON
BEHALF OF UNDERGROUND SCHOLARS.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ANNEX OF A
LINE OF TWO THIRTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS
SHANTA MOMENT ON WHAT
CHARACTERS ROSES AND A STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
AN EXTRA LINE OF FIFTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ONE FIFTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. AND
WE'LL MOVE ON TO THE NEXT LINE
OF ONE SIXTY FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. NINE ONE SIX BEFORE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MICHALEK FINE OF
TWO OH EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS TEACH
STEVENS WITH THE PUBLIC
DEFENDER'S OFFICE IN SAN DIEGO
COUNTY STRONGLY SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU ANEXO GOAL LINE
OF EIGHTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
ONE EIGHTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. ALL RIGHT MOBILE BONTA
NECKLINE OF LINE TWO HUNDRED
AND THIRTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
JIM WEINBERG ON BEHALF OF THE
FRENCH COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION
TO CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. NEXT OVER
THE LINE OF NINETY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MY NINETY THREE
YEAR LINE IS OPEN. ALL RIGHT
NUMBER ONE THE NEXT LINE OF BUT-
NINE SEVEN DB SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN SEVENTY SEVEN. HELLO
THIS IS SHERRY WITH AN HARPER
FROM THE COMMUNITY JUSTICE
CENTER AND ON BEHALF OF ALL
RETURNING SERVICE THEM WHAT
CAUSED THE FRESNO WE ARE
WHOLEHEARTEDLY AND STRONGLY
INSUPPORTABLE. THANK YOU. THE
NEXT PLAN WILL GO TO HIS LINE
FIFTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
AND THEN WE'LL MOVE ON TO THE
NEXT LINE OF LYING TO FORTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. TOMAHAWK
SENIOR PUBLIC SAFETY ADVISOR
FOR CALIFORNIA FOR SEEKING
JUSTICE. RETIRED DEPUTY CHIEF
OF POLICE CITY WAS SACKED
RETIRED. DIRECTOR CALIFORNIA
DON'T COOL OPERATIONS IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU AN EXTRA
LINE OF TWO FORTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS
NATASHA BAKER AND I LIVE IN
OAKLAND AND I AM ALSO CALLING
IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. AND THAT WAS OUR
LAST SUPPORT THANK YOU. MY
RURAL DESTRUCTION TO CHECK ONE
MORE TIME SEE IF THERE'S ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
OF S. B. EIGHTY ONE. SURE IF
YOU ARE IN SUPPORT YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO OF SB
EIGHTY ONE ONE ZERO IF YOU
AREN'T SUPPORT. AND WE HAVE
FIVE IN Q. WILL GO TO THE FIRST
LINE OF ONE FIFTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. AND PLEASE CHECK
YOUR MUTE BUTTON LINE FIFTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. NEARLY
YES. EITHER VIA WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE FOR YOU
THINK MANY JUDGES IN STRONG
SUPPORT WHEN THEY'RE GONNA
JONES. THANK YOU. AN EXTRA LINE
OF NINETY THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI CAN YOU HEAR ME. YES
HI THERE ARE FOUR HUNDRED NINE
NOW AND I ONLY STOCKS LOOK
FORWARD- THANK BILL AB ONE
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
HAVE ONE AFFECTED FAMILY
MEMBERS- BECAUSE THEY DON'T
SEVEN ONE AFTER TWENTY YEARS ON
THE ON BY BANKING I WOULD THINK
YOU WOULD JUST NEED YOUR NAME
AND ORGANIZATION. YOU VERY MUCH.
PRITCHETT THANK YOU HELLO.
THANK ALLOWED TO FORTY YEAR
LINE OF OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
THIS IS WILBUR THAT THAT THAT
AS ON BEHALF OF RESTORE DRAFTED
IN SUPPORT. YOU THANK YOU THE
NEXT OF A LINE OF FORTY. YOUR
LINE OPEN. HELLO YES GO AHEAD.
MY NAME IS MEDIA HE MANAGED AND
I AM CALLING A STRONG SUPPORT
FOR AT THE EIGHT ONE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT OVER THE LINE OF
NINETY YOUR LINE IS OPEN. BY
NINETY YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
CHECK YOUR MUTE BUTTON. MY NAME
IS ANY COMING UP WITH PROJECT
CAN SHIP AND I'M IN SHOCK THE
POOR OF SB EIGHTY ONE. THANK
YOU NEXT OVER A LINE OF TWO
TWENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK GOD I'M AND I'M CALLING
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF. OKAY
THANK YOU. ANNEX OF A LINE OF
TWO THIRTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. AND YOUR EMPLOYMENT BY
THE CORPORATION AND I AM IN
AGREEMENT WITH THE- EIGHTY ONE.
THANK YOU. AN EXTRA LINE OF TWO
FIFTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I
REMEMBER OF THE COMMITTEE AS
LONG AS POLICY DIRECTOR FOR THE
ANTI RECIDIVISM COALITION IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF SB EIGHTY ONE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND THE
LAST WHEN I Q. COMES FROM LINE
OF EIGHTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
YOUR LOCAL MAJOR GOOD AFTERNOON.
AND SENATOR I INSPIRON.
ORGANIZATION CRACKED THE VERY
FIRST DEBATE THE INJECTORS
INLAND EMPIRE THANK YOU THANK
YOU. I WANT TO THANK ALL OUR
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. NOW WE'RE
GONNA MOVE TURN LEAD FOR
WITNESS- IN OPPOSITION. WE HAVE
A SURE MUCH SLOWER I HOPE I GET
THAT RIGHT- MODERATOR ARE THEY
PREPARED TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION OF US BE EIGHTY ONE.
YES SIR LINE SHOULD BE OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS WHO SHALL MATURE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE.
SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION AND WE ARE
FIRST WANT TO THANK ON CENTER
SKINNER STEIN. RETURNING ON THE
COMMISSION- BUT THAT WE
MACINNES BECKLEY OPPOSED SENATE
BILL EIGHTY ONE- WHICH SEEK TO
LIMIT THE APPLICATION OF MANY
ENHANCEMENTS INCLUDING AN
INTERACTIVE IN WHICH MULTIPLE
ENHANCEMENTS ARE ALLEGED IN A
SINGLE CASE ORDER TOTAL
SENTENCES OVER TWENTY YEARS AT
THE CURRENT EVENTS IS CONNECTED
TO MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES AT THE
CURRENT MARKET CONNECTED TO
PRIOR VICTIMIZATION OR
CHILDHOOD TRAUMA. THE CURRENT
BANK IS NOT VIOLENT OR
ENHANCEMENT IS BASED ON A PRIOR
CONVICTION THAT IT OR FIVE
YEARS OLD ON SOME OF THESE
CONDITIONS ARE SUBJECT ACTIVE
THAT POTENTIALLY DIFFICULT TO
DEMONSTRATE APPROVED. OTHERS
INCLUDING THE CIRCUMSTANCES THE
WEAR AND MULTIPLE ENHANCEMENTS
ARE ALLEGED TO HAVE HIGH
CONVICTION IS MORE THAN FIVE
YEARS OLD DO NOT NECESSARILY
PROVIDE ENOUGH INFORMATION AS
TO WHETHER ENHANCEMENT ENACTED
BY THE LEGISLATURE. CALIFORNIA
VOTERS. SHOULD ULTIMATELY BE
IMPOSED. SHE WE BELIEVE THAT ON
FOR DIDN'T LET YOU. CREATE
TRAVEL TO. ON YOUR OTHER
APPROPRIATE FRANKLIN'S COUNTY.
THAT WOULD BE IN STATE THE
NATURE OF THAT. AND ACTION
EIGHT BY THE ARE YOU GAY.
INSTEAD ACCORD WOULD BE TO THE
CRIME TO DO. IT'S HARD AND IN.
UPON A SHOWING BY AND
CONVINCING AT THE- THAT THE
MISSILE OVEN HERE WITHIN DANGER
FACE. IS SHOWING WOULD BE IN A
TO THE BEING LAW THAT ONLY
REQUIRE TO DEFINE TO BE FOUND
GUILTY BEYOND A REASONABLE
DOUBT. BUT ALSO REQUIRED
ENHANCEMENTS TO BE GENERAL. TO
GENERAL DAVID CLAD AND PROVED
OPPORTUNITY TO RESULTS
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE AND ASK FOR
YOUR NOTEBOOK. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. NOW LET'S COME BACK TO THE
CA ROOM TWO OLD THREE ARE THERE
ANY WITH HERE OP. S. B. EIGHTY
ONE. CASEY NINE KNOWLEDGEABLE
TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY WITH THIS
IN OPPOSITION SB ONE. SHE NINE
MODERATOR WE'RE GONNA WILL NOW
MOVE TO OUR PHONE INES DO WE
HAVE WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
CUTE FOR S. B. EIGHTY ONE CAN
YOU GIVE ME THE NUMBER. THANK
YOU IN OPPOSITION OF SB EIGHTY
ONE YOU MAY PRESS ONE AT ZERO.
AND WE HAVE THREE RIGHT NOW
WHAT ARE THE FIRST LINE OF TWO
FORTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
SORRY I ACTUALLY WAS IN FAVOR
OF A NIGHT. OF PROSTATE RIGHT
IS YOU GUYS WHICH OVER
COMPOSITION. OKAY YOU CAN SEE
GENERAL COURT THANK. HELLO. OUR
MODERATOR WILL GO TO OUR NEXT
CALL. YOUR LIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS
AMANDA FRANKLIN AND I'M AND
FONG- FAVOR AS PROP EIGHTY ONE
I MEAN SB EIGHTY ONE. THANK YOU
WERE LOOKING FOR OPPOSITION AT
THIS TIME WE'RE LOOKING FOR
CALLERS AND OPPOSITION OF S. B.
EIGHTY ONE. THANK YOU OVER A
LINE OF ONE THIRTY ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS RYAN COUSINS I'M AN
ASSISTANT CHIEF DEPUTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY WITH YOLO COUNTY
CALIFORNIA- I RESPECT THE
EFFORTS THAT WERE MADE BY
SENATOR SKINNER WITH THE
COMMITTEE I RESPECTFULLY
DISAGREE WITH SENATE BILL
EIGHTY ONE. IT ESSENTIALLY
TREATS ALL CRIMES AS
PRESUMPTIVELY NOT MITIGATED I
APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS ABOUT
GIVING GUIDANCE GUIDANCE TO
JUDGES BUT IT'S IT IS
PRESUMPTIVELY HAVING THEM
DISMISS ENHANCEMENTS BASICALLY
TREATING THE CRIMES AS NOT
AGGRAVATED WHEN FOR EXAMPLE
THERE BEEN MULTIPLE VICTIMS. OR
USE OF A WEAPON OR INFLICTION
OF GREAT BODILY INJURY BUT- THE
MOST GLARING- THING THAT I SEE
WRONG WITH THIS RESPECTFULLY IS
WITH THAT PUBLIC SAFETY
EXCEPTION. IT DISCOUNTS
ENHANCEMENTS FOR THEFT AND I
THINK ONE OF THE GREATEST
THREATS THAT WE FACE TO YOUR
NAME IN YOUR ORGANIZATION ARE
THIS TIME WE'VE ALREADY TAKEN
PRIMARY TESTIMONY. THANK YOU.
WELL I. THANK YOU OVER A LINE
OF ONE TWENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. MY NAME IS SHERRY EVAN
LOW AND JOB I JUST WANT TO CALL
IN RESPECTFULLY YOU OPPOSED TO
THE S. B. EIGHTY ONE. THANK YOU.
AND WE HAVE NO MORE OPPOSITION
IN Q. YEAH SHE CHECKED ONLINE
TO MORE TIME FOR ANY POTENTIAL
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. YES IF
YOU ARE AT OPPOSITION OF SB
EIGHTY ONE YOU MAY PRESS ONE
MINUTE AND THEN THE. ZERO
BROUGH LINE OF ONE THIRTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I'M SORRY I
UNDERSTOOD THAT WE ARE ABLE TO
CALL IN TO PROVIDE TESTIMONY.
WE'VE ALREADY TAKEN PRIMARY
TESTIMONY LOW WE'RE JUST TAKING
THOSE INDIVIDUALS BOTH FOREIGN
AND AGAINST THAT JUST STATE
YOUR NAME IN OUR ORGANIZATION.
WE ARE PRIMARY WITNESS ALREADY
IN OPPOSITION HARD TESTIFIED.
THANK YOU NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE
OF OUR LINES SIXTY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS
NICHOLA AND I. EIGHTY ONE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU THE NEXT OF A
LINE OF TWO FIFTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. I MEAN IT'S EASY.
TO USE HIGH HOLIDAY THAT JUST
CALLED AND I'M ACTUALLY CALLING
IN SUPPORT OF. THE EIGHTY ONE
NOT OPPOSITION. THEY JUST
CALLED THANK YOU. AND WE HAVE
NO MORE FOR THEIR OPPOSITION TO
IN Q. THREE OKAY I'LL BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE ANY
QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS VIA
COMMITTEE MEMBERS SURE. IT'S
BEEN PROPERLY MOVES VISOR
WINNER. SURE I HAD A QUESTION-
OKAY CENTER OCHO A BOOK SORRY-
SENATORS SKINNER JUST A QUICK
QUESTION ON NOT- IS THIS A
MANDATE FOR JUDGES OR IS THIS
A- SUGGESTION. IT FOR IT
ACTUALLY- DIRECTS THE JUDGE
UNDER WHAT CONDITIONS FOR THE
PARAMETERS FOR THE APPLICATION
OF THE ENHANCEMENT SO IT'S A
MUST THEY MUST FOLLOW THESE
PROTOCOLS CORRECT CORRECT
BECAUSE THERE WERE NO THE POINT
AS MY WITNESS TESTIFIED SINCE
THERE WERE NO THERE WAS NO
GUIDANCE AND NO PROTOCOLS WE'VE
HAD THIS VERY THIS SIGNIFICANT
DISPARITY IN WHO HAS RECEIVING
THE ENHANCEMENTS ESPECIALLY.
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE
RECEIVED THREE OR MORE AS
INDICATED THERE ARE A HUNDRED
AND FIFTY ENHANCEMENTS ON THE
BOOKS SO ANY INDIVIDUAL CAN
HAVE DEPENDING ON WHAT THE
PROSECUTOR DESIRES CAN TRY TO
LEVY UPWARDS SIX SEVEN EIGHT
NINE MORE ENHANCEMENTS ON
ADDITION TO THE BASIC CRIME. SO
WITH THIS GUIDANCE DOES IS THE
ONLY WAY THAT THE JUDGE COULD
DISMISS IT IS IF THERE IS A-
RATHER TO. THE JUDGE WOULD NEED
TO USE THE ENHANCEMENT IF.
THERE'S A CLEAR THREAT TO
PUBLIC SAFETY BY NOT APPLYING
THE ENHANCEMENT SO PUBLIC
SAFETY WHAT WE ARE DOING IN THE
DESIGN OF EIGHTY ONE IS PUTTING
PUBLIC SAFETY FIRST AND
FOREMOST. WOULD YOU SAY THE
ENHANCEMENTS ARE IN TRYING TO
FORMULATE MY THOUGHTS HERE THE
ENHANCEMENTS ARE. A NEGATIVE
THING IT DEPENDS IT DEPENDS ON
A YOU KNOW WE HAVE WE HEARD
ABOUT CASES FOR EXAMPLE IN THE
PENAL CODE REVIEW COMMITTEE
WHERE. AN WE KNOW THAT- TO
BASICALLY MOST CALIFORNIANS ARE
MOST AMERICANS OWN GUNS AND IT
IS VERY COMMON FOR A PERSON TO
HAVE A GUN IN THEIR CAR. NOW
WHAT HAPPENS IS A PERSON WITH A
GUN IN THEIR CAR. IS THEN
ARRESTED FOR TOTALLY DIFFERENT
CRIME BUT THE PRESENCE OF THE
GUN IN THE CAR EVEN IF NOT USED
OR POTENTIALLY EVEN IF NOT
LOADED CAN ADD ADD A GUN
ENHANCEMENT TO THAT BASIC CRIME.
BUT WHAT WE SAW ON THE DATA. IS
THAT FOR EXAMPLE IF I WERE THE
PERSON WHO COMMITTED THE CRIME.
AND HAD THE GUN IN MY CAR BUT I
DIDN'T USE THE GUN IN THE CAR
IN THEIR CRIME BUT I HAD TO GO
TO THE CAR. THAT IS HIGHLY
UNLIKELY FOR ME TO GET THAT
ENHANCEMENT ADDED. WHEREAS IF.
I WERE. BLACK OR BROWN FOR
EXAMPLE. AGAIN SAME
CIRCUMSTANCES EXACT SAME
CIRCUMSTANCES. I MIGHT HAVE
BEGUN ENHANCEMENT USED. ON MY
IN IN MY IN THE PROSECUTION
SODA SUPPLIED TO THE SENTENCE
OF WHATEVER MY OTHER CRIME WAS.
SURE THANK YOU SENATOR SKINNER.
CENTER CALM WATER. THANK YOU
SENATOR SKINNER FOR- THIS BILL
I JUST AS I A COLLEAGUE WHO
SERVED ON THE PENAL CODE
REVISION COMMITTEE WITH YOU
WANTED JUST- YOU KNOW ELEVATE
SOME OF YOUR POINTS THAT YOU
KNOW ENHANCEMENTS ARE REALLY
SEEN AS SENTENCE ADDITIVES. SO
YOU ARE MIGHT BE CHARGED I'M
AND THEN THE PROSECUTOR HAS THE
ABILITY TO ADD ENHANCEMENTS TO
THE ORIGINAL CHARGE AND WHAT WE
HAVE SEEN AND WHAT WE LEARNED
THROUGH EXHAUSTIVE TESTIMONY IS
THAT OFTENTIMES INSPECT IN MOST
INSTANCES- THOSE ENHANCEMENTS
ARE SORT OF- CHARGED
DISCRIMINANT LEE- AND ALSO VERY
HAPHAZARDLY WITHOUT CLEAR
DIRECTION AND GUIDELINES. FOR
WHICH A JUDGE CAN USE IN ORDER
TO DECIDE WHEN IT IS
APPROPRIATE TO ACCEPT AN
ENHANCEMENT AND WHEN IT ISN'T.
ANOTHER EXAMPLE IS OFTENTIMES
WITH GANG ENHANCEMENTS WE WILL
SEE MEMBERS WHO ARE IN. WHO
MIGHT BE CHARGED WITH A
PARTICULAR CRIME AND THEN THEY
WILL HAVE A GANG ENHANCEMENT
YOU KNOW ADDED TO THAT CHARGE
WHEN THEY'RE BLACK AND BROWN
YOU'LL HAVE MEMBERS WHO ARE
ALSO IN GANGS AND LIKE THE
ARIAN BROTHERHOOD THE MAYBE UP
ON PARTICULAR YOU KNOW EVERYONE
MAY BE UP ON A DRUG CHARGE.
THAT PARTICULAR PERSON WHO
pBROTHERHOOD GANG IS NOT LEVIED
AN ADDITIONAL GANG ENHANCEMENT
AND SO WHEN YOU HAVE THAT KIND
OF SORT OF HAPHAZARD-
DISCRETION- BY A PROSECUTOR IN
CONCERT WITH THE JUDGE. LEVYING
THESE ENHANCEMENTS WHICH ADD
IMPORTANT AMOUNTS OF TIME TO
SOMEONE- IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT YOU HAVE
GUIDELINES THAT ALLOW YOU TO
SORT OF BE MORE EQUITABLE OR AT
LEAST TO BE FAIR AND HOW
ENHANCEMENTS ARE GIVEN OUT-
THAT'S WHY I THINK THE AG STOP
USING THE GANG DATABASE THAT'S
WHY A NUMBER OF SORT OF ACTIONS
HAVE BEEN TAKEN OVER THE COURSE
OF THE PAST YEAR BECAUSE WE
HAVE SEEN HOW. REYES SAYS BUT
JUST HOW AN EQUITABLE THE
ENHANCEMENTS ARE LEVY SO I JUST
WANT TO SORT OF. SHARE A LITTLE
BIT OF THAT GIVEN MY EXPERIENCE
ON THE COMMITTEE AND THE
DISCUSSIONS THAT WE HAD AROUND
THIS IT'S HOW TO GIVE VERY
CLEAR GUIDELINES TO JUDGES. ON
HOW TO USE ENHANCEMENTS- YOU
CAN HAVE ANOTHER DISCUSSION OF
IF IT ENCAMPMENTS ARE EVEN
APPROPRIATE BUT THAT'S NOT WHAT
THIS BILL IS ABOUT. MERRY GO SO
DO WE HAVE ANY M. HAVE YOU
HEARD ANYTHING FROM THE JUDGES
AND HOW THEY FEEL ABOUT THESE
GUIDANCE- WILL YOU HEARD FROM
A- PERSON WHO SERVED TWENTY
FIVE YEARS ON THE BENCH AS MY
MAIN WITNESS IN SUPPORT. AND
WHO- AND- WE COULD ALWAYS BRING
HIM BACK IF THAT WERE OKAY WITH
SURE BUT HE BASICALLY. HE
EXPRESSED ANOTHER JUDGE WE HAD
OTHER JUDGES ALSO ON THE
COMMITTEE EXPRESSED THAT THEY
OFTEN FELT IN THIS IN THIS KIND
OF. DIFFICULT CIRCUMSTANCE FORT
BECAUSE THERE WERE THERE WASN'T
REAL GUIDANCE AND- YOU KNOW
WHEN THERE'S REAL PUSH FROM THE
PROSECUTOR TO USE ENHANCEMENTS.
THEN IT SORT OF YOU KNOW WHAT
YOU DON'T COOL WHAT IS THE
PARAMETERS FOR THE JUDGE'S
DISCRETION SO THEY WERE I MEAN
THE REASON THAT- JUDGES BEEN
RECEIVING TESTIFIED TODAY'S
BECAUSE OF HOW STRONGLY FOR
EXAMPLE HE FEELS ABOUT THIS.
THAT HE FEELS THAT IT REALLY
DOES. NEED TO HAVE SOME CLEAR
PARAMETERS THAT JUDGES NEED
THAT GUIDANCE- AND I KNOW THAT
YOU DIDN'T ASK THIS QUESTION SO
MY APOLOGIES FOR SAYING IT BUT
I WANTED TO MAKE CLEAR THAT
THIS DOES NOT CHANGE. THE
CHARGE OF THE BASE CRIME
WHATSOEVER IN ANY WAY NOR THE
PENALTY RELATED TO THE BASE
CRIME NOR DOES IT ELIMINATE ANY
OF THE HUNDRED AND FIFTY
ENHANCEMENTS THERE ARE OTHER
BILLS AND OTHER BILLS BOTH OF
IN THE PAST AND CURRENTLY THIS
YEAR THAT OUR- PURPOSE IS TO
ELIMINATE A PARTICULAR
ENHANCEMENT. THIS BILL IS MUCH
MORE IS ENTIRELY AND SOLELY
DESIGNED TO GIVE GUIDANCE TO
THE JUDGE. THANK YOU CENTER
SKINNER- THANK YOU ANY
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS QUESTIONS
BY COMMITTEE. ARTS CENTER
SKINNER I WANT THANK YOU FOR
THIS MEASURE AGAIN LET'S BE
VERY CLEAR THIS BILL BY KNOWN
STRETCH OF THE IMAGINATION
REMOVES THE ENHANCEMENTS THAT
CURRENTLY EXIST IT SIMPLY GIVES
BETTER GUIDELINES AS TO WHEN IT
IS APPROPRIATE TO APPLY. THOSE
ENHANCEMENTS- N. AS SHEARED
HISTORY SHOWN THAT THOSE THESE
ENHANCEMENTS ARE USUALLY
APPLIED IN A VERY UNEQUALLED
MATTER WHEN IT COMES TO RACE
AND- AND- ECONOMICS AS WELL
THAT PLAYS A MAJOR ROLE AS WELL
IT'S OFTEN STATED IT'S BETTER
TO BE. GUILTY AND RICH AND POOR
INNOCENT SO AND WE SEE THOSE
ENHANCEMENTS ONLY- HAPPEN
HAPPENS TO NOT BE TO YOUR CRIME
AND ANY KIND OF WAY. NO ONE'S
THINKING ABOUT IF IN FACT WHEN
THEY'RE COMMITTING A CRIME THAT
I'M GONNA GET AN ENHANCEMENT
THAT'S GOING TO DETER THAT
ACTION SO TO CONTINUE TO TELL
PEOPLE'S LIVES AWAY WHEN WE
COULD. BE BETTER SERVED IN
TRYING TO PROVIDE THEM A-
REHABILITATIVE A CHANCE OF
DOING AS SENATOR SKINNER SAYS
THE BASELINE CRIME IF IT'S FIVE
YEARS SENTENCE THEY WILL DO
THAT TIME AND HOPEFULLY THAT
TIME THEY'VE LEARNED FROM THEIR
WAYS VERSUS. WHAT WOULD HAVE
BEEN FIVE TURNS INTO FIFTEEN
YEARS AND WHAT YOU HAVE THEN IS
A HARDENED CRIMINAL WHO COMES
OUT WITH LITTLE HOLE MANY TIMES
OF BEING A CONTRIBUTING MEMBER
TO SOCIETY BUT AGAIN I'VE
TALKED TO PLENTY JUDGES AND
THEY APPRECIATE. BOB ABILITY
FOR CLARITY AND GIVEN THEM THE
PARAMETERS ARE WHEN IT'S
APPROPRIATE- TO USE OR NOT BUT
IT DOESN'T REMOVE THE
ENHANCEMENTS AT ALL JUST GIVE
THE JUDGE AGREED AUTHORITY ONE
ONE HOUR IF NOT TO APPLY SO ON
THAT NOTE- WERE. LOOKING FOR A
MOTION TO DO PASS. WELL WITH
THE MEMONS. JEFF ALTARUM. ON
THIS ONE NO MANAGEMENT ON THE
OTHER OKAY I'M SORRY THE NEXT
ONE I GET TO SKINNER BILLS FROM-
IS DUE TO PER- SEEKING A MOTION
ON THAT. I THOUGHT. ARE GOT
CENTER WINNER DID MAKE A MOTION.
FIFTIES TO WILL CALL THE ROLL
ON S. EIGHTY TO PAY TO. SB
EIGHTY D. PASTOR. BRADFORD ON
RED FOR DIET CHOI BOGUE. NOT
VOTING OKAY. IN TROUBLE NOT
VOTING LAGER KAMAGRA SKINNER BY
SKINNER AYE WIENER. WIENER AYE
VOTES FOR ZERO. BILL IS OUT
INTEREST THAT MEASURES OUT FOR
THE ZERO NOW IF YOU'RE PREPARED
WILL MOVE TO S. B. EIGHTY TWO
YES THANK YOU- MISTER CHAIRMAN
OVER SO THIS IS ANOTHER. BILL
THAT IS ONE OF THE
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT CAME FROM-
COMMITTEE ON THE REVISION OF
THE PENAL CODE NOW WHAT THIS
BILL RECOGNIZES IS THAT
CALIFORNIA'S ROBBERY STATUTE
WAS WRITTEN BELIEVE IT OR NOT
IN EIGHTEEN SEVENTY TWO AND IS
NOT BEEN MODIFIED SINCE NOW
THERE ARE MANY ADDITIONAL.
CRIMES HAVE BEEN ADDED TO THE
BOOKS THAT HAVE SOMETHING TO DO
WITH THEFT OR STOLEN ITEMS OR-
BENJAMIN ARE YOU NAME IT BUT
ROBBERY JUST AS A SINGULAR
STATUTE HAS NOT BEEN MODIFIED.
AND THE ROBBERY STATUTE THAT
EXISTS ON OUR BOOKS IS
IMMATERIAL TO THE VALUE OF WHAT
A PERSON STOLE WHAT IS SUPPOSED
TO DIFFERENTIATE IT BETWEEN
THEFT IS THAT ROBBERY INVOLVES
INJURY. OR USE OF WEAPONS ARE
THERE ARE THESE OTHER FACTORS
WHICH THEN MAKES IT A FELONY.
NOW BECAUSE CURRENT LAW ARE
THEFT LAW THE THEFT IS HAS A
VALUE ASSOCIATED SO THINGS OF
TOTAL VALUE OF NINE HUNDRED AND
FIFTY OR LESS. BUT WHAT HAPPENS
IS THAT WE'VE HAD CIRCUMSTANCES
IN MANY OF THESE WE RECEIVE
TESTIMONY ABOUT. WHERE. EIGHT
WHAT MIGHT BE CONSIDERED A
PETTY THEFT OCCURS. BUT IN THE
ACT SO FOR EXAMPLE. ON A PERSON
IS A SHOPLIFTER AND IS RUNNING
OUT OF THE STORE. BECAUSE THEY
DON'T WANT TO BE CAUGHT IN THE
BUMP INTO THE SECURITY GUARD
THEY DON'T KNOCKED THE SECURITY
GUARD OVER. THEY DON'T HURT THE
SECURITY GUARD BUT THEY BUMP
INTO THEM AS THEY RUN OUT.
BECAUSE THERE IS NO REAL
DEFINITION OF WHAT THE FORCE OR
THE OTHER THINGS THAT ARE
SOCIALLY WITH ROBBERY. ANY
PROSECUTOR WHO CHOOSES TO CAN
ELEVATE THAT CHARGE TO A FELONY
CHARGE. NOW. CERTAINLY ANY.
THEFT THEN FALLS OR RESULTS IN
AN INJURY TO A PERSON AND I
WANT TO BE CLEAR THAT UNDER THE
LAW GREAT BODILY INJURY CAN
INCLUDES BRUISING A BLACK TIE
CAN BE DEFINED UNDER OUR
STATUTE IS GREAT BODILY INJURY
THAT MY BILL THE THIS ONE SB
TWO WOULD NOT. ALLOW THAT TEND
TO BECOME. THE FACT WHAT MY
BILL DOES IS CREATE A HIGHER
CATEGORY OF DAFT. ABOVE JUST
THE BASELINE ONE WHICH ONLY.
REQUIRES NOW UP TO SIX MONTHS
IN JAIL. BUT CREATING A NEW
CATEGORY OF THEFT SECOND ND YOU
UP IN UP TO A YEAR OF JAIL
WHERE THERE WERE SOME
INADVERTENT AND HOW MANY USED
TO TERMS THAT ARE ALWAYS SCARY
FOR PEOPLE BUT FOR SEVERE BUT
DOES NOT RESULT. IN THE TYPE OF
INJURIES I DESCRIBED EVEN
BRUISING. AND IS NOT AN ASSAULT
OR BATTERY. BUT NONE OF THOSE
THINGS CAN BE FACTORS FOR MY
BILL TO APPLY. BUT RATHER FOR
THE CIRCUMSTANCES THAT- BLURRED
NOW. AND ARE NOT APPROPRIATE TO
BE CHARGED IS ROBBERY WE WANT
PEOPLE. WHO COMMIT VIOLENCE
WHEN THEY STEAL TO BE CHARGED
WITH ROBBERY ABSOLUTELY THAT IS
APPROPRIATE AND WE WANT THAT
BUT WHERE WE ARE FINDING IS
BECAUSE AGAIN THE LACK OF
CLARITY BETWEEN THE DISTINCTION
THAT THERE ARE PEOPLE BEING
CHARGED WITH FELONY ROBBERY.
THAT JUDGES EVEN FEEL ARE
SHOULD NOT IS NOT APPROPRIATE
NOW TO D. A.'S THAT TESTIFIED
IN THE COMMITTEE DESCRIBED
THANKS FOR EXAMPLE. D. A.
O'MALLEY WHO IS PRESIDENT OF
THE DA'S ASSOCIATION AT THE
TIME SHE STATED THAT. CERTAIN
OF THESE ROBBERIES THERE WAS A
FAMOUS COURT CASE CALLED ESTES
ARE OFTEN LOW LEVEL CRIMES AND
THEY SHOULD HAVE LESS SEVERE
SANCTIONS. THEN FELONY ROBBERY.
BANDAGE THAT SHE OFTEN TRIES TO
PROSECUTE THEM AS SOMETHING
DIFFERENT. ADDITIONALLY D. A.
ROSEN TESTIFIED THAT THE
COMMITTEE SHOULD LIMIT THE
PROSECUTORS ABILITY TO CHARGE
SUCH ROBBERIES AS FELONY
OFFENSES. BUT THE ONLY WAY THAT
WE CAN GIVE THAT GUIDANCE IS BY
FIXING THE STATUTE AND SO. WHAT
IN DOING SO WHAT I'M TRYING TO
ACHIEVE BY EIGHTY TWO IS TO
CREATE A NEW CATEGORY OF THEFT
AND THIS IS NOT USUAL FOR ME TO
BE ADVOCATING TO CREATE A NEW
CRIME. AND A CRIME WITH A
HIGHER PENALTY BUT IT'S
APPROPRIATE SO THAT WE DO NOT
HAVE CIRCUMSTANCES WHERE PEOPLE.
HAVE COMMITTED SOMETHING THAT
IS. AGAIN THIS THIS TYPE OF
DISTINCTION THAT MAY OF THAT
MANY OF US. RESULTED IN. A
BUMPING INTO THE SECURITY GUARD
OR- OUTSIDE YELLING AT SOMEONE
FOR EXAMPLE. SO THERESHOULD BE
A ABILITY TO CHARGE THEM WITH
SOMETHING MORE THAN THE VERY
LOWEST MISDEMEANOR BUT NOT
SOMETHING AS HIGH AS ROBBERY
WHICH COULD END UP GIVING YOU
FIVE YEARS IN PRISON SO THAT'S
THE DISTINCTION I'M TRYING TO
CREATE- AND WITH THAT I WOULD
LIKE TO TURN TO MY WITNESS IN
SUPPORT WHO IS AGAIN. OUR-
JUDGE PETER ESPINOZA WHO AS I
INDICATED WAS ORIGINALLY
APPOINTED TO THE SUPERIOR COURT
BY GOVERNOR PETE WILSON SERVED
TWENTY FIVE YEARS AND WAS A
MEMBER HI IS A MEMBER OF THE
PENAL CODE REVIEWS REVISION
COMMITTEE. SURCHARGES PANOS.
THANK YOU SENATOR AND- AGAIN
TRUCK. MANY OF THE COMMENTS OF
A WILL ALL REMAIN. EXPLANATION
OF THIS BILL. BUT. IT'S
IMPORTANT TO REMEMBER THAT- IF
SERIOUS INJURY OR USE OF A
WEAPON IS ALLEGED THE
APPROPRIATE CHARGES STILL
ROBBERY- AND OTHER CHARGES THAT
CAN BE FILED LIKE A SONG. THE
DESIGNATION OF ALL OPERATIONS
SERIOUS AND VIOLENT CRIMES IS
SOMEWHAT MISLEADING AND AS
SENATOR SKINNER'S ALREADY
INDICATED WE ARE RELYING ON A
STATUE THAT WAS CREATED IN
EIGHTEEN SEVENTY TWO WITHOUT.
ANY OR MUCH- UPDATING THE
DEFINITION IS EXTREMELY BROAD
AND ANY AMOUNT OF FOR WILL
SUPPLY. ALL ROBBERY OR VIOLENT
OFFENSES UNDER THE THREE
STRIKES LAW BUT NOT ALL
ROBBERIES ARE ACTUALLY VIOLENT
IN THE- SIGNIFICANCE OF THIS
BILL- THE LEMONADE THE
POSSIBILITY THAT IF YOU ARE IN
A SITUATION WHERE YOU ARE
CHARGED. WITH RESISTING- THE
ARREST OF DURING THE PARIS
STUFF YOU YOU WILL NOT LIKELY
CHARGE WITH STRIKER. I'M JUST
GOING TO GIVE YOU A COUPLE OF
DROPS THE- AGAIN THROUGH OUR
RACIAL EQUITY LANDS 86% OF
PEOPLE IN C. TWO C. R. FOR
ROBBERY. MORE PEOPLE OF COLOR
THE RULE OVER EIGHT THOUSAND
UNARMED COMMERCIAL OPERATION
CALIFORNIANS TWO THOUSAND AND
NINETEEN. AND EXPERIENCE TELLS
US THAT MANY. YES THIS
ROBBERIES. INVOLVE PEOPLE WHO
ARE. PRINT FROM SOME UNMET PEER
BILL NAY. ON THE- BECAME THE CA
BECAME COME THAT SUCH. ARE TOO
LIBERALLY AND FREQUENTLY USE.
TO RAISE WARMER ADMITTED PETTY
CASH TO FELONY STRIKE OFFENSE
ALL THE CONSEQUENCES. THAT
ENSUE- MANY THE CASES THAT I.
OBSERVED IN MY TWENTY FIVE
YEARS WHERE PETTY THEFTS WERE
ELEVATED TO FIRST DEGREE
ROBBERY. STRIKE OFFENSES-
INVOLVED PEOPLE WHO WERE
SUFFERING FROM AN THAT THE A
GROUP HEALTH NEEDS SUCH AS- IN
RECENT ILLNESS OR NON MEN
UNTREATED SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER WHICH CLEARLY AFFECTS
THEIR DECISION MAKING ABILITY-
WHEN IT AND- THEY ARE THEY ARE
RESPONSE TO BEING CONFRONTED
DURING A PETTY THEFT AFTER. THE
TYPICAL ESTAS ROBERT HE HAS
DESCRIBED BY SENATOR SKINNER IS
WHEN A PERSON ENTERS THE STORE
GRAB SOME SORT OF MERCHANDISE
AND ONE. CONFRONTED BY STORE
SECURITY ARE OUR EMPLOYEES AT
THE STORE USING SOME LEVEL OF
THREAT OR- SOME OF THEM OF
COURSE TRY TO ESCAPE. SOMETIMES
A IS CAN BE A SIMPLE. PUSHING
AND SHE TO ESCAPE GRASP. OF
SOME OF THE TO THEM- AND IT YOU
KNOW- THERE ARE SOME SICK
PORTION OF THE POP. BOTH IN THE
COUNTY JAIL IN THE STATE PRISON
SYSTEM COURT PEOPLE WHO SUFFER
FROM ON THAT. HEALTH MAKES.
FUND UNTREATED BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH NEEDS IN EGYPT FOR
EXAMPLE THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY
JAIL WHICH IS A MAJOR TRIBUTARY
TO THE CDC ARE HAS SIX
THOUSAND- PERSONS WHO ARE IN
SOME FORM OF MENTAL HEALTH
HOUSING RIGHT NOW SO. THIS IS
AN ISSUE- THAT THE COMMISSION
TOOK VERY SERIOUSLY CONSIDERED-
THE GREAT PLAINS YOU HEARD FROM
THE DH. WE THAT WE RECEIVED
TESTIMONY FROM WE ALSO RECEIVED
TESTIMONY FROM STEVE WAGSTAFFE
FROM- SANTA CLARA OR SAN MATEO
COUNTY- AND- I THINK THE
SENATORS BILLS IS A. IS A
RATIONAL RESPONSE- TO THE
PROBLEM OF THE TRY USE THANK
YOU. DO YOU. DONALD THAT'S
SUPER WITNESS WILL COME TO ROOM
FORTY TWO OLD THREE AND TWO
THIRDS ANY WITNESSES HERE WHO
ARE. TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT OF
S. B. EIGHTY TWO. SHE NINE
LET'S MOVE NOW THE ROOM AT
TWENTY FORTY SEEKING WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT OF S. B. EIGHTY TWO
C. NINE WILL NOW GO TO OUR
PHONE LINES MODERATOR DO WE
HAVE ANY CALLERS IN Q. ON
WANTING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF. S. B. EIGHTY TWO. THANK YOU
IF YOU WISH TO MAKE A COMMENT
IN SUPPORT OF SB EIGHT TWO
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT
THIS TIME. AND WE CURRENTLY
HAVE ABOUT TWENTY FIVE IN Q.
FOUR FY NINETY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. RIGHT I DON'T MIND
MISTER CHAIR. GOOD AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS MAKE A
DOCTOR OFF ON BEHALF OF THE
ACLU OF CALIFORNIA AND STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
I'M TWO OR THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THE COMMANDER YEAH MAN
AND I AM FROM TYPING CALIFORNIA
AND I'M STRONG SUPPORT. THANK
YOU ALL RIGHT SIXTY ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. SEMENTARA BEHALF OF
THE PROSECUTORS GOING TO
CALIFORNIA AND FLORIDA TO
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU I'M TO TEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MARGO GEORGE UP FROM THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION PROUD CO SPONSOR IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU LINE ONE NINETY SIX PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON AGAIN
SHARED SENATORS ASKING TOO MUCH
YOU KNOW ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIANS FOR SAFETY JUSTICE
WE ARE PROUD CO SPONSORS OF SB
EIGHTY TWO THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ALL RIGHT TO TWENTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NOT ON BEHALF BUT
CALIFORNIA ATTORNEYS FOR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE. SPONSORED
APPS THIS COURT. THANK YOU
RIGHT TO SIXTY TO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
JIM LAMBERT ON BEHALF OF THE
FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON
LEGISLATION THAT CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT OF BREAST E. EIGHTY TWO
THANK YOU. THANK YOU I'M FORTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE FOUR
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. LATER
HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA RELIGIOUS ACTION
CENTER OF REFORM JUDAISM IN
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT NINETY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON AGAINCHAIRED
SENATORS AND EIGHTY COMING OFF
CALLING ON BEHALF OF PROJECT
KINSHIP BASED OUT OF SANTA ANA
ORANGE COUNTY WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT FOR SB EIGHTY TWO THANK
YOU. THANK YOU I'M TWO ZERO
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU ALL RIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ONE ONE SHISHI PLEASE GO AHEAD.
AFTERNOON THIS IS GREGORY SET
UP WITH THIS **** JUSTICE
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU ALL RIGHT FORTY FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MEDIANTE MANAGEMENT
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU I'M
SIXTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ATTORNEY ERIC SCHWEITZER FRESNO
CALIFORNIA IN EMPHATIC SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL THANK YOU. THANK
YOU ALL RIGHT TO FIFTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE TWO FIVE
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE ONE
NINETY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
JANA KLEIN WITH THE SAN DIEGO
COUNTY PUBLIC DEFENDER'S OFFICE
I AM IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU BYE
NINETY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
WELL I NINE THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. CAN YOU HEAR ME RIGHT.
PINE TO SIXTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME
IS SHOPPING ON BEHALF OF API
PACIFIC EMPOWERMENT EDUCATION
FUND WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF AT.
EIGHT EIGHT. THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT ONE TWENTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON- THE
SALLY MARTINEZ ON BEHALF OF
FRESNO BUT IF WE DON'T ON IN
STRONG SUPPORT FOR SB BECAUSE.
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT EIGHTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. LINE EIGHT SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. FIVE FIFTY TO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. CHRIS HI CAN
YOU HEAR ME. YES PLEASE GO
AHEAD. J. FOR A AYE- MEDICATION
BECAUSE OF THE POOR COMMITTEE
FULL CONTROL OF TOWN IS STRONG
SUPPORT OF S. B. INTO. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT FIFTY
THREE PLEASE CALL AT. NINE FIVE
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
CATHERINE LEVINE OFFICIALS FOR
FAMILIES I'M CALLING- IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB EIGHTY TWO. THANK
YOU ARE LYING TO FORTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. CANACCORD ON
ON BEHALF OF THE CAMPING FISCAL
PUBLIC DEFENDER'S OFFICE IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT
EIGHTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. Y.
EIGHT SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE
ONE SIXTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NINE ONE SIX FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. IT'S FIFTY FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI CAN YOU HEAR ME.
YES PLEASE GO AHEAD- GOOD
AFTERNOON WHEN A DATABASE
ISRAELI VIA WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ALLIANCE FOR YOUTH AND
COMMUNITY JUSTICE INSTRUCTS
REPORT. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT TO
THIRTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NINE TWO THREE THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. WELL HELLO MANY MISSIONS
MOMENT IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK
YOU ALL RIGHT INTO SIXTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
ONE PACKAGE FOR ELLA BAKER
CENTER FOR HUMAN RIGHTS AND
DRUG POLICY ALLIANCE IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT
TO TWENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI MY NAME IS THAT OUR ECONOMY
AND I'M CALLING IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF A SPEEDY TO. THANK
YOU THANK YOU ALL RIGHT NINETY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. WHY NINE
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE LINE
TO SEVENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
RIGHT THE COMMITTEE- ESPANA
EXAMPLE WOULD BE INTERESTED IN
THAT THE COALITION IN STRONG
SUPPORT THAT'S THE EIGHTY TWO
THANK YOU. THANK YOU APPLYING
TO FORTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NINE TWO FOUR ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NINE TWO SEVENTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
DONNA PROVIDING DEPUTY PUBLIC
DEFENDER AND CPD A LEGISLATIVE
COMMITTEE MEMBER PROUD CO
SPONSOR AND OFFERING STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT
TWO SIXTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO YES PLEASE GO AHEAD.
AMANDA'S FRANKLIN IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT
TWO SEVENTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
LOG IN TO YOUR PUBLIC SAFETY
ADVISOR CALIFORNIA CITY
INJUSTICE IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT TO FIFTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. BLIND TWO
FIVE FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. JUST
AS A REMINDER SHE WISHES TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF S. B.
EIGHTY TWO PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME LINE
SEVENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
BUT. NINE SEVEN SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NINE TO FORTY ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. TRYING TO FOUR ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THREE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. CAN YOU HEAR ME. YES
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON. YOU WANT TO LET YOU
GUYS KNOW THAT IT SEEMS LIKE
WE'RE HAVING ISSUE I WAS NOT
GIVEN THE NUMBER IN Q. FIVE
HAVE TO BE GUESSING WHEN MY
TURN COMES BACK AND THAT'S
PROBABLY WHY YOU'RE NOT GETTING
A LOT OF RESPONSES BUT I AM IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF- SB. EIGHTY
TWO. THANK YOU. THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT EIGHTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. AFTERNOON HERE AND
FINISH HER MY NAME IS YOU KNOW
CALL MAJOR AND I'M CALLING IN
STRONG SUPPORT AT BEING EIGHTY
TWO ON BEHALF OF CRIME THE
BARBECUE STEAK INJECTED AN
EMPIRE THANK YOU. THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT INTO EIGHTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI THIS IS CLARISSA
THANK BUT WITH RESTORED JUSTIN
IN THE COURT. THANK YOU ARE
GOING TO SEVENTY EIGHT PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS GINA
HERNANDEZ AND I AM IN SUPPORT
OF THE EIGHTY. THANK YOU ONLINE
ONE THIRTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MY IDEA I'M IMPROPRIETIES-
EIGHTY THREE EIGHTY TWO. THANK
YOU WERE GOING TO ASK YOU TO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
NATASHA BAKER AND I'M A
RESIDENT OF OAKLAND CALIFORNIA
I AM ALSO CALLING TRUMP
SUPPORTED XBT KILL. THANK YOU
ALL RIGHT TWO FIFTY FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YES PLEASE GO AHEAD.
I ALSO WAS NOT GIVEN A NUMBER
JUST FY I JUST WANTED TO- ECHO
THE ONE OF THE LAST SPEAKERS
BUT- I AM CALLING FROM OAKLAND
EGYPT PAVIA PEACE MOVEMENT IN
SUPPORT OF SB EIGHTY TWO. THANK
YOU. YOUR LINE TO EIGHTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO ASK. GOOD AFTERNOON
STEPHANIE REGULAR PUBLIC
DEFENDER'S OFFICE CONTRA COSTA
COUNTY IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK
YOU ONE MOMENT FOR THE NEXT
COMMENT. AND OUR LAST COMMENT
IS FROM ONE THING TO EIGHTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE GERMAN THE
NUMBER THIS IS YOUR LANDA
NUMBER READY WITH INITIATE
JOHNSON FROM STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU RYAN CHIU FORTY
WARNING PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE
TO FORTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME. YES
PLEASE GO AHEAD THE BILL WITH
THE FAMILY THE PUBLIC
DEFENDER'S OFFICE AND ON THE
COURT OF AT THE. TWO THANK YOU
I HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT THANK
YOU AT THIS TIME. OKAY
MODERATOR DISCUSS ONE MORE TIME
TO JUST TO SEE IF THERE ARE ANY
POTENTIAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
BEFORE WE MOVE ON TO OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO MAKE A
COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF S. B.
EIGHTY TWO PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. NINE
ONE SIX THREE FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. CAN YOU HEAR ME. YES
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS
TAYLOR HOW ARE YOU AND I AM
STRONG SUPPORT FOR SB EIGHTY
TWO THANK YOU THANK YOU. FOR
THANK YOU AND I HAVE ONE MORE
IN Q. FROM LINE. TWO HUNDRED
EIGHTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GREEN CARILLO FROM SAN DIEGO
COUNTY IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
EACH YEAR. THANK YOU THANK YOU
I HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENTS
THANK YOU AT THIS TIME THANK
YOU MODERATOR NOW WE'RE GOING
TO MOVE TO OPPOSITION AND I SEE
WE HAVE ONE LEAD- WITNESS WHO
SPEAKING IN AN OPPOSITION OF S.
B. EIGHTY TWO AND THAT IS
FRANKLY. MODERATORS MR LEE
PREPARED FOR HIS TESTIMONY.
THANK YOU DON'T MIND EVERYBODY.
GOOD AFTERNOON EVERYBODY WE
STRONGLY OPPOSED TO SB EIGHTY
TWO WHICH IS DISASTROUS TO OUR
STATE AB WAS PASSED. WITHOUT
THE USE OF WEAPON OR SERIOUS
INJURY WE WAS CONSIDERED AS
PETTY THEFT HELLO TO PARDONING
WALKERS THE LEGAL DEFINITION OF
SERIOUS INJURY IS NARROW AND
SPECIFIC DOES ACCORDING TO
DISTRICT ATTORNEYS EVEN EVEN
THOUGH WE TALK SUFFERS WITH
BLOODY NOSE BLACKBODY OOZES
ETCETERA AS LONG AS THE RUBBLE
IS WITHOUT WEAPON IS TYPED UP
VIOLENT ROBBERY YES TO BE
CONSIDERED AS THE ONLY VIOLENT
I DID THAT UNDER S. B. EIGHTY
TWO. THIS IS THE LOGICAL AND
THE SAFETY OF. EVERYBODY WHY
PROP FORTY SEVEN IN DANGERS I
GOING TO JUST BE TO STEAL. S.
B. EIGHTY TWO M. PEOPLE TO.
THIS BILL SEEMINGLY HAS NOT
COME. THAT GENDER BASED. H.
NEED TO AND SO DESPITE AMONG.
MANY CRIMINALS CAN USE BECAUSE
HARM PHYSICALLY INSIDE. TODAY
VICTIMS WITH THE USE WEAPONS
SHE IS SHE DOES AND WOMEN ARE
THE MOST AND THE THIS BILL
WHICH ALSO HAS NOT CONSIDER.
LIKE A LOGICAL HARM PROPERLY.
WELL THE COMMISSION BE EXCUSE
OF MOORING PRISON COST. BUT
EVERY TIME NEEDS OF ALL SYSTEM
NEGATIVE WE'VE- TO MAINTAIN ALL
AND ALL. THE TOP. SHOULD BE
GIVEN TO LAW CITIZENS ON THE OF
SAFETY AND WELL BEING. IT
APPARENTLY WE HAVE SO MANY
HIGHLY VISIBLE WHAT WE CASES
HERE CAPTURING THE ATTENTION OF
THE WORLD BECAUSE THE CITIZENS
TO AVOID PUBLIC STREETS. THIS
BILL IS JUST. GOING TO THE
OPPOSITE DIRECTION. YEAH THAT'S
KIND OF WHAT POLICE. BECAUSE
LEADERS AS A AND VOEPEL I'LL
HERE BECAUSE- S. EIGHTY TWO IS
A BIG. THING DETERMINE TO BE
ABLE AND MUST REJECT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU- WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION MODERATOR DO WE HAVE
CALLERS IN Q. FOUR OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO MAKE A
COMMENT IN OPPOSITION OF SPD TO
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. AND WE HAVE ABOUT
SIXTEEN IN Q. WAR TIMELINE ONE
TWENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YEAH PLEASE GO AHEAD. OKAY MY
NAME IS SHERRY AND I'M RESIDENT
OF LOS ANGELES COUNTY I'M
CALLING IN TO RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSED TO THE S. B. EIGHTY
ONE. EIGHTY TWO BECAUSE. I
THINK IS REALLY HARMFUL. OKAY
ALL. PEOPLE ARE WE. WEAKER THAN
THE MOST OF THE CRIMINALS
BECAUSE WE FEEL. ARJUN'S FROM
KIND TO MEDICAL GROCERS WHICH
ALREADY BACKGROUND WHAT IS IN
YOUR NAME AND YOUR ORGANIZATION
AND YOUR OPPOSITION TO THE
MEASURE WE'VE TAKEN PRIMARY
TESTIMONY. OKAY HELLO I'M
CALLING TO- POSTER S. B. EIGHTY
TWO THANK YOU. THANK YOU RIGHT
ONE THIRTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO THIS IS RYAN COUSINS
ASSISTANT CHIEF DEPUTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY WITH THE L. A. COUNTY
CALIFORNIA BY. STATE OUR
OPPOSITION IT WOULD MEAN A
FELONY OR A MISDEMEANOR WOULD
TURN ON HOW WELL THE VICTIM
TAKES A PUNCH AND THAT IS NOT
ACCEPTABLE. THANK YOU RYAN ONE
SIXTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN
MICHELLE THOMAS JOB
REPRESENTING THE ALAMEDA COUNTY
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S OFFICE AND
THE CALIFORNIA DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION AND
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU RYAN WON ALL FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU RYAN
ONE ZERO FIVE YOUR OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. IT OKAY FOR GOODNESS
DISTRICT ATTORNEY KINGS COUNTY
FOR RETURN TO RESPECT AND
RESPONSIBILITY I STRONGLY URGE
IN OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL AS
IT FURTHER ERODES OUR- CITIZENS
SECURITY AND SAFETY AND FEELING
SECURE THEIR OWN PRESENCE AND-
SO I STRONGLY URGE AND AN
OPPOSITION TO THIS WE ALREADY
HAVE FORTY SEVEN SEAT WHICH IS
THE INTERMEDIARY WHICH IS
TAILORED TO A CASE BY CASE
SITUATION AND ITS BILLING
REALLY REDUNDANT AND
UNNECESSARY. MY GOODNESS THANK
YOU. RIGHT TO FIFTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE TWO FIVE
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. YEAH
GOOD AFTERNOON- I DISCUSS THE
CUSTOM I STRONGLY OPPOSE I
SPEAK TO ON BEHALF OF ALL MY
ALL MOMS I KNOW. THANK YOU NINE
TO FIFTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI WARREN CHU FOR A REASON
OAKLAND AND MEMBER OF THE OPEN
CHINATOWN CHAMBER OF COMMERCE I
STRONGLY OPPOSED SB EIGHTY TWO
THOUSAND THE PROGRESSIVE BUT
THEY'RE WAY TOO MANY LOOPHOLES
IN IT. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT TO
SIXTY FOUR POINT. GOOD
AFTERNOON JIM KERBER SAN
DIEGANS AGAINST CRIME STRONGLY
OPPOSE SB EIGHTY TO A BLACK GUY
IS NOT G. B. I. UNDER THE LAW.
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT TO SEVENTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. I DIDN'T
FEEL YOU CAN CALL ME WITH A
CALIFORNIA AND IT IS NOT THE
UNITED STATES- STRONGLY AGAIN.
POSTED AT THE END YOU CAN THANK
YOU. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT A ONE
SIXTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YES THIS IS ABOUT CALL FROM
THE- ALAMEDA COUNTY AND I THINK
THERE'S A LOT OF LOOPHOLES AND
UNCERTAINTY. AND I OPPOSE SB
EIGHTY TWO. THANK YOU OF MINE
ONE EIGHTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI I'M JOE SWOON. I'M
SHANIA OPPOSE SB. EIGHTY TWO.
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT TO THIRTY
TO PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE TRAIN
OAKLAND NATIVE AND CONSTITUENTS
SENATOR SKINNER AND I'LL BE
HAPPY TO OPEN CHINA COUNTY
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE- I THINK
THE TIMING SB TWO IS
INSENSITIVE TONE DEAF AND
LACKED INPUT. SO I OPPOSE SB
EIGHTY TWO. THANK MIND SIXTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE SIX
H. PLEASE GO AHEAD. TRYING TO
NINETY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO THIS IS MATTHEW GRECO
FROM SAN DIEGO TO SAN DIEGANS
AGAINST CRIME WERE STRONGLY
OPPOSED TO SPD TO URGE A NO
VOTE. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT ONE
SEVENTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. I
LIVE IN THE HAN SAN FRANCISCO I
STRONGLY OPPOSE SB EIGHTY TWO
BECAUSE AGAIN IT IS VERY
UNCLEAR AND- TRYING TO MAKE A
DISTINCT. DETERMINATION BECOMES
A FELONY OR MISDEMEANOR THANK
YOU I DON'T THINK WHAT IS BEING
PROPOSED IS ACTUALLY ADEQUATE
TO ACHIEVE THAT WITH. THANK YOU
KNOW INJURIES ARE AS A REMINDER
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF SB EIGHTY TWO
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. AND WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO NINETY EIGHT PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO IF ANY YEAH YES
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES I JUST
CALLED YOU. EIGHTY TWO HI
NOTHING ABOUT THE THANK YOU IT
READ INCREASE THE CRIME
ESPECIALLY FOR THE ASIAN
COMMUNITY IT'S VERY EASY TO GET
ROB. CATCH WHATEVER. EXAMPLE
WOULD I GET ONE THOUSAND DOLLAR
RETENTION FIFTY DOLLAR AND THEN
THE ROCK AGAINST FREE IT'S SO
UNFAIR CHECK THE NEWS ALL THE
ASIAN COMMUNITY EVEN JUST NOT
ASIAN COMMUNITY. IF THREE TO
INCREASE THE HATE OKAY SO
PLEASE MONNOT ON AT THE- AB TWO
I PRESENT YOUR THE FOUNDATION
IN SOUTH IN CALIFORNIA NAME
BELIEVE RIGHT NOW. THANK. YOU
THANK YOU. THANK YOU RIGHT ONE
SEVENTY PLEASE AHEAD. THIS IS
KELLY READ WITH KEEP TELL SFE
AND I URGE NOVO ON IT T. E. TWO
THANK. THANK YOU OF MINE ONE
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE ONE
SEVEN NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
BUYING TWO ZERO NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NINE TWO ZERO NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE. NINE
SIXTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO LINE SIXTY EIGHT PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME
YEAH PLEASE GO AHEAD. I'M SORRY
I DIDN'T KNOW I WAS GOING TO
CREATE- YEAH WHAT IN THE WORLD.
THIS IS RIDICULOUS I OPPOSED-
EIGHTY TALE- I APPRECIATE YOU
GUYS HAVING THE PHONE CALL THAT
WE CAN DO THIS OVER THE PHONE.
THAT ARE COMING BACK ON THANK
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT FOR
THE THANK YOUR ONE SEVENTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. RIGHT ONE
SEVENTY LAKH NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME THIS
FIGURE YOU LOOK AT. I HAD. IT
MADE NON EMERGENCY COULD BE I
STRONGLY- SB EIGHTY TO ENSURE
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES.
NORTHERN IRELAND CRIMES. THANK
YOU I HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT
THANK YOU AT THIS TIME. THANK
YOU- WELL I UNDERSTAND A LOT OF
PEOPLE CANNOT GET THROUGH I GOT
NUMEROUS COMPLAINTS RIGHT NOW
WE HAVE BEEN WAITING FOR OUR
STATE THEY WILL NOT NOT GIVEN
THE NUMBER THEY WERE
COMPLAINING TO ME RIGHT NOW AT
LEAST A THOUSAND OR MORE PEOPLE
WAITING IN LINE ARE YOU ARE YOU
WILL NOT GIVE THEM THE NUMBER-
GA QUEUE UP ONE MORE TIME TO IF
THERE'S ANY OTHER- COLLARS AND
OPPOSITION. MODERATOR PLEASE.
THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO MAKE A
COMMENT IN OPPOSITION OF S. B.
EIGHTY TWO PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. I HAVE
THREE IN Q. IT'LL JUST BE ONE
MOMENT FOR OUR FIRST ONE. RIGHT
TWO ZERO NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NINE TWO ZERO NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. WELL I AM
THREE ZERO THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YES HI I HEAR ONLY. HE'S
A. TWO YEARS OR YOUR HEAD
DOESN'T WILL COLLECT ARE
USUALLY WHERE WE CALL. OKAY
THEN WHEN YOU ARE YOU WITH YOUR
NAME YOUR WORKERS PEOPLE OR BE
ROB THE PEOPLE ARE HAPPY THIS
YEAR I AM YOUR- THANK THAT'S
ALL NEED AND YOUR POSITION
THANK YOU. THANK YOU I'M THREE
OH TWO PLEASE CALL AHEAD. I
MEAN A YOUNG I- FROM SANFORD
STRONGLY. THAT. EIGHT YOU.
THANK YOU RIGHT TO NINETY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE TWO NINE
EIGHT PLEASE CALL AHEAD. I HAVE
NO FOR COMMENTS THANK YOU AT
THIS TIME. THANK YOU. WE'RE
GONNA BRING ABOUT TO THE
COMMITTEE QUESTION OR CONCERNS
BY THE COMMITTEE SENATOR WIENER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THOMAS
CHAIRMAN I KNOW. I'VE BEEN
HEARING A LOT OF THIS BOB WE
HEARD BUT HERE IN THE- OF SOME
OF THE HORRIFIC AT.
PARTICULARLY ON OUR API TO.
RECENTLY WHICH WE'VE BEEN
SAYING. IT ALL OVER WITH THE UP.
AND UP TO CAN HE CRY. AGAINST A
P. I. P. FUELED BY A LAW OF
WHAT'S OVER OF THE- RACIST.
MADE OVER THE LAST YEAR- IN IN
MY COMMUNITY IN SAN FRANCISCO.
WE'VE GOT A TAX ON SENIORS AND
IT'S CAN AND THE PHILIPPINE CAN.
AND THE COMMUNITY- AND IS. VERY
AN AWFUL AND WE NEED TO MAKE
SURE. THAT OUR COMMUNITY
WORKING HAND IN GLOVE. WITH OUR
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT IS
APPREHENDING- THESE
PERPETRATORS AND THAT THEY ARE
HELD ACCOUNTABLE. FOR THEIR
HORRIFIC ACTIONS WE'VE ALSO
SEEN- STORES TARGETED IT'S
REALLY IT IS. IT IS TO. THE
PROBLEM IS REAL- AND FOR. FIVE
SEEN ON ENORMOUS AMOUNT OF IN
OUR AND- ABOUT THIS BILL. THIS
BILL DOES NOT IF YOU SAW
SOMEONE. THAT IS A DIFFERENT
CROSS. NINE RAW FOR PETTY. IF
GO UP TO US. AND SHALL THAT
SENIOR TO THE- YOU A AGAINST
SENIOR IF YOU'RE INTO THAT
SCENE- YOU CAN BE CHARGED WITH
A- IF GOD FORBID THAT SCENE
TYRESE OR WHETHER OR NOT THE
PER SENIOR DOT. THAT IT IS
MURDER OR- OR SOME OF CRIME AND
NOTHING IN BILL CHANGES. I'D
PUT SOME INSTANCE ALSO FACEP.
IT SAYS IF SB EIGHT TWO IS
ASSAULTS LOS WRONG WITHOUT A-
ONE BE A FELON ANYMORE. BUT
THAT'S THE BEST FALLS. COMMIT
ROBBERY WITH VIOLENCE IT IS
STILL A FELONY ROBBERY IN
ADDITION TO AN ASSAULT. ANYONE
IF YOU ASSAULTED THE PERSON.
AND SO YOU KNOW THIS THIS COMES
OUT OF THE PENAL REVIEW
COMMISSION I WANT TO THANK
CENTER SKINNER FOR DOING
ENORMOUS WORK ON THAT COMMITTEE
FOR YEARS THAT IS A COMMITTEE
THAT WAS MADE UP OF A BROAD
CROSS SECTION. OF THE COMMUNITY
INCLUDING JUDGES INCLUDING
DISTRICT ATTORNEYS AND PUBLIC
DEFENDERS AND PRIVATE CRIMINAL
DEFENSE ATTORNEYS AND
LEGISLATORS AND OTHERS AND THE
GOAL IS TO SAY YOUR WE HAVE
PROVISIONS IN OUR PENAL CODE
THAT HAVE BEEN THERE FOR
SOMETIMES A HUNDRED AND FIFTY
YEARS OR A HUNDRED THIRTY.
YEARS AND I'VE NEVER BEEN
TOUCHED AND HOW ARE THEY BEING
APPLIED TODAY AND IS THAT
APPROPRIATE- AND WE SEE THAT BY
TIMES SOME DISTRICT ATTORNEYS
ARE OVERCHARGING- YOU KNOW WHAT
WHEN AND TURNING WHAT IS NOT A
SITUATION WHERE YOU'RE GOING
AND GOING AND INJURING SOMEONE
AND COMMITTING A TERRIBLE CRIME
AGAINST SOMEONE. AND TURNING IT
FROM A MISDEMEANOR INTO A
FELONY- SUIT YOU KNOW THIS AND
WE ALSO HAVE TO BE CLEARING
THIS COMES UP A LOT IT COMES UP
IN OTHER CONTEXTS. MISDEMEANORS
A REAL CRIME. MR YOU CAN GO TO
COUNTY JAIL FOR A YEAR FOR A
MISDEMEANOR I WOULDN'T WANT TO
GO TO COUNTY JAIL FOR A YEAR.
THAT'S A SERIOUS PUNISHMENT-
AND IF YOU COMMIT. A CRIME
WHERE YOU'RE REALLY ENTERING
SOMEONE WE'RE ASSAULTING THEM
YOU CAN GO TO STATE PRISON
STILL. EVEN WITH SB EIGHTY TWO.
SO I THINK IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT FOR PEOPLE TO FOCUS
ON WHAT THIS BILL DOES AND WHAT
IT DOESN'T DO- AND I UNDERSTAND
PEOPLE ARE. REALLY ANGRY AND
SCARED ABOUT WHAT'S HAPPENING
IN THE COMMUNITY I SHARE THAT
ANGER. TURNS MY STOMACH WHEN I
SEE WHAT PEOPLE ARE CAPABLE OF
DOING TO OTHER PEOPLE-
PARTICULARLY TO SOME OF OUR
MOST VULNERABLE SENIORS IT IS
DESPICABLE. AND IT NEEDS TO BE
THE PEOPLE NEED TO BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE. BUT THAT'S NOT
WHAT THIS BILL. IS ABOUT- AND
SO I SUPPORT THIS BILL- I DON'T
MOVE IT. AND I HOPE THAT PEOPLE
WHO ARE AS CONCERNED AS WE ALL
ARE ABOUT WHAT'S HAPPENING THE
COMMUNITY. CAN FOCUS ON THE
FACTS HERE. AND REALLY FOCUS ON
HAVING ACCURATE FACTS ABOUT
THIS LEGISLATION AND ANY
LEGISLATION. I KNOW LIKE MY
COLLEAGUES I NEVER HAVE A
PROBLEM FOR BEING CRITICIZED.
FOR WHAT I DO AND I'M SURE
CENTER SKINNER IS OF THE SAME
MIND BUT I BUT IT'S BUT IT'S
NOT RIGHT. TO CRITICIZE SOMEONE
FOR WHAT THEY DIDN'T DO- AND
THAT IS HAPPENING HERE WITH US
YOU TO SOME OF THE BILL. THANK
YOU ANY DISAGREEMENTS BY
COLLEAGUES HERE. IN NINETEEN
NINE I JUST ALSO JUST WANNA
RECALLED BACK WHICH A SENATOR
WINNER JUST STATED- THIS BILL
DOES NOT MINIMIZE CRIME IN ANY
SHAPE FORM OR FASHION AND IN
FACT IT ENHANCES THE TIME THAT
ONE WOULD DO FROM SIX MONTHS TO
A YEAR FOR A MISDEMEANOR THEFT.
AND I THINK THAT SIGNIFICANT
BUT AGAIN IT DOESN'T DO
ANYTHING AND HAS BEEN DESCRIBED
BY THE OPPOSITION TO MAKE ARE
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS WHETHER
IT'S OUR API COMMUNITY ANYONE
ANYMORE VULNERABLE AND LESS
LIKELY FOR THE OTHER INDIVIDUAL
WHO MIGHT ASSAULT SOMEONE TO BE
CHARGED FOR THAT CRIME WHAT
THIS DOES IS JUST. PREVENT
THERE ARE UNNECESSARY. CHARGES
FOR PEOPLE WHO ABUSE MINOR.
FORCE IN THE COMMISSION OF THAT
CRIME AND THAT'S WHAT AND THE
SAYS SENATORS TRYING TO ADDRESS
HERE VERSUS- AGAIN OVER
SENTENCING PEOPLE- IN MANY WAYS
SO ON THAT NOTE- CENTERS CAN OR
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. HANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR APPRECIATE
THE- DISCUSSION SO FAR BY THE
COMMITTEE. NO THE MY COLLEAGUE
FOR SEARCHES GO REYES SUCH
THINGS AS ASSAULT. I WILL
ADDITIONALLY ADD BATTERY FOR
EXAMPLE THIS BILL DOES NOT
ELIMINATE BATTERY AND YOU CAN
BE CHARGED WITH EITHER THEFT OR
ROBBERY AND BATTERY YOU CAN BE
CHARGED WITH A HATE CRIME ALONG
WITH STAFF TO FOR EXAMPLE YOU
COULD BE CHARGED WITH ELDER
ABUSE YOU COULD BE CHARGED. THE
THING THAT WHAT HAPPENED SO
OFTEN IS WE CONFLATE THE CHANGE
OF WORK IN ONE STATUTE AS
AFFECTING ALL OTHER FACTORS
WHEN THIS DOES NOT AFFECT ALL
OTHER FACTORS NOW I USE THE
EXAMPLE OF A BLACK GUY VERY
SPECIFICALLY BECAUSE THERE IS
LITERALLY A NUMBER OF. COURT
CASES AND PRECEDENTS WHERE
BLACK I WAS DEFINED AS GREAT
BODILY INJURY. AND IF THERE IS
ANY TYPE OF GREAT BODILY INJURY
THEN SB EIGHTY TWO DOES NOT
APPLY AT ALL TO EVEN BRUISING.
IS UNDER. THE PENAL CODE AND
YOU CAN LOOK IT UP UNDER THE
DEFINITION OF PENAL CODE
INCLUDES FOR EXAMPLE PROVING
BRUISING. SO AS ARE A COLLEAGUE
FROM SEARCHES GROUP DESCRIBED.
THERE'S BEEN A HORRIFIC
INCREASE OF CRIMES AGAINST- OUR
API COMMUNITY BEYOND THERE IS
FEAR NOW THAT ANY TYPE OF
CHANGES IN OUR PENAL CODE MIGHT
MOTIVATE UCH CRIMINALS TO
CONTINUE TO PREY ON OUR API
COMMUNITY WITH APPS I AM
ABSOLUTELY. OPPOSED TO ANYTHING
THAT WOULD INCREASE THOSE
CRIMES AGAINST OUR API
COMMUNITY AND I WANT SUCH
CRIMES TO BE FULLY FULLY
ENFORCED AND TO IF THEY HAVE A
HATE. PRIME COMPONENT TO THEM
TO HAVE THE ADDITION OF THE
HATE CRIME ADDED. AND IF
THERE'S ANY TYPE OF SERIOUS
INJURY FOR- FOR EXAMPLE SOME
FOLKS NOT NECESSARILY THOSE WHO
CALLED IN BUT YOU SEE I THINK
SOMEONE WHO DID CALL INDEED YOU
SUS EXAMPLE. IF A PERSON SHOP
SOMEONE AN ELDERLY PERSON FOR
EXAMPLE OFF THE BENCH THEY HAVE
NOT COMMITTED THE THEFT YET
THEY'VE SHOPPED PERSON
VIOLENTLY OFF THE BENCH. THEN
THE COMMIT THE THEFT THERE ARE
TWO CRIMES THERE THERE'S NOT
JUST THE THEFT THERE IS THE
EITHER BATTERY OR ASSAULT OF
THE SHOVING THEM OFF THE BENCH.
SO  WANTED TO BE VERY CLEAR
THAT EIGHTY TWO IS NOT TRYING
TO ADDRESS THAT TYPE OF
CIRCUMSTANCE OR CREATE ANY TYPE
OF LESSER CHARGE FOR THAT
CIRCUMSTANCE- NOW IT IS
ENTIRELY THE CASE THAT THERE
MAY BE A NEED AS WE GO THROUGH
THE PROCESS TO CLARIFY SOME
DEFINITIONS BECAUSE OBVIOUSLY
IT IS CREATED SOME CONFUSION
BUT I THINK THAT UNFORTUNATELY
SOME OF THOSE AND ARE
PROSECUTED PROSECUTOR COMMUNITY
HAVE USED THIS BECAUSE THEY
OPPOSE THIS BILL. THEY HAVE
INFLAMED SOME LEGITIMATE FEARS
ON PEOPLE'S PARTS NONE OF US
WANT TO BE A VICTIM OF CRIME I
DON'T CARE WHAT THE CRIME IS I
DON'T CARE WHAT ANY LEVEL I DO
NOT NOR DOES ANYONE ELSE WANT
TO BE A VICTIM OF CRIME. NOR DO
I EVER FEEL GOOD ABOUT ANY TYPE
OF CRIME DOESN'T EVEN MATTER IF
THERE IS STILL APPROPRIATE.
SENTENCES FOR APPROPRIATE
CRIMES AND THAT IS WHAT I AM
TRYING TO DO IN SB EIGHTY TWO
AND I DON'T THINK IT IS
APPROPRIATE TO PREY UPON
PEOPLE'S LEGITIMATE EMOTIONS
ABOUT CRIME IN THIS PARTICULAR
CASE WHICH I THINK HAS BEEN
DONE- I DID TAKE A NIGHT
APOLOGIES CHAIR THAT I DID NOT
OPEN THAT I AM TAKING AN
AMENDMENT THAT EXCLUDES
ORGANIZED RETAIL CRIME THAT
WASN'T BRACED SO MUCH IN THIS
CALL BUT ONE OF THE CONCERNS
FOR EXAMPLE IS THAT WE HAVE HAD
AND WE DO HAVE NOW A SITUATION
WHERE. PEOPLE DELIBERATELY
STEAL FROM SAY THE SAME STORE
AGAIN REPEATEDLY AND KEEP THEIR
STEALING UNDER A CERTAIN DOLLAR
AMOUNT. ON AND JUST TO AVOID
HIGHER CHARGES. AND WE HAVE NOW
A NEW STATUTE. COVERING
ORGANIZED RETAIL. THEFT OR
ORGANIZED RETAIL CRIME AND SO I
AM MAKING SURE THAT THIS BILL
DOES NOT TOUCH OR INTERFERE
WITH THAT STATUTE AND SO I'VE
TAKEN THAT AMENDMENT. AND WITH
THAT I WOULD HOPE THAT THE
COMMITTEE APPRECIATES THAT THIS
BILL DOES NOT DO THE THINGS
THAT WERE ASSERTED AND I HOPE
THAT I. CAN GET TO RIDE VOTE.
THANK YOU ARE WE HAVE A MOTION
FIVE CENTER WIENER AND IT'S A
TO PASS AS POLLS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS. AT TO OUR
RECOMMENDATION. CAN OUR
CONSULTING CALL THE ROLL ON S.
B. EIGHTY TWO SB EIGHTY TO DO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS BRADFORD PARK
ROAD FOR DIET CHAU BOTH
RESPECTFUL NOW. BUT CHAO ABOVE
NO COM LAGER. KAMLAGER AYE
SKINNER. BY IN OUR AYE WIENER
AYE WIENER AYE AFFORDABLE AND-
SURE. SKINNER THAT'S OUT FOR
THE ONE. NOW WE'RE MOVING ON TO
SENATOR BATES THANK YOU FOR
WAITING SO PATIENTLY CENTER
VERY SINISTER. DO A LITTLE
HOUSE CLEANING KEEP IN WILL
HAVE YOU READY. S. SURVEYS WILL
BE PRESENTING S. B. TWO FORTY
EIGHT. AM I ON THE ON THE RADAR
I THANK YOU FROM MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO PRESENT SB TWO FORTY EIGHT A
CENTRALLY- IT WOULD EXTEND THE
PRESUMPTION OF OPENNESS THAT
EXISTS IN ALMOST ALL CALIFORNIA
COURT ROOMS TO PROCEEDINGS
UNDER THE SEXUALLY VIOLENT
PREDATOR ACT. RECENTLY TRIAL
COURT JUDGES CONSIDERING THE
POTENTIAL RELEASE OF SEXUALLY
VIOLENT PREDATORS INTO OUR
COMMUNITIES ARE ORDERING THAT
THOSE PROCEEDINGS BE CLOSED TO
THE PUBLIC HOWEVER UNDER THE
UNITED STATES CONSTITUTION
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC HAVE THE
RIGHT TO BE PRESENT AND HAVE
ACCESS TO COURT PROCEEDINGS. IN
SAN DIEGO MARY TAYLOR AND
CYNTHIA MEDINA WHO ARE BOTH
VICTIMS OF SEXUALLY VIOLENT
PREDATORS WE'RE NOT ALLOWED TO
ATTEND THE DEFENDANT'S COURT
PROCEEDINGS AND HAVE THEIR
VOICES HEARD AS A RESULT THEY
TOOK PART IN MULTIPLE PROTESTS
OUTSIDE OF THE SAN DIEGO
COURTHOUSE AND EVENTUALLY
FORMED THE GROUP YOUR VOICE HAS
POWER. SB TWO FORTY EIGHT
RESPONDING TO THESE PUBLIC
CONCERNS WOULD REQUIRE THAT
PROCEEDINGS FOR CIVIL
COMMITMENT OF SEXUALLY VIOLENT
PREDATOR AND SUBSEQUENT
HEARINGS REGARDING HIS OR HER
POTENTIAL RELIEF BE IN OPEN
COURT AND ON THE RECORD UNLESS
COMPELLING IN EXTRAORDINARY
CIRCUMSTANCES JUSTIFY CLOSING
THE COURTROOM TO THE PUBLIC. SB
TWO FORTY EIGHT CLOSES A
LOOPHOLE THAT ENSURES SEXUALLY
VIOLENT PREDATORS SHOULD RETURN
TO THE STATE HOSPITAL TO
CONTINUE. THE S. V. P. ORIGINAL
COMMITMENT TO CAPTURE NEW
PRISON SENTENCE HAS BEEN
COMPLETED AND I DO UNDERSTAND
THAT THE COMMITTEE YOUR ODD
CHAIRMAN'S- RECOMMENDED
AMENDMENTS DEAL WITHOUT ARE
ONLY AND I CERTAINLY ACCEPT OF
THOSE AMENDMENTS AND THANK. YOU
SO MUCH FOR WORKING AND I KNOW
THAT WHEN. THREE YESTERDAY AND
TODAY BUT I DO HAVE- SENATE
POSSIBLE I'D LIKE TO THANKS-
SAN DIEGO DISTRICT ATTORNEY
SUMMER STEPHAN FOR INTRODUCING
THE NEED FOR THE REGULATIONS
RINGING THE ISSUE BEFORE US.
AND HERE TODAY OR ON THE-
TELEPHONE IS DEPUTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY PATRICK ESPINOSA AND
MERRY TAYLOR. WITH YOUR VOICE
HAS POWER WHO WILL TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT TODAY OF THE BILL IN
ITS ENTIRETY BUT HAVE BEEN
INFORMED OF THE PROPOSED
AMENDMENT SO LET ME CALL ON
THEM- MISTER CHAIR. THANK YOU
WERE GOING OFFER YOUR PRIMARY
YOUR TWO PRIMARY MYTH WITNESSES
TWO MINUTE TO TESTIMONY EACH.
YES. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN
BRADFORD AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS
MY NAME IS PATRICK ESPINOSA.
CHIEF OF THE SEX CRIMES AND
HUMAN TRAFFICKING DIVISION OF
THE SAN DIEGO COUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE SUPERVISING
ALL SB PEOPLE THE CATION IN THE
COUNTY OF SAN DIEGO I'VE BEEN A
PROSECUTOR IN THE STATE
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE FOR OVER
TWENTY FIVE YEARS. IT SHOULD
ATTORNEY SUMMER STEPHAN AND THE
SAN DIEGO COUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE IS A SPONSOR
OF SB TWO FORTY EIGHT VERY CARE
ROCK WILL EXPLAIN THE
IMPORTANCE OF ALLOWING
SURVIVORS OF SEXUAL ASSAULT YOU
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO OBSERVE
THE SDP PROCESS WHEN THEIR
ATTACKER IS BEING CONSIDERED
FOR RELEASE BERMAN S. B. P.
COMMITMENT. HISTORICALLY S. B.
P. PROCEEDINGS I'VE ALWAYS BEEN
OPEN TO THE PUBLIC RECENTLY
DEFENSE LAWYERS HAVE BEEN
SEEKING TO CLOSE S. B. P.
HEARINGS IN THE CORALS CASE
VICTIMS WERE EXCLUDED FROM THE
COURT. AND THE JUDGE MADE THE
WRONG DECISION TO RELEASE THE
BOLDER THAN MOST RAPISTS THE
COURT'S DECISION TO RELEASE THE
STP WAS SUBSEQUENTLY REVERSED
BY THE APPELLATE COURT BUT THE
EXCLUSION OF THE VICTIMS COULD
NOT BE UNDONE OPPONENTS OF SB
TWO FORTY EIGHT HAVE ARGUED
THAT SB HEARINGS. SHOULD BE
TREATED WITH THE SAME LEVEL OF
CONFIDENTIALITY THAT APPLIES
AND LPS MENTAL HEALTH
PROCEEDINGS IN JUVENILE COURT
PROCEEDINGS WE WOULD WELCOME
SUCH AN AMENDMENT THAT WOULD
CARVE OUT AN EXCEPTION TO
SPECIFICALLY CODIFIED THE
VICTIMS RIGHT TO BE PRESENT AT
S. B. B. HEARINGS TO MERE LPS
WORDS OR JUVENILE COURT
HEARINGS. LPS PROCEEDINGS
WELFARE IN THESE INSTITUTIONS
CODE SECTION FIVE ONE ONE EIGHT
PERMITS ANY PARTY TO THE
PROCEEDING TO DEMAND TO BE HERE
AND BE PUBLIC IN JUVENILE
DELINQUENCY PROCEEDINGS WELFARE
AND INSTITUTIONS CODE SECTIONS
SIX SEVEN SIX POINT FIVE
PROVIDES VICTIMS OF CRIME THE
RIGHT TO BE PRESENT IN JUVENILE
PROCEEDINGS. AND ESTABLISHES A
PROCEDURE FOR EXCLUDING VICTIMS
OF CRIME PUNISHER IN OF
SUBSTANTIAL PROBABILITY
OVERRIDING INTEREST WILL BE
PREJUDICED BY THE PRESENCE OF
THE VICTIM WE WOULD WELCOME
SUCH AN AMENDMENT TO CODIFY THE
RIGHT OBJECTIVES TO BE
PRESIDENT S. B. B. HEARINGS
LIKE OCCURS IN JUVENILE COURT
HEARINGS WE WOULD ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE. ON SB TWO FORTY AT
TWO FORTY. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MIX WITH MISS TAYLOR. GOOD
AFTERNOON IS MERRY SELECT YOU
HEAR ME. THANK I'M HERE TO ASK
THE CALIFORNIA SENATE PUBLIC
FACE COMMITTEE TO SET F. TWO
FOR EIGHT I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF
SAN AS WELL AS MYSELF BOTH OF
US SURVIVE OF SEXUAL BY BOULDER
MOST RATE THIS WHO TERRORIZED
SICKENING OF SAN DIEGO BACK IN
THE NINETY EIGHTY WE ARE ALSO
SOUNDING MAY OF THE KEY GROUP
YOUR HOW POWER. B. THE VICTIM
OF A BY SEXUAL THOUGHT LEAST
THAT RUN THE- A PART OF THE-
PROCESS. IS REESTABLISHING YOUR
POWER. AND CONTROL. TO QUOTE
CYNTHIA IT IS HOW A PERSON TO
BEING A VICTIM TO A SURVIVOR.
HOW I IN SANDY. SAN DIEGO. GALA
THAT RIGHTS AS A VICTIM
SURVIVOR AND YOU COMMUNITY
MEMBER DIDN'T MATTER. WE
PERSONAL LEAVE BEHIND MADE OUR
WAY DOWN TO THE STANDING ZOO.
COURT FOR. WENT THROUGH SECURE.
STOOD OUT THE COURTROOM IN A
HOME WAIT FOR OUR- WAITING BE
LET IN. ONLY TWO OUT UNDER
OCCASIONS. THAT THE JUDGE
DECIDE TO. THE PROCEED. WITH
OUR A DANCE NOTICE AND WITH NO
LIKE FOR. OTHER THAN DAY
REFERENCE TO THE- RIGHT TO PRY.
HE WHERE WHERE ARE RIGHTS AS
THE AND JEANINE MEMBER. IT WAS
MORE THAN BEING INCONVENIENCED
I'M FEELING LIKE OUR K. AND
MONEY WERE WASTED. BY COOL THE
COURTS. JUDGE ALSO OFF ALL
ACCESS INFORMATION WOULD BE YOU.
IN MAKING CRITICAL THAT IN- AND
OUR ENTIRE CAN. IT WAS. EIGHTY
TO REALIZE. THAT RIGHTS NOT
MATCH AT ALL JUST LIKE THE DID
NOT TO THEME THE NIGHT HE
BROUGHT INTO OUR- AND IT HAS AT.
WE THOUGHT. AND FOLLOW AGAIN
THIS TIME BY THE COURT. SB TWO
FOUR EIGHT MAKE THE RIGHT OF
VICTIMS AND THE- RIGHT THE
PUBLIC. AT LEAST IN. TO THE
RIGHTS OF THE- NOT ONLY DOES IT
COMPOSED ON THE ARE THE JUST
THE SYSTEM MORE TRAINS. IT
GIVES OF BY YEAH TO GAIN BACK
THEIR- I URGE THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC SAFETY TO SUPPORT SENATE
BILL TWO FOUR EIGHT. THANK YOU.
GOOD A GOOD FIRM- ROOM AND SEE
IF THERE'S ANYONE HERE AND
FORTY TWO OH THREE WHO WISHES
TO TESTIFY CENA NO ONE
PRESIDENT WILL NOW MOVE TO ROOM
TWENTY FORTY. OR SEEN NO
WITNESSES THERE TO TESTIFY WILL
NOW MOVE TO OUR MODERATOR AND-
PASS FOR THOSE WISHING TO
TESTIFY TO BE CUTE- AND-
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT OF S. B.
TWO FOUR EIGHT MODERATOR. THANK
YOU IF YOU WISH TO MAKE A
COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF S. B. TWO
FOUR EIGHT PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE
CURRENTLY HAVE ABOUT TWENTY
FIVE IN THE QUEUE WE'LL GO TO
LINE ONE HUNDRED AND NINETEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS CYNTHIA MEDINA. I AM A CO
FOUNDER OF YOUR VOICE HAS POWER.
AND IT WILL BE A MUCH SEXUAL
ASSAULT SINCE THE AGE OF FOUR I
MULTIPLE CREDITORS. WHEN I
TESTIFIED AGAINST THEM THERE
WAS TOTAL. SHANMUGARATNAM
SECRETARY MRS OUTSTANDING
LISTEN I THINK IT'S A NO
BRAINER THERE'S TRANSPARENCY
WHEN WE HAVE TO DO IT WE'RE
GOING TO COURT AND TELL THEM
WHAT THEY DID TO. WE SHOULD
HAVE THE EQUAL TRANSPARENCY
FROM THEM I SUPPORT BILL SB TWO
FORTY EIGHT. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU RIGHT ONE THIRTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YOUR NUMBER
ONE SHERMAN WITH RESEARCHERS.
IN COURT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ALL RIGHT ONE HUNDRED PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS TERRY
LARSON I AM THE DIRECTOR OF
YOUR VOICE HAS POWER AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT SB. TWO FORTY
EIGHT. THANK YOU RIGHT OF ONE
HUNDRED ELEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
AND KENNEDY YOUR VOICE HAS
POWER I STRONGLY SUPPORT. B.
TWO FOUR EIGHT THANK YOU. THEY
ALL THE. SORRY I CAN'T HEAR.
WHAT MY NAME IS. SHARE KENNEDY.
AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT SB. TWO
FORTY EIGHT. WITH THIS PLEASE.
THANK YOU I'M THREE TWO NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
CAMERON TAYLOR MY MOTHER IS A
SURVIVOR OF A VIOLENT SEXUAL
PREDATOR I STRONGLY SUPPORT SB.
TWO FORTY EIGHT. THANK YOU RYAN
THREE FORTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY
NAME IS AUSTIN TAYLOR MY MOTHER
IS A SURVIVOR OF SEXUAL ASSAULT
NOT THE COURT SB TWO FOUR EIGHT.
THANK YOU AT LINE THREE THIRTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON BRITNEY PERSONALITY
WITH THE CALIFORNIA NEWS
PUBLISHERS ASSOCIATION AND
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU
APPLYING TO NINETY THREE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. TO REMAIN IN THE PART
OF- SB. TWO FOUR EIGHT. THANK
YOU ALL RIGHT FORTY ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THIS IS ALICE KEYSER
FROM SAN DIEGO. YOUR VOICE HAS
POWER MEMBER I SHOULD STRONGLY
SUPPORT S. B. TWO FORTY EIGHT
AND THANK YOU SO MUCH SENATOR
BATES YOU REALLY CARE ABOUT
YOUR COMMUNITY. THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT AND THREE FORTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS
ERICA SMITH I'M A FRIEND OF THE
VICTIM AND I SUPPORT SB. FORTY
THANK YOU RIGHT ONE FIFTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO CAN YOU
HEAR ME YES PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YES MY WIFE IS A SURVIVOR OF A
BOAT. A VIOLENT SEXUAL EACH
PREDATOR. I STRONGLY SUPPORT IS
B. TWO FORTY EIGHT. THANK YOU
OF MINE THREE THIRTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS
PATRICIA MANGAN I AM THE-
SISTER OF THE VICTIM OF A
VIOLENT SEXUAL PREDATOR AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT SB TWO TWO
FOUR EIGHT. THANK YOU RYAN TO
NINETY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YOUR LOCAL REPRESENTING OUR
UNIVERSITY POLICE. A COALITION
OF PUBLIC SAFETY OFFICER ABOARD
SYSTEM. YEAH CALIFORNIA SINCE.
FOR AN OFF ARE ON THE
CALIFORNIA NARCOTIC ABOUT IT.
FOLLOWING SUPPORT OF. THE THANK
YOU NINE THREE TO EIGHT GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS KATE VAN
BROCKLIN AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT
S. B. TWO FOUR EIGHT. THANK YOU
ALL RIGHT THREE THIRTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
EMILY BOSWORTH MY FRIEND MERRY
TAYLOR AND YOU HEARD IS A
SURVIVOR OF THE VIOLENT SEXUAL
PREDATOR AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT
SB TWO FORTY EIGHT. THANK YOU
ALL RIGHT THREE FORTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
JESSE PASS AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT AT. FIFTY TWO FORTY
EIGHT. THANK YOU RYAN THREE
TWENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI MY NAME. OUT THERE MY ON
SURVIVOR OF SEXUAL ASSAULT AND
I VERY MUCH SUPPORT SB TWO FOUR
EIGHT. THANK YOU APPLYING THREE
THIRTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS LESLIE
LAURA WITH YOUR VOICE HAS POWER
I'M GOING TO STRONGLY SUPPORT
SB TWO FORTY EIGHT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT THREE
THIRTY TO PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MY NAME IS TOMMY IN AND MY
SISTER WAS A SURVIVOR OF A
VIOLENT VIOLENT SEXUAL PREDATOR
AND I TO STRONGLY SUPPORT SB
TWO FORTY EIGHT. THANK YOU RYAN
THREE TWENTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY NAME IS MATT JENNINGS
AND I'M A FRIEND'S BROTHER AND
FAMILY MEMBER OF A
HEARTBREAKING NUMBER WOMEN
WHO'VE BEEN VICTIMS OF SEXUAL
VIOLENCE I SPEAK ON THEIR
BEHALF AND THE BEHALF OF ALL
MEDICAL WORKING TO BE BETTER
ALLIES TO VICTIMIZE WOMEN BY
SAYING I SUPPORT BILL. TO
FORTY. THIRTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS SHANTA
MOMENTS CHARACTERS ROSES AND I
SUPPORT THIS BILL. THANK YOU
ALL RIGHT ONE TWENTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS SHARON DOWNTURN- RESIDENTS
OF LOS ANGELES COUNTY AND AS A
MOTHER OF FOUR DAUGHTERS AND
OUT ON BEHALF OF ALL THE
MOTHERS BUT I KNOW I STRONGLY
SUPPORT S. B. TWO FOUR. EIGHT
THANK YOU YOUR MIND THREE FORTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME'S LORRAINE
CARTER CAN AND I AM A SURVIVOR
OF THE SEXUAL ASSAULT AND I AM
IN FULL SUPPORT SB TWO FORTY
EIGHT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU I'M
THREE FIFTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
BELOW ARE YEAH MY WIFE IS VERY
A SURVIVOR OF SEXUAL ASSAULT
AND I'D STILL MANY SUPPORT OF
S. B. TWO FORTY EIGHT. THANK
YOU NINE THREE THIRTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
SHERRY SAVAGE MY FRIEND OF THE
FIBER OF THE SEXUALLY VIOLENT
PREDATOR AND THEY DESERVE TO BE
HEARD SO I STRONGLY SUPPORT SB
TWO FOUR EIGHT. THANK YOU NINE
THREE FIFTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THIS IS- TOMMY AND- I AM
A NEPHEW OF MERRY TAYLOR AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT S. B. TWO
FORTY EIGHT. THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT ON ONE OH NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY NAME IS- ALBERT
PARSONS I AND- HUSBAND IS THE
DIRECTOR OF YOUR VOICE HAS
POWER. I STRONGLY SUPPORT SB.
TWO FOUR EIGHT. THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT THREE FIFTY FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS HEATHER
REDUCE HAUSER- MY ON IS MARY
TAYLOR AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT
AS SHOULD BE TWO FOUR EIGHT.
THANK YOU AND ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
WISH TO COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF
S. B. TWO FOUR EIGHT PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT THIS TIME.
AND WHAT WE'RE GOING THREE
HUNDRED AND SIXTY FOUR PLEASE
FOR I HAD. THIS IS MATTHEW
GRECO DIRECT NOT A DIRECTOR OF
THE SAN DIEGANS AGAINST CRIME.
STRONGLY IN SUPPORT OF SB TWO
FORTY EIGHT URGING A YES VOTE.
THANK YOU LINE IS FORTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS MERRY CRISTINA TAYLOR MY
MOTHER DAUGHTER BEST FRIEND AND
MENTOR IS A SURVIVOR OF A
VIOLENT SEXUAL PREDATOR AND I
SUPPORT SB TWO FORTY EIGHT.
THANK YOU LINE AT THREE FIFTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. ANYONE WHO
MIGHT HAVE BEEN OF THE SURVIVOR
OF A VIOLENT SEXUAL PREDATORS
AND I'M IN SUPPORT OF SB. TWO
FOUR EIGHT. THANK YOU RIGHT
THREE FIFTY EIGHT PLEASE GLAD.
HI MY NAME IS JENNIFER AND THEN
ROBERT RAYMOND OR DAUGHTER
HERE'S WHAT WE ARRAIGNMENTS AND
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT- SENATE
BILL CHIU FORTY EIGHT. TAYLOR
AND WE FIND WHAT. WHAT THANK
YOU ALL RIGHT THREE SIX THREE
PLEASE GLAD. THIS IS TINA I AM
A MOTHER AND A DAUGHTER AND I
WOULD. LIKE TO BE KNOWN THAT I
AM A SURVIVOR A VIOLENT SEXUAL
CRIME AND I ALSO STRONGLY
SUPPORT SB TWO FORTY EIGHT.
THANK YOU OF MINE THREE SIXTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME
IS OTHER JOB. MY HUSBAND
PROVIDER OF A VIOLENT SEXUAL
PREDATOR AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT
AS THE CHIU FORTY EIGHT. THANK
YOU OF MINE THREE FORTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY
COMPANION I AM PROVIDER AND
OTHER CYCLES MY MOTHER IS NOT
ABLE. TO BUY MORE AND WE ARE
ALL. CAPABLE RIGHT THREE SIXTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. BECAUSE
OF. IS ABLE OKAY THANK. ONE
MILLION APRIL. THANK YOU OF
MINE THREE FORTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. BOB AND- MY SISTER IS
ALL ABOUT ALL- BIOCHEMICAL
POSER ARE YOU STRONG SUPPORT
THANKS THREE TO FORTY EIGHT.
THANK YOU RYAN THREE TWENTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME
IS KEREN KATZ GUARD I'M WITH
YOUR VOICE HAS POWER AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT BILL SB TWO
FORTY EIGHT. THANK YOU OF MINE
THREE SEVENTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY NAME IS LAURA JEAN
I'M THE POSTER OF THE SEXUAL
ASSAULT SURVIVORS AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT SB TWO FOUR
EIGHT. THANK YOU I HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENTS THANK YOU AT
THIS TIME.
MODERATOR PLEASE
CHECK THE LINE ONCE AGAIN TO BE
ISSUE WE HAVE HEARD ALL THE
OPPOSITION FOR S. B. I'M SORRY.
SB. TWO FORTY EIGHT. THANK YOU
IF YOU WISH TO COMMENT IN
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND I
DO HAVE A COUPLE MORE THAT JUST
OUT AND IT'LL JUST BE ONE
MOMENT FOR THEM. THANK YOU
MODERATOR. YOU'RE WELCOME. ARE
IN THE WORKS LIKE I HAVE FIVE
FOUR IN Q. WE'LL GO TO LINE
THREE SEVENTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I AM LOCKED POLICY
DIRECTOR FOR CALA DEFLATION WE
SUPPORT SB TWO FORTY EIGHT.
THANK YOU YOUR MIND THREE
SEVENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MY NAME IS STEVEN LUNDY-
DEMOCRATIC SOCIALISTS OF
AMERICA WE SUPPORT SB. TWO
FORTY EIGHT. THANK YOU NINE
THREE THIRTY FOUR PLEASE CALL
ADDED. MY NAME IS CAPTAIN GO MY
SISTER MARY TAYLOR IS A VICTIM
OF AGAIN FILING CRIME AND SHE
WAS TREATED ALMOST AS BADLY BY
THE COURT. OF THE DAVID IT
DEMOCRATIC EXPERIENCE FOR HER I
STRONGLY- I ASKED YOU TO
SUPPORT S. B. TWO FORTY EIGHT
THANK YOU. NINETY THREE SEVENTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD- MY NAME
IS MARY TAYLOR I AM THE MOTHER
OF THE SEXUAL AND VIOLENT
ASSAULT VICTIMS AND I SUPPORT
S. B. TWO FOUR EIGHT. THANK YOU.
HI. THANK YOU ARE WE DO HAVE
ONE MORNING HERE TO JUST BE ONE
MOMENT.
FOR A MODERATOR WOULD
YOU MIND CHECKING THE LINE ONE
MORE TIME TO MAKE SURE WE HAVE
HEARD OF IT- ABLE EVERYONE THAT
IS IN SUPPORT. SB. TWO FORTY.
THANK YOU FOR SUPPORT OF S. B.
TWO FOUR EIGHT PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND ZERO AT THIS TIME AND WE'RE
TRYING THREE HUNDRED AND TWENTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS
MARGARET HAIG AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT SB. TWO FORTY EIGHT.
THANK YOU AND I DO HAVE ONE
MORE IN Q. JUST ONE MOMENT FOR
THIS ONE. THE LAST COMMENT I
HAVING QS FROM THREE SEVENTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
MY NAME IS BRIDGET CAN'T YOU
WEAR I HAVE THREE FRIENDS WHO
HAVE SURVIVED A VIOLENT SEXUAL
ASSAULT AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT
SB TWO FOUR EIGHT PLEASE LET IT
PASS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU I
HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENTS THANK
YOU AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU
MODERATOR HAVING HEARD FROM ALL
THE SUPPORTERS WHO WILL NOT
FOLLOW THE SAME PROCESS AND
HEAR FROM ANY OPPOSITION WE
CURRENTLY HAVE TO LEAD
OPPOSITION AMY HOFFMAN AND
MAYER CHRISTOPHER. ARE YOU ON
THE LINE. YES. PLEASE STATE
YOUR NAME. ANY OFTEN. PLEASE GO
AHEAD. S. B. Q. FORTY EIGHT
WILL FOREVER CHANGE THE COURT
THE BILITY TO PROTECT THE
PSYCHOTHERAPIST PATIENT
PRIVILEGE AND- FURTHER
UNDERMINE THE REHABILITATED
AFTER DESTRUCTIVE ENERGY. MY
NAME IS AMY HOFFMAN AND I AM
THE SUPERVISING ATTORNEY AT THE
SAN DIEGO PUBLIC DEFENDER
SEXUALLY VIOLENT PREDATOR UNIT
I'VE HANDLED MULTIPLE
CONDITIONAL RELEASE HEARINGS
THAT FOCUS ON EVIDENCE AND
TESTIMONY OF SEX OFFENDER
TREATMENT. ADDITIONALLY
HEARINGS OCCUR AFTER LENGTHY
CRIMINAL SENTENCES AND AFTER
YEARS IF NOT DECADES OF
TREATMENT AT COALINGA STATE
HOSPITAL. MANY WONDER GO
TREATMENT GO THROUGH AN
INTENSIVE MORE THAI INPATIENT
PROGRAM STRUCTURED ON EVIDENCE
BASED PRACTICES. NO WHERE IS
THERE A GREATER NEED FOR THE
COURTS TO PROTECT THE
PSYCHOTHERAPIST PATIENT
PRIVILEGE. WITHOUT IT PATIENTS
WILL BE RELUCTANT IN MAKING
FULL DISCLOSURES UPON WHICH
DIAGNOSIS AND TREATMENT THE PAN.
YOU MAY NOT ONLY FOCUSES ON THE
OFFENSES THEY COMMITTED BUT
ALSO REQUIRED TO KEEP LOOK AT
THEIR OWN VICTIMIZATION TRAUMA.
A MAGIC HAVING EVERY
CONVERSATION WITH YOUR
THERAPIST REVEALED FROM THE
WITNESS STAND FOR ALL TO HEAR.
THE CONSTITUTIONALLY GENOCEA SB
T. LIVE PRESS ON THE NON
PUNITIVE NATURE OF THE PATIENT.
CONFINEMENT SIMILAR TO
CONSERVATORSHIP PROCEEDINGS THE
COURT CURRENTLY HAS THE
DISCRETION TO CLOSE PORTIONS OF
S. ET RELIEF HEARING. SB TWO
FORTY EIGHT WITH A RADICALLY
THE COURT'S ABILITY TO
DETERMINE WHETHER MENTAL HEALTH
AND MEDICAL EVIDENCE. SHE TO
CONTINUE TO RECEIVE PRIVACY
PROTECTIONS FOR THAT HE KEEP
PATIENT. THESE PROCEEDINGS
PRESENT CHALLENGES IN THE COURT
IS NOT A MORE VICTIMS RIGHT TO
MAKING THESE DECISIONS.
CONDITIONAL RELEASE PROGRAM HAS
AROUND THE CLOCK SUPERVISION
INCLUDING TWENTY FOUR HOUR GPS
THAT YOU CASTING AND POLYGRAPH
EXAMINATION. WE ALL UNDERSTAND
THAT THERE IS FEAR AND
APPREHENSION WHEN CONSIDERING.
RELEASED A SEXUALLY VIOLENT
OFFENDER. HIGHER TO PLACEMENT
IN THE GUINNESS RELEASE. THE
VICTIMS AND PUBLIC ARE NOTIFIED
AND INVITED TO ATTEND THE
PUBLIC HEARING. AS THE COURT
REGARDING THEIR CONCERNS. SB
TWO FORTY EIGHT DOES NOTHING TO
INCREASE PUBLIC SAFETY
PROSECUTORS ALREADY HAVE THE
ABILITY TO ACCESS THE
INDIVIDUAL RECORD. NO PUBLIC
GOOD IS SERVED BY FURTHER
OPENING ACCESS TO THOSE
RECORDS. THE MORE THE
LEGISLATURE CHIPPED AWAY AT THE
PRIVACY RIGHTS OF EACH AND THE
GREATER THE CHALLENGE WHERE
JUSTICE SYSTEM IN DELIVERING
EFFECTIVE TREATMENT ASSEMBLY
COMMUNICATION. YEAH THANK YOU
VERY MUCH OF A MISS HOFFMAN MAY
I PLEASE HAVE MY A CHRISTOPHER
PLEASE. IS MY CHRISTOPHER ON
THE LINE. SLASH YOU ARE DIALED
IN AS A PARTICIPANT YOU CAN
PRESS STAR ZERO AND I WILL OPEN
YOUR LINE. I CURRENTLY DO NOT
C. MEYER DIALED IN. OKAY SO
LET'S MOVE ON TO ANY WITNESSES
HERE IN ROOM FORTY TWO OR THREE.
C. NINE ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES
IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY WHO WISH
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO SB
TWO FORTY EIGHT SEEN ON. THANK
YOU WILL NOW MOVE ON TO
WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY
VIA TELECONFERENCE SERVICE.
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PUMP THE INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO SB TWO
FORTY EIGHT WE WILL BEGIN.
THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO MAKE A
COMMENT IN OPPOSITION OF SB TWO
FOUR EIGHT. PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU MODERATOR KEEP PLEASE
GIVE ME A TOTAL NUMBER OF
PEOPLE WAITING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU I
CURRENTLY HAVE TWO IN THE QUEUE
WE'LL GO TO LINE THREE SEVENTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. BLIND
THREE SEVEN NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS JEREMY
THOUGH AND I AM IN SUPPORT OF
S. B. TWO FORTY EIGHT. THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
WHAT.
THANK YOU SEVEN FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
MARCO GEORGE FROM THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION- WE ARE IN
OPPOSITION TO SB TWO FORTY
EIGHT BECAUSE THAT WOULD
CURTAIL JUDICIAL DISCRETION.
WHICH IS THE APPROPRIATE-
MEASURE IF THE FOR A JUDGE TO
DECIDE ON A CASE BY CASE BASIS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT. THANK YOU I'M FIFTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY A
CHRISTOPHER. HI MY CAN YOU HEAR
ME YES YOU'RE THE LEAD-
OPPOSITION WITNESS PLEASE GO
AHEAD YES I'M SORRY I COULDN'T
NOBODY COULD HEAR ME DO YOU
MIND IF I READ MY STATEMENT
NOW. NOT AT ALL PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU SB TWO FORTY EIGHT
WORKS DIRECTLY AGAINST
REHABILITATIVE EFFORTS OF SEX
OFFENSE SPECIFIC TREATMENT.
WHAT TYPE OF LEGAL AND ETHICAL
MANDATES A PSYCHOTHERAPIST
PATIENT PRIVILEGE SB TWO FOUR
EIGHT ARMS THE REHABILITATIVE
EFFORTS AFFECTED CANCER
TREATMENT AND DISCOURAGES
INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE BEEN
CERTAINLY COMMITTED FROM FULLY
PARTICIPATING IN REHABILITATIVE
EFFORTS AND THAT DOES NOT
CONTRIBUTE TO THE PREVENTION OF
SEXUAL ABUSE. MY NAME IS MAYA
CHRISTOPHER I AM THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE ASSOCIATION FOR
TREATMENT SEXUAL ABUSERS. MY
INTERNATIONAL ORGANIZATIONS
SPECIALIZING IN THE
IMPLEMENTATION DEVELOPMENT OF
BEST PRACTICES EVIDENCE BASED
TREATMENT AND THE PROVISION. TO
EFFECTIVELY REDUCE SEXUAL
OFFENDING. WE RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE SB TWO FOUR EIGHT. TELL
YOU TO A FOR THE PATIENT
CONFIDENTIALITY WHICH THEIR
STATUTORILY ENTITLED INCREASES
INDIVIDUAL RELUCTANCE TO MAKE
FULL DISCLOSURES IN THE
TREATMENT PROCESS OF THE
PATIENT COMMUNITY SUPERVISION
AND TO FULLY ENGAGE IN THE
TREATMENT GROUP PROCESS.
FURTHER TREATMENT REPORTS SUCH
AS THOSE THAT COME FROM SEXUAL
INTO TREATMENT DID NOT JUST
INCLUDE INFORMATION REGARDING
PATIENT. LISA PRIVILEGED
INFORMATION ALSO AFFECT THE
PATIENT'S FAMILIES PROCEED. AND
SAFETY WITHIN THE COMMUNITY AS
WELL POTENTIALLY THE NAMES AND
RELATIONSHIPS OF PEOPLE WHO
HAVE BEEN HARMED BUT DID NOT
REPORT THEIR FINDINGS ARE
INCLUDED WITHIN THE REPORT. GET
YOUR HARASSMENT BUT WHAT SHOULD
BE WILL COME RELEASE OF ITS-
INCREASES THE- HARM OF AL
THESE INDIVIDUALS AND INCREASES
THE ABILITY OF THE PATIENTS
MAINTAIN OR FORM PRO SOCIAL
NETWORK THAT WE KNOW INCREASE
COMMUNITY SAFETY. THE PUBLIC.
AUTHORED BY H. B. TWO FOUR
EIGHT IMPACTS PATIENTS ABILITY
TO FIND EMPLOYMENT HOUSING AND
MAINTAIN THE CONDITIONS OF A
CONDITIONAL RELEASE. INCREASED
PUBLIC PRESSURE ON POTENTIAL
LANDLORDS EMPLOYERS LIMIT
ALREADY ALMOST MONEY CONNECTING
OPTIONS AT LEAST TO INCREASE
TRANSIENT THESE DOCTORS WITH NO
INCREASED RISK TO THE COMMUNITY.
FTP LOGS ARE DESIGNED TO
PREVENT SEXUALLY. TO TREATMENT.
SB TWO FOUR EIGHT AT THE
BARRIERS TO EFFECTIVE TREATMENT
AND A PACK IN KEUCHEL BEST
PRACTICES THAT PREVENT SPECIAL
TECHNIQUE. DOES NOT ADD TO
COMMUNITY SAFETY. PLEASE
OPPOSED SENATE BILL TWO FOUR
EIGHT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ALL RIGHT TO- EIGHT.
PAGE STEPHEN FROM THE SAN DIEGO
COUNTY PUBLIC DEFENDER'S OFFICE
AYE OPPOSED SB TWO FORTY EIGHT
THANK YOU. NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT THREE SIXTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE
THREE SIX NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
BLIND THREE TWENTY THREE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS CONNIE%
HOWARD I AM FROM SAN DIEGO AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSE SB TWO FORTY
EIGHT THANK YOU. THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT SIXTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MY NAME IS DENNIS PLAN CHAMBER
COULD BENDIGO COUNTY PUBLIC
DEFENDER'S OFFICE I OPPOSE SB
TWO FORTY EIGHT. THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT EIGHTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YES GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS HOME CHIANG MAI FROM
SAN DIEGO COUNTY I VEHEMENTLY
OPPOSE SB THIRTY EIGHT. YEAH
THANK YOU KNOW WRITING THREE
NINETY PLEASE GO AHEAD. YEAH
THIS IS A MILLION NAY BANGING
ON THE DOOR COUNTY- YOU
STRONGLY OPPOSED THESE S. B. HI
BEFORE. I THINK IT'S NIGHT AND
OTHER PURPOSES INCREASING ONE.
ALSO WITH A GOOD BUT YOU WILL
WALK. THAT WILL CAUSE ANOTHER
GLOBAL CONFLICT. WHAT I AM
SAYING THAT IS PEOPLE WILL BE
HURT. BUT THAT THAT PEOPLE WILL
ALWAYS FIND A WAY PLEASE JUST
STATE YOUR NAME WELL ONE YOUR
AGENCY AND WHETHER OR NOT YOU
SUPPORT- OPPOSE THE SUPPORTER
OPPOSED VIA THE BILL. BY
APPROACH. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT
AND ONE NINETY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY NAME IS TATIANA KLEIN
I'M AN ATTORNEY WITH THE SAN
DIEGO COUNTY PUBLIC DEFENDER'S
OFFICE AND AYE OPPOSED THE BILL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT
THREE TWELVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI MY NAME IS ANDREA HELLO I'M
A BIG FAN HERE COUNTY PUBLIC
DEFENDER'S OFFICE AND I BECAUSE
THIS BILL. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
RIGHT THREE SIXTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I'M REVEREND DR ANDREA
TRAILERS ON THE COORDINATOR FOR
THE CIRCLES OF SUPPORT
ACCOUNTABILITY AND CHANGE AGO
WHICH FOCUSES ON REINTEGRATION
FOR SDP'S INTO THE COMMUNITY-
PRIVATE PROTECTION IS CRITICAL
FOR DIAGNOSTIC REHABILITATION
FOR THE INDIVIDUAL I OPPOSE SB
TWO FORTY EIGHT. THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT THREE ELEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY NAME'S KATIE BELISLE
I AM ALSO CAñADA COUNTY PUBLIC
DEFENDER AND A MOTHER AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE AT THE TWO
FORTY EIGHT. THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT SEVENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY NAME IS SHERRY WE
DON'T HARPER FROM THE COMMUNITY
JUSTICE CENTER AND WE WORK IN
RESTORATIVE PRACTICES EVIDENCE
BASED PRACTICES FOR THOSE WHO
ARE VICTIMS OF SEXUAL VIOLENCE
AND THE COMMITTED SEXUAL HARM
AND WE WORK AT THE SUCCESSFUL
INTEGRATION OF ESCAPEES
RECALLING STATE HOSPITAL. AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE SB TWO FORTY
EIGHT. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT
THREE EIGHTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS VALERIE
WHITE SIDE ON THAT BEHAVIOR
ANALYST ANDEDUCATOR IN SAN
DIEGO AND I HAVE A FRIEND WHO
IS THE VICTIM OF A VIOLENT
SEXUAL PREDATOR AND I. FORTY
EIGHT. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT TO
FORTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
CANACCORD ARMAGH ON BEHALF OF
THE SAN FRANCISCO PUBLIC
DEFENDER'S OFFICE IN OPPOSITION
ALSO WANTED TO ADD IN MY
INDIVIDUAL CAPACITY AS THE
DAUGHTER OF A SURVIVOR- THAT
SEXUALLY VIOLENT CRIMES- ALSO
PERSONALLY. THANK YOU NINE
THREE NINETY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS ANDREA
BOLLINGER AT THE PUBLIC
DEFENDER FROM THE CLOSE S. B.
CHIU FORTY. THANK YOU AS A
REMINDER IF YOU WISH TO COMMENT
IN OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO FORTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS
NANCY OF PEOPLE DEFENDING THE
PUBLIC DEFENDER'S OFFICE AND
I'M IN OPPOSITION SB. TWO FORTY
EIGHT. THANK YOU RIGHT THREE
SIXTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY
NAME IS ROBIN RAINWATER- I
WANTED TO DISCUSS THE FACT THAT
MOST IMPORTANTLY TE AMENDMENT
ALTHOUGH INTRODUCED TO CLOSE
THE SMALL LOOPHOLE HAS LARGE
FUTURE IMPLICATIONS BY
EXPANDING THE BACK IN THE
WELFARE AND INSTITUTIONS CODE
EXPANDING TO INCLUDE IN THE
TURNER THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
JEEZ LIMIT YOUR COMMENTS TO
YOUR NAME AGENCY AND WHETHER OR
NOT YOU SUPPORT OR OPPOSE THE
BILL. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT TWO
EIGHTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GREEN CLEAR SAN DIEGO PUBLIC
DEFENDER'S OFFICE AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE SB TWO FORTY
OKAY. THANK YOU NEXT TO WHERE I
HAVE CABIN. BLASTING THANK YOU
EVERYONE FOR LEFT IN Q. IT'LL
JUST BE ONE FOR THE LINE. FIVE
THREE NINETY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. KELLY IN NYC DANIEL- I
HAVE A FRIEND NOT FOE SURVIVOR
AND I'M IN NEED SUPPORT- TWO
FOUR EIGHT. THANK YOU I HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENT THANK YOU AT
THIS TIME. THANK YOU MODERATOR
CAN YOU PLEASE THE CHECK THE
LINE ONE MORE TIME TO MAKE SURE
WE'VE HEARD FROM ALL OPPOSITION
WITNESSES PLEASE. THANK YOU AS
A REMINDER IF YOU WISH TO MAKE
A COMMENT IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. I HAVE A COMMENT FROM
MINUS FOUR OH TO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY NAME IS JOBS FOR OUR
YOUNG WITH DECEMBER MEDINA
COUNTY PUBLIC DEFENDER'S OFFICE
I'VE BEEN DEFENDING THESE CASES
FOR TWENTY ONE YEARS AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE. THIS MEASURE.
THANK YOU OF MINE THREE NINETY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. BRIAN THREE
NINE ZERO PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES
PLEASE GO AHEAD- YOU HAD
BUSINESS IN MILLION NEW VIETNAM
WE ALL NEED A COUNTY I STRONGLY
OPPOSE- S. B. TWELVE FORTY TWO.
WELLS NOW. FOR BORDERLINE THREE
TWENTY TO PLEASE GO AHEAD. ON
THE FRONT PANEL COUNTY PUBLIC
DEFENDER'S OFFICE JUST WITH MY
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU I DON'T
pGRAGSTON HERE WITH CIRCLE THE
DEPARTMENT COUNT ABILITY IN
FRESNO AND I'M CALLING TO
OPPOSE. THANK YOU I HAVE NO
FURTHER LINE THANK YOU AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU MODERATOR.
THANK YOU TO ALL OUR SUPPORT IN
A POSITION WITNESSES WILL NOT
BRING THE DISCUSSION BACK TO
OUR MEMBERS DO ANY OF OUR
MEMBERS HAVE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS AT THIS TIME. WHAT. I
GUESS I'LL ASK A QUESTION WELL
WERE YES MEMBERS OF. SO I JUST
WANTED TO CONFIRM SENATOR- THAT
THE AMENDMENTS WERE TAKEN
REGARDING JURY TRIAL. NO THE
AMENDMENTS THAT WERE TAKEN NOW
I HAVE TO DO WITH THE LOOPHOLE
THAT IT ALLOWS SEXUALLY FAILING
**** PREDATORS TO ACTUALLY NOT
HAVE TO RETURN THAT AFTER THEY
COMMIT ANOTHER FELONY- THEY CAN
RE LITIGATE THEIR COMMITMENT TO
THE STATE HOSPITAL SEEMS THAT
SUMMER TAKING ADVANTAGE OF A
LOOPHOLE THAT'S CURRENTLY IN
THE LAW. SO THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS SOUGHT THANKS TO THE
CHAIR I ACTUALLY A POLL THAT
PART OF THE BILL REGARDING THE
CLOSING OF THE LOOPHOLE IT'S A
CHANGE AND WHETHER THE OPEN
PROCEEDINGS PART. OF THE BILL
ON HIS SUPPORTABLE. FIVE MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THE MOMENT
DELETE SECTION ONE OF THE BILL
SO THAT'S THE OPEN PROCEEDINGS
PART AND KEEPS THE OTHER
SECTION YEAH. CORRECT. WE ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS BY MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE. NINETY NINE
SURVEY TO TALK TO CLOSE OUT
YOUR FILE JUST WANT TO SAY
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR YOUR STAFF
AND CERTAINLY OUR CHAIR FOR
WORKING ON MINE TO POTENTIAL
ADDITIONAL AMENDMENTS SO WE
DIDN'T GET THERE ON THIS ROUND
BUT I DO APPRECIATE THAT YOU
TOOK THE TIME AND I'D LIKE TO
SAY ON BEHALF OF BOTH SIDES OF
THIS ISSUE IT IS A DIFFICULT
ONE. I AM VERY VERY SUPPORTIVE
AS YOU ALL KNOW OF THE
REHABILITATION OF FOR FOLKS
THAT HAVE SPENT TIME
INCARCERATED VARIETY OF REASONS
IN A PARTICULAR THIS ISSUE
AREA- THAT PEOPLE HAVE PROBLEMS
AND HIS IS VERY VERY DIFFICULT
ONE I PERSONALLY HAVE BEEN A
VICTIM OF SOMETHING QUITE
SIMILAR TO THIS AS A CHILD AND
I JUST WANT TO SHARE THAT. THE
MEMORIES OF THAT LAST A
LIFETIME AND SO- THAT'S WHY I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT THAT
THERE'S CLOSURE FOR THE VICTIMS
AND PERHAPS WE NEED TO DO A
LITTLE MORE WORK ON HOW WE
MIGHT ACHIEVE THAT BUT AT THE
SAME TIME ALFA BROUGHT UP AND
THOSE WHO OPPOSE THE BILL THAT
WE DO HAVE TO PROTECT TO THE
ASSAILANT WE HAVE TO ENSURE
THAT. THERE'S AN OPPORTUNITY
FOR REHABILITATION AND ONLY THE
OXFORDS CAN DECIDE I BELIEVE ON
WHETHER THAT ACTUALLY OCCURS AT
THE TIME THEY'VE SPENT THEIR
THEIR TIME IN A STATE HOSPITAL.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT THE WHAT THE
STATISTICS ARE BUT WE DO HAVE
THAT WHAT IS IT THE 8% EVERY
RECIDIVISM NO MATTER WHAT IS
DONE THIS WAS A COUPLE YEARS
AGO ONLY STILL HAVE STATISTICS
THAT WE NEED TO BE LOOKING OUT
TO DETERMINE WHETHER THE
TREATMENT CHEN IN THE APPROACH
TO SOMETHING AS SERIOUS AS
THEIR FATHER ARE ACTUALLY WE'RE
GETTING GOOD RESULTS BUT IN THE
MEANTIME. IT IS IMPORTANT AS I
SAID TO RECOGNIZE BOTH THE
VICTIMS AND CERTAINLY AT THE
PREDATORS AND HOPE THAT WE
CANNOT CHANGE THEIR BEHAVIOR SO
THAT ARE VICTIMS WHO SPOKEN
FROM THE HEART OF OUR OUR OUR
RECOGNIZE ALSO AND I THINK
THERE'S A PATH THERE THAT WILL
TAKE THIS ONE HUNDRED I WOULD
DONE AGAIN. EXCEPT THE CHAIRS.
AMENDMENTS AND ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. THE GREAT THANK YOU. WE
HAVE HIGH RECOMMEND. I AM
SEEKING A STATE. DELETION OF
SECTION ONE OF THE BILL
PRESERVES DISCRETION OF THE
JUDGE TO CLOSE PORTIONS OF THE
PROCEEDINGS UNDER EXISTING
CONSTITUTIONAL LEGAL STANDARDS
HEY. FINISH THE AVERAGE FOR
TOTAL ON WITH. I WAS JUST GONNA
IT THAT. DID YOU A QUESTION I
WAS JUST TO STATE THAT BY FEEL
TOOK THE AND THEN- THAT WAS
REALLY A I DO THE PROBLEM. PART
OF THE BILL AND ON THESE THE
BILL AND THAT'S AMENDED- OKAY.
SO WE HAVE TO- TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROACH. DO WE HAVE
A MOTION. AND WE HAVE A MOTION
BY- CHOI BO. IT MEASURES OUT
FIVE ZERO CONGRATULATIONS AND
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR YOUR
WORK. NEXT UP SENATOR MEANT. SB.
TWO SIX FOUR. BUT SENATOR WHEN
YOU'RE READY THIRTY THREE PRESS
SIX FOR THANK YOU MEMBERS AND
THANK YOU THE COMMITTEE STAFF
WHO'S BEEN WORKING WITH US ON
THIS BILL. SB TWO SIXTY FOUR
WHICH WOULD PROHIBIT THE SALE
OF FIREARMS AMMUNITIONS AND
FIREARMS PRECURSOR PARTS. ON
ALL STATE AND COUNTY
PROPERTIES- ARE SPECIFICALLY IT
TO SIXTY FOUR PROHIBITS. STATE
OFFICERS EMPLOYEES OR OPERATORS
LET'S SEIZE OR LICENSEES OF ANY
STATE OWNED OR COUNTY OWNED
PROPERTY. CONTRACTING FOR
AUTHORIZING OR ALLOWING THE
SALE OF ANY FIREARMS AMMUNITION
OR FIREARM PRECURSOR PARK ON
PROPERTY OWNED OR OPERATED BY
THE STATE AND COUNTIES. THIS
WOULD EXEMPT LAW ENFORCEMENT
GUN BUY BACK PROGRAMS WHOSE
PURPOSE IS TO REMOVE GUNS FROM
THE COMMUNITY. NOW THE ORIGIN
OF THIS BILL WAS THE WEEKEND
THAT WE HAD THE EL PASO
SHOOTINGS FOLLOWED BY THE
DAYTON SHOOTINGS. I HAVE THREE
YOUNG CHILDREN WE ACTUALLY HAVE
RELATIVES IN DAYTON PRETENDING
UNIVERSALLY DAYTON. AND MEMBER
HAVING TO EXPLAIN TO THEM.
ABOUT THE SPECTER OF GUN
VIOLENCE AND GUN MASSACRES IN
THIS COUNTRY. WE HAD TO MAKE
THE PHONE CALLS THAT SUNDAY
MORNING TO CHECK IN WITH
RELATIVES. THANKFULLY ALL THE
PEOPLE THAT WE KNEW WERE SAFE
REPORTS MANY OTHERS WERE NOT.
LATER THAT MORNING WE WENT TO
OUR COUNTY FAIRGROUNDS TO RUN
AND I FORGET FOR THE FIVE K. OR
TEN K. I'M REMEMBERING IT IS A
TEN K. BUT THAT PROBABLY MEANS
IS A FIVE K. I HAD THE TWO
OLDER CHILDREN WITH ME MY WIFE.
AND OUR YOUNGEST WITH HER. AND
AS WE FINISHED UP I REMEMBER
JUST BEING BOMBARDED WITH
PEOPLE GIVING US FLYERS FOR THE
FREE GUN SHOW AT NEXT WEEK'S-
NOT NEXT WEEKEND. I'VE SEEN THE
FLYERS PLASTERED ALL AROUND.
AND WONDERING WHY AT THE COUNTY
FAIRGROUNDS OF ALL PLACES MY
CHILDREN WERE BEING ASKED
WHETHER THEY WANTED TO ATTEND A
CONCERT THE NEXT WEEKEND. WHEN
I WAS GROWING UP THE COUNTY
FAIRGROUNDS WERE KNOWN FOR
FAMILY FRIENDLY EVENTS. IN
ADDITION TO THE COUNTY FAIR
EACH YEAR THAT HAVE RODEOS FOUR
H. EVENTS CONCERT THE CIRCUS.
AND OTHER BANDS LIKE THAT.
TODAY THEY'RE PRIMARILY KNOWN
FOR GUN SHOWS. THE AVERAGE
COUNTY FAIRGROUNDS FOR A STATE
HOUSE FIVE GUN SHOWS A YEAR.
FOR THE COMMITTEE STAFF IS
DESCRIBED GUN SHOWS ARE
SENSUALLY FORTY MARKET FOR
FIREARMS THEIR PRIMARY
MECHANISM BY WHICH UNLICENSED
UNREGISTERED AND ILLEGAL
FIREARMS OR TRAFFIC THROUGH
SECONDARY MARKETS. ACCORDING TO
GIFFORDS GUN SHOWS CREATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO CIRCUMVENT GUN
SAFETY LAWS ARE COMMON VENUE
FOR STRAW PURCHASES AND LEGAL
GUN TRANSFERS. AN ATF ALCOHOL
BUREAU OF ALCOHOL TOBACCO AND
FIREARM REPORT DESCRIBED GUN
SHOWS AS A MAJOR TRAFFICKING
CHANNEL AND FOUND THE GUN SHOWS
WERE THE SECOND LARGEST SOURCE
OF ILLEGALLY TRAFFICKED
FIREARMS UNITED STATES. EVEN
HERE IN CALIFORNIA WHICH HAS
THE MOST STRINGENT REGULATIONS
ON GUN SHOWS IN THE COUNTRY A
HIGH NUMBER OF SALES OF
UNLICENSED AND UNREGISTERED
GUNS ORIGINATE AT GUN SHOWS.
ONE OF MY WITNESSES STEVE
LANGLEY THE FORMER HEAD OF THE
BUREAU OF ALCOHOL TOBACCO AND
FIREARMS. UNFORTUNATELY HAD TO
LEAVE BECAUSE IT A HARD STOP
BEFORE THIRTY PM BUT WAS GOING
TO DESCRIBE HIS PERSONAL
EXPERIENCES IN OBSERVING THESE
TYPES OF TRANSACTIONS. TENSIONS
ARE PRIMARY CONDUIT THROUGH
GHOSTS WHICH GOES GUN KITS ARE
SOLD. OUT IF YOU DON'T KNOW
GOES GOING KIDS ARE PARTIALLY
MANUFACTURED GUN PARTS THAT
COME WITH INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW
TO BE FULLY ASSEMBLED. BECAUSE
THEY'RE NOT ACTUALLY FIREARMS
THEMSELVES THEY'RE NOT SUBJECT
TO FIREARMS REGULATION SUCH AS
BACKGROUND CHECKS AND WAITING
PERIODS. THOSE GUYS HAVE BECOME
A TOP CONCERN OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT BECAUSE THEIR
UNREGISTERED AND UNLICENSED AND
UNTRACEABLE. BATF RECENTLY
FOUND THE 30% OF GUNS RECOVERED
AT CRIME SCENES HERE IN
CALIFORNIA WE'RE GOES GUNS. BUT
I WILL SAY THAT EVEN IF THERE
WERE ZERO SALES OF ILLEGAL
UNLICENSED OR UNREGISTERED GUNS
AT GUN SHOWS WHICH IS NOT THE
CASE. CONCHO STILL MAKES OUR
COMMUNITIES LESS SAFE LESS SAFE.
LET'S BE CLEAR THE PRIMARY
PURPOSE OF GUN SHOWS IS TO SELL
GUNS. TO PUT MORE GUNS IN TO
OUR CALIFORNIA COMMUNITIES. AND
AS THE EVIDENCE MAKES CLEAR
MORE GUNS MEANS MORE GUN
VIOLENCE. COUNTRIES THAT HAVE
MORE GUNS HAVE MORE GUN
HOMICIDES MORE GUN DEATHS MORE
GUN INJURIES IT'S THE SAME
STORY FOR STATES THAT HAVE MORE
GUNS. MORE GUNS ALSO LEAD TO
MORE CRIMES AS NUMEROUS
INCORRECTLY- INTERCOURSE.
STUDIES HAVE FOUND. WHAT WE'RE
FACING RIGHT NOW IN THIS
COUNTRY IN THE STATE IS A
PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS. LONG
AFTER KOBE NINETEEN TWO SIDES
WILL STILL BE FACING AN
EPIDEMIC OF GUN VIOLENCE IN
THIS COUNTRY. AND THE LARGELY
OVERLOOKED IN THE NEWS THIS
YEAR WAS A SOBERING STATISTIC.
FORTY THREE THOUSAND AMERICANS
DIED DUE TO GUN VIOLENCE LAST
YEAR DURING THE PANDEMIC. THE
HIGHEST NUMBER OF GUN DEATHS IN
MANY YEARS. WE MUST STAND UP
AND SAY ENOUGH IS ENOUGH. EVERY
LIFE THAT WE READ ABOUT IS NOT
JUST A STATISTIC IS SOMEONE
MEANINGFUL. TO THEIR FAMILY
THEIR FRIENDS THEIR NEIGHBORS
THEIR COWORKERS. AND GUN
VIOLENCE. THESE ARE ALL
AVOIDABLE DEATHS. BY THE SECOND
AMENDMENT PROTECTS THE RIGHT OF
THE PEOPLE TO KEEP AND BEAR
ARMS BUT IT DOES NOT REQUIRE
THE TAXPAYER OWN PROPERTY BE
USED TO HELP WITH. THE SALE OF
THOSE GUNS IN OUR COMMUNITIES.
SB TWO SIXTY FOUR ONE SURE THE
STATE IS NOT PROFITING FROM THE
SALE OF FIREARMS AND AMMUNITION
ON STATE PROPERTY. FOR
FACILITATING GUN SHOWS THAT
WOULD UNDERMINE CALIFORNIA'S
STRONG FIREARM REGULATIONS.
WITH THAT I WANT TO INTRODUCE-
SO UNFORTUNATE I MENTION STEVE
LINDLEY CANNOT JOIN US BECAUSE
HE DID HAVE A HARD STOP HE WAS
GOING TO TESTIFY. ABOUT THE
STUDIES IN HIS PERSONAL
OBSERVATIONS SHOWING THAT GUN
SHOWS YOU'RE IN CALIFORNIA YOU
DO INDEED HAVE A LOT OF STRAW
SALE PURCHASES OR ATTEMPTED
PURCHASES. ANOTHER SALES
UNLICENSED OR UNREGISTERED GUNS
ON FORTY COULD NOT JOIN US BUT
HIS TESTIMONY HAS BEEN
SUBMITTED FOR THE RECORD- BUT I
AM HAPPY TO INTRODUCE CHARLES
BLACK- BRADY ORANGE COUNTY
WHOSE FAMILY WAS PERSONALLY
AFFECTED BY GUN VIOLENCE. THANK
YOU MISTER BLACK. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
CHARLES BLACK I'M A PAST
PRESIDENT AND CURRENT BOARD
MEMBER OF BREAKING ORANGE
COUNTY- MY REPRESENT TODAY I AM
A RETIRED ATTORNEY AND CAME TO
THIS ISSUE AFTER THE GUN DEATH
OF MY SON. WE WISH TO THANK
SENATOR CAVEMEN FOR HIS PLEDGE
TO DRESS FOR. WHY THE WORLD ARE
WE SUPPORTING GUN SHOWS AT
STATE AND COUNTY OWNED PROPERTY
WITH TAXPAYERS MONEY WHAT WE
ARE DEALING WITH THE GRIEF OF
GUN VIOLENCE VICTIMS THANK
COMMUNITIES ACROSS CALIFORNIA.
WE BELIEVE THAT OUR PURCHASE OF
A FIREARM IS LITERALLY A GREAT
DECISION AND SHOULD BE DONE IN
A MORE APPROPRIATE STUDY. DONE
SHOWS ARE NOISY BUT CRIMINAL
WITH CARNIVAL LIKE ATMOSPHERE.
THE MASS KILLING OF FIREARMS
AND THE PROMOTION OF STAYING AT
THESE EVENTS AT STATE OWNED
PROPERTIES- FAMILY
ENTERTAINMENT OFTEN TAKES
PLACE. CREATES THE APPEARANCE
THAT THE STATE GIVES THEM
CLOSER APPROVAL OF SUCH SALES.
CERTAINLY THE FREE ADMISSION
OFTEN OFFERED FOR CHILDREN TO
ATTEND WITH. A PARENT GIVES ONE
PAUSE. PUBLISHED RESEARCH HAS
BEEN AVAILABLE FOR YEARS THAT
BRING A FIREARM INTO THE HOME
INCREASES THE RISK OF SUICIDE
HOMICIDE AND UNINTENTIONAL
SHOOTINGS TO THAT HOME. AND YET
HERE WE ARE WITH GUN SHOWS AND
LOCAL COMMUNITIES THAT PROVIDE
MASS KILLINGS OF FIREARMS
AMMUNITION AND PRECURSOR I
ACQUIRE ARM PARTS TO THE
GENERAL PUBLIC. ADDITIONALLY
AND NOT INTOXICATE THE SAME
TAXPAYERS PICK UP THE TAB. ONLY
EIGHTEEN BILLION DOLLARS IN
ANNUAL COSTS OF GUN VIOLENCE IN
CALIFORNIA. THEN ENSUES.
THEREFORE WE RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR I. BOATS IN THE MAST
AND PROMOTIONAL FIREARMS
PRECURSOR GUN PARTS AND
AMMUNITION ONE STATE AND COUNTY
OWNED PROPERTIES. THIS STATE
SHOULD NOT BE COMPLICIT WITH
SUBJECTIVITY. THANK YOU THANK
YOU. WE'RE GONNA BRING IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE HEARING-
ANYONE PRESENT HERE IN FORTY
TWO OLD THREE WHO WANTS TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. OF SB. TWO
SIX FOUR LET'S GO TO ROOM
TWENTY FORTY. AND I SEE NO
WITNESSES THERE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF. TO SEARCH FOR A
MODERATOR CAN WE GO TO OUR
PHONE LINES AND SEE IF WE HAVE
CALLERS IN Q. IN SUPPORT OF SB.
TWO SIX FOUR. THANK YOU IF YOU
WISH TO COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF
S. B. TWO SIX FOUR PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
WE HAVE ABOUT FIFTEEN IN Q.
OVER TO THE FIRST LINE OF THREE
HUNDRED AND SIXTY FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. JENNIFER LONG BOMB OF
NEVER AGAIN CALIFORNIA AND MY
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ALL RIGHT FOR TEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. FOUR ONE ZERO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU OF MINE FOR
TWENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS MORE TOP ON BEHALF OF
THE CITY OF SAN DIEGO ON
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ONE ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
MAKE A COMMENT IN SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT
THIS TIME. JUST ONE MOMENT FOR
NEXT COMMENT.
THANK YOU AGAIN
FOR YOUR PATIENCE IT'LL JUST BE
ONE MORE MOMENT FOR OUR NEXT
COMMENT. WELL. RIGHT TO SIXTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS
IS TROY CORLEY I'M FROM OXNARD
CALIFORNIA I'M A MEMBER OF
NEVER AGAIN VENTURA COUNTY AND
I FIRMLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU OUR NEXT COMMENTERS
FROM LINE FOR SEVENTEEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS ROSY AND
SHARP MIND THE FOUNDER OF NEVER
AGAIN CA AND I'M STRONGLY
SUPPORT OF SB TWO SIXTY FOUR
THANK YOU. THANK YOU OF MINE
EIGHTY THREE PLEASE GLAD. HI
THIS IS KATHY FERGUSON WITH
NEVER AGAIN SEE A DOT ORG I
STRONGLY SUPPORT S. B. TWO
SIXTY FOUR TO MAKE OUR
COMMUNITY SAFER THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT THREE
NINETY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
SANDY WILDER FROM BRADY ORANGE
COUNTY AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT
THE BILL. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT
THREE NINETY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS STACEY
REPRESENTING THE WELLSTONE
DEMOCRATIC RENEWAL CLUB IN THE
EAST BAY AND MYSELF AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THE BILL.
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT THREE FORTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. I'M SORRY
THAT'S LINE FOR THIRTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS
TOMMY MAY I LIVED IN THE COUNTY
C. R. P. AND- MEMBER AND- ATTY
GUN OWNERS VOTES. OPPOSE. THANK
YOU FOR TAKING PART WHEN
SOMEONE HAS WON. HI CAN YOU
HEAR ME. YES PLEASE GO AHEAD HI
THIS IS SUSAN LOU CALLING FROM
ORANGE COUNTY I'M WITH ASIAN
AMERICANS INACTION AND WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT SB. TWO SIXTY
FOUR. THANK YOU IN A RECIPE ONE
MOMENT FOR HER NEXT COMMENT.
OVERLAIN ONE CHIANG TREES GO
AHEAD. BY IS JULIE EVAN LOW I
AM- REPRESENTING WOMEN FOR
AMERICAN VALUES IN ABJECT
WAVING ORANGE COUNTY AND I
STRONGLY THE COURT ON. THE
COURT. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT
TWENTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YES THIS IS ALAN OUR GUNS I'M A
PROFESSOR OF ORTHOPEDIC SURGERY
AT UC SAN DIEGO AND ALSO A
SUPPORTER OF NEVER AGAIN
CALIFORNIA AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT. S. B. TWO SIX STATE
PARK THANK YOU. THANK YOU YOUR
NEXT WHAT'S WHY NUMBER EIGHTY
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
HYPERVENOM I'M CALLING FROM
WOMEN FOR AMERICAN VALUES AND
ETHICS IN NEWPORT BEACH I-
STRONGLY SUPPORTING ATHLETES
YOU SIX FOUR THANK YOU. THANK
YOU AS A REMINDER IF YOU WISH
TO MAKE A COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF
S. B. TWO SIX FOUR PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND ZERO AT THIS TIME. THAT
WE DO HAVE THREE MORE IN HERE
JUST BE ONE MOMENT FOR NEXT
COMMENTS.
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR
YOUR PATIENCE JUST ONE MORE
MOMENT FOR THE NEXT COMMON.
THERE WERE LINES FOR TWENTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES
HELLO- MY NAME IS FRANCESCA
WANDER BOB IN THE CHAMPIONSHIP
STYLE NUMBER OF INDIVISIBLE AND
I AM CALLING IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU AND THE NEXT COMMENTED
STREAMLINED FOR THIRTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS NOT
THE NEED FROM ORANGE COUNTY I'M
CALLING ON BEHALF OF ASIAN
AMERICANS IN ACTION IN CONCORD
OF SB TWO FIFTY FOUR THANK YOU.
OH MY GOD I CAN'T SEEM TO TURN
OFF. THANK YOU ONE MOMENT
SHARON LAST COMMENT. ANY
ADDITIONAL CALLERS MODERATOR I
DO HAVE ONE IN Q. IT'LL JUST BE
ONE MOMENT THANK YOU GIVING
THEM THEIR LINE NUMBER DOWN.
AND WE'RE TRYING TO ONE SEVENTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES THIS IS
JILL COOPER FROM NEVER AGAIN
CALIFORNIA I'M A RETIRED
TEACHER WHO STRONGLY SUPPORTS
SB. TWO SIXTY FOUR. THANK YOU
AND I HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT
THANK YOU AT THIS TIME. THANK
YOU MODERATOR- NOW LET'S MOVE
TO OPPOSITION WE HAVE TWO
PRIMARY. LEAGUE WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION OF US THREE TWO SIX
FOUR WE HAVE. COREY BOILS AND
WE HAVE DAN REID ARE EITHER OF
THEM QUEUED UP READY TO GO.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
CODY BOILED HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE WESTERN FAIRS ASSOCIATION
RESPECTIVELY OPPOSED SB TWO
SIXTY FOUR THAT WOULD AFFECT
ALL SEVENTY FOUR FAIRGROUNDS IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA THE
NETWORK A CALIFORNIA BEARS
EXPECTED TO BE FINANCIALLY SELF
RELIANT RECEIVE MINIMAL FUNDING
FROM THE STATE EACH YEAR YET
DISREGARD CONTROL SO G. AGENT
AND COUNTY FAIRS SERVE NUMEROUS
FUNCTIONS FOR LOCAL
COMMUNITIES. THESE FUNCTIONS
INCLUDE BUT ARE NOT LIMITED TO
ACTING AND STAGING AREAS AND
EVACUATION POINTS FOR WILDFIRES
NATURAL DISASTERS HOUSING
HOMELESS SHELTERS AND CURRENTLY
ACTIVE KOBE NINETEEN TESTING A
VACCINE DISTRIBUTION CENTERS AS
A RESULT EACH FAIR HOSTED
BENTON CONVENTION CENTER OF
LOCAL INTERESTS IN ORDER TO
BETTER SERVE THEIR RESPECTIVE
COMMUNITIES AND GENERATE THE
NECESSARY REVENUE TO KEEP THE
FAIR OPERATING. WE AGREE WITH
THE CENTER THE PUBLIC SAFETY
MUST ALWAYS BE A TOP PRIORITY
IN ANY EVENT THAT A FAIRGROUND
HELD AT THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS
POINTS OUT CURRENT LAW MANDATES
THAT ALL FIREARMS TRANSACTIONS
TAKING PLACE ON FAIRGROUNDS BE
SUBJECT TO THE SAME TEN DAY
WAITING PERIOD THAT WOULD BE-
PURCHASED AT A GUN STORE.
REQUIRES A FIREARM TO REMAIN IN
THE POSITION OF THE TRANSACTING
DEALER UNTIL THAT PERIOD ENDS
IN THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
HAS COMPLETED THE REQUIRED
BACKGROUND CHECK WESTERN BEARS
EDUCATION IN THE ALLIANCE THE
CALIFORNIA BEARS BELIEVE THAT
LOCAL AIRPORTS KNOW WHAT TYPE
OF EVENT BEST SERVE THEIR
COMMUNITIES SB TWO SIXTY FOUR
TAKES A FULL CONTROL WAY AND
TEXTBOOKS AND SET THE PRECEDENT
THAT THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
CAN DICTATE TO LOCAL FAIRS WHAT
EVENTS BEST SERVE THE LOCAL
COMMUNITY AND WHICH DO NOT I
LIKE TO THINK THE SENATOR STAFF
FOR THE ONGOING DISCUSSIONS
THAT WE'VE HAD WITH HIS OFFICE
AND THE COURT CONTINUED I'M
SURE THIS WILL GO FORWARD THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. NEXT WITNESS.
GERMAN THIS IS GOING TO HEARING.
YES WE CAN DO NOT AB DE READ.
OKAY GOT. WE ARE YOU. RICHARD
SHERMAN CAN YOU HEAR ME WE CAN
HEAR YOU LOUD AND CLEAR. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AJIT ROY
GRIFFITH. THE LEGISLATIVE
DIRECTOR FOR CALIFORNIA RIFLE
AND PISTOL ASSOCIATION CAN READ
A STEP AWAY FOR A FAMILY MATTER
TODAY I'M ALSO SPEAKING ON-BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA GUN OWNERS
NATIONAL RIFLE ASSOCIATION
NATIONAL SHOOTING SPORTS
FOUNDATION CALIFORNIA DEER
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA ALBUM
FOR CONSERVATION CALIFORNIA
BOWHUNTERS. CHANGING OLD COUNTY
WILDLIFE FEDERATION AND MANY
OTHERS WE BELIEVE SENATE BILL
TWO SIXTY FOUR IS A DIRECT
ATTACK ON THE LAWFUL PROCESS
ORDER IN PLACE AND IS
UNCONSTITUTIONAL. CLEARLY THIS.
WOULD DEVASTATE GUN SHOWS BOTH
THE NONPROFIT AND THE PROFIT.
TO PARTICIPATE WHO EXERCISE THE
RIGHT TO TURN THESE LAWFULLY
AND PURCHASE ITEMS AT THESE
EVENTS FROM CALIFORNIA.
REVERSION TO THIS BILL HAVE
BEEN DETERRED BY TWO PREVIOUS
GOVERNORS. I'M VERY
DISAPPOINTED TO HEAR THIS
AUTHORED THE PREVIOUS AUTHORS
CONTINUE TO MAKE FALSE CLAIMS
OF THESE GUN SHOWS REPRESENT A
THREAT TO THEIR COMMUNITIES.
THE CALIFORNIA RIVAL
CRYSTALLIZATION SUBMITTED
PUBLICLY RECORDS REQUEST
SEEKING INFORMATION RELATED TO
THE STATEMENT THE LAST TWO
YEARS AND TO DATE NO RECORDS
HAVE BEEN PRODUCED. MAKING SUCH
INACCURATE CLAIMS TO
LEGISLATORS IN AN EFFORT TO
WRONGLY WRONGFULLY INFLUENCE
POLICY DECISIONS IS UNETHICAL
AND UNFAIR TO THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC. PROMOTERS AND OPERATORS
OF GUN SHOWS WHAT COMPLY WITH
NO LESS THAN TWENTY SIX
SECTIONS OF THE PENAL CODE.
CONTROLS ARE HIGHLY REGULATED
IN CALIFORNIA AND WALDRON NO
LESS STRINGENT. FOR THOSE
VENDORS AT GUN SHOWS. HIS
MEETING UNTIL MAY. NOT DO SO I
THEY'RE LIKE. HAVE BEEN SOME
AND CAL BAR OF JUST. FOR THE
EVENT. AND COME. VETTED BEFORE
THEY'RE ALLOWED TO ATTEND. TWO
SIX FOUR WAS TO PROHIBIT
FIREARM PRECURSOR PART
SPONSORED AND COUNTY PROPERTY.
WHEN AB SEVENTY NINE WAS SIGNED
INTO LAW LAST YEAR AND WILL BE
IMPLEMENTED IN TWENTY TWENTY
FIVE THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
WILL BE TASKED RECORDING A
STAGGERING NUMBER OF
TRANSACTIONS AS FARMS ARE
LITERALLY MADE DOZENS OF PARTS.
NOW ADD TO THIS LIST
RESPONSIBILITY PATROL
PATROLLING GUN SHOWS ALL OVER
CALIFORNIA FOR PARKS BETTER YET
YOU FIND. ALL THIS WHILE WE'RE
TEN THOUSAND KNOWN ARBORETUM
CHALLENGE CONTINUE TO GROW IN
CALIFORNIA. WE ARE CONFUSED
ABOUT THE AUTHOR'S. INTENT FOR
THIS LEGISLATION. JULY TWENTY
TO BUT SIGNED INTO LAW A BILL
AB- EIGHT FIFTY SEVEN TO
PROHIBIT GHOST GUNS ALREADY.
INFORMED MADE OR MANUFACTURED
HOME CALIFORNIA REQUIRES A
SERIAL NUMBER TO BE OBTAINED
FROM DOJ REPLY TO THIS FARM. SO
THE ONLY LEGAL TO. TO USE
PRETTY CERTAIN PARTS TO MAKE
COLLEGE GUNS AND DATE TO GO TO
DATE WITH CURRENT MUCH LIKE TO
HAVE A DEFINITION OF JUST WHAT
THE AS A PRECURSOR PARK. WE WE
DIDN'T EVEN HAVE THAT
DEFINITION AND WE'RE TRYING TO
MAKE THEM EVEN MORE. UNLAWFUL
TO SELL. YEAH YES B. TWO SIX
FOUR IS PASSED RESOLVE IN ON A-
AND COSTLY LOS. CREATED IN.
NIGHTMARE STATE AND COUNTY FOR.
OR ALREADY SPREAD FAR TO. I
GREATLY APPRECIATE YOUR TIME
AND WE STRONGLY ENCOURAGE
JOURNAL SB TWO SIXTY FOUR AND
WE VERY MUCH WOULD STILL LOOK
TO SEE SOME PROOF OR EVIDENCE
PRESENTED BY HIS FATHER. AS TO
THE DANGERS OF THE SHOWS ON
COUNTIES THERE'S VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE YOUR. TIME THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. MY CAN WE GO TO
WHAT LET'S GO BACK TO- HERE TO
ROOM- FORTY TWO OH THREE ARE
THERE ANY WITNESSES- AND IT'S
OPPOSITION- SB TWO SIX FOUR YOU
CAN COME TO THE PARK TO GLASS
RIGHT THERE STATE YOUR NAME AND
YOUR POSITION. THANK YOU
CHAIRMAN AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS
BURKE. YOU SPEAK BEFORE YOU
TODAY MY NAME IS GUY MYERS I AM
A LICENSED GUN SHOW PRODUCER BY
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE I HAVE
OTHER VARIOUS LICENSE WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE AS WELL
AS SOME OTHER GOVERNMENT
AGENCIES ISSUE BY A CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENTS. I'M NOT HERE TO
QUESTION- THE SINCERITY AND THE
THOUGHT OF THE SENATORS
CONCERNED ABOUT SAFETY FOR HIS
FAMILY I WOULD LIKE TO POINT
OUT THOUGH THAT OTHERS HAVE
DESIRED SAFETY FOR THEIR
FAMILIES AND MORE AND MORE
ESPECIALLY IN THE LAST TWELVE
MONTHS FROM WHAT I'VE SEEN.
THERE ARE MORE AND MORE. ALL
THAT ARE CONCERNED ABOUT THE
SAFETY OF THEIR FAMILIES AND
THE WAY THAT THEY WANT TO-
RESPOND TO THAT AND HAVE THE
ABILITY TO KEEP THEIR FAMILY
SAFE. I'M NOT QUESTIONING YOUR
MOTIVES I THINK YOUR MOTIVES
ARE ON A ROLL HE WOULD LIKE TO
SEE. A SAFER SOCIETY THAT'S
GREAT- I THINK DON'T THERE IS
SOME MISINFORMATION GOING
AROUND AND SOME OF YOUR
ASSUMPTIONS. THIS IS NOT THE
FORMAT TO DISCUSS THOSE I WOULD
BE HAPPY FOR ANY OF YOUR STAFF
TO GIVE ME A CALL. I WOULD BE
HAPPY TO SHOW THEM WHAT WE DO.
NO GUNS ARE. TRANSFERRED AT GUN
SHOWS. YOU CAN PUT A DEPOSIT ON
THE GUN. YOU CAN TELL HERE
BACKGROUND INFORMATION AND THEN
YOU HAVE TO WAIT AND PICK IT UP
AT THE LOCAL TRANSFER DEALERS.
SO THERE'S NO GUNS GOING OUT
THAT GUN SHOWS. WE HAVE LOTS OF
STAMPED WE HAVE WARM STAFF THE
PROJECT THE PRODUCTS SO THEY
DON'T GET STOLEN. THERE'S A LOT
OF MISINFORMATION LIKE I SAY
THIS IS NOT THE FORMAT TO
DISCUSS THAT IN. BUT I WANT TO
PUT. MY FACE OUT HERE'S THE
EMAIL THERE ARE US OUT THERE
MAKING A LIVING. IN THE GUN
SHOW. INDUSTRY AND WE RESPECT
YOUR CONCERN FOR SAFETY WE ALL
HAVE CONCERN FOR SAFETY. NOBODY
WANTS BALANCE HAVING GUNS OKAY.
NOBODY I APPRECIATE YOUR TIME
AND I WOULD APPRECIATE IF YOU.
VOTE NO ON THIS PROPOSAL LIKE I
SAY. THANK YOU TIMES YOU LIKE
YOUR STAFF. TO CHAT WITH ME IF
YOU HAVE TO DO THAT. SHOULD ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION HERE AND- FORTY TWO
ALL THREE. XINING ON LET'S NOT
MOVE TO ROOM TO FOUR. ANYWAY
THIS I IN OPPOSITION OF. TWO
SIXTY FOUR. CENA NAINA
MODERATOR CAN WE GO TO THE
PHONE LINES FOR CALLERS IN
OPPOSITION OF S. B. TWO SIX
FOUR. EIGHT THANK YOU IF YOU
WISH TO MAKE A COMMENT IN
OPPOSITION OF S. B. TWO SIX
FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND I
CURRENTLY HAVE ABOUT TWENTY
FIVE IN Q. OR JUST A LINE OF
THREE SEVENTY THREE PLEASE GLAD.
BY THIS IS MARK HENLEY WITH
CALIFORNIA WATER ASSOCIATION OR
WETLANDS CONSERVATION GROUP
THIS BILL NEGATIVELY IMPACT
BURKE FUND RAISING EVENT- WORKS
FIREARMS ARE RAFFLED OR
AUCTIONED OFF. IN ARMS- THERE-
JUST NEED YOUR NAME INNER
EDITION PLEASE. ARE NOT IN
TRIBUNE THAT THE GUN VIOLENCE
PROBLEM WE ARE DROPPED WAS
ISSUED. THANK YOU THANKS TO
THIS. IT THANK YOU I'M FOUR
FOUR THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
BLANKS FOR FORTY THREE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANKS FOR TWELFTH
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS
JOHN EGGMAN I AM THE CHAIRMAN
THE BALLOT COUNTY GUN OWNERS
AND C. R. P. A MEMBER NRA LIFE
MEMBER FARMS POLICY COALITION
MEMBER GUN OWNERS OF AMERICA
MEMBER SECOND AMENDMENT
FOUNDATION CONTRIBUTOR- BY IS
STRONGLY OPPOSE SB. TWO SIXTY
FOUR. Q. THE QUICKNESS. THANK
YOU RYAN FOR THIRTY ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. DANIEL HANSEN CFTA
NUMBER AND REMEMBER YOUR ONLY
OPPOSED SENATE BILL TWO SIXTY
FOUR THANK YOU. THANK YOU OF
MINE FOR FORTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS KATHY
MURPHY. I AM A MEMBER OF NEVER
AGAIN CALIFORNIA I AM A VERY
STRONG SUPPORTER S. B. TWO SIX
FOUR. THANK YOU FOR DOING
OPPOSITION RIGHT NOW BUT WE
APPRECIATE YOUR TESTIMONY THANK
YOU. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT TO
SIXTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU MY NAME IS CARLENE
ELLIS AND I AM A LAW ABIDING
GUN OWNERS AND A COMPETITIVE
SHOOTER AND I'M A TAXPAYER- I
AM A MEMBER OF THE SOUTH
SACRAMENTO CHAPTER OF THE
CALIFORNIA RIFLE AND PISTOL
ASSOCIATION THE GUN OWNERS OF
CALIFORNIA. INTERNATIONAL
DEFENSIVE PISTOL ASSOCIATION
AND THE SACRAMENTO DEFENSIVE
PISTOL SHOOTERS AMONG MANY
OTHERS AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE S.
B. TWO SIXTY FOUR THANK YOU
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT
FOURTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS BRIAN LONG A MEMBER OF
COWBOY FAST DRAW ASSOCIATION
AND CALIFORNIA RIFLE AND PISTOL
ASSOCIATION I STRONGLY OPPOSE.
TWO SIXTY FOUR THANK YOU THANK
YOU. THANK YOU BRIAN FOR TWENTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. BLIND FOR
TWO ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS ERIN AND MICHAEL- HAVE
A NUMBER OF CALIFORNIA RIFLE
AND PISTOL ASSOCIATION AND- THE
PROBLEM THAT THAT WERE-
REPORTED DOESN'T SOUND LIKE A
GUN SHOW PROBLEMS SOUNDS LIKE A
POLICING PROBLEM AND I. ALSO I
DON'T THINK THAT THAT- YEAH. I
MEAN YOU POSITION CLOSE IN ON
THE BILL. I DID OPPOSE STRONGLY
OPPOSE THANK YOU. THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT EIGHTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MISTER CHAIR THE STOMACH
MAN I'M THE CHAIR OF THE SOUTH
SACRAMENTO CHAPTER OF THE
CALIFORNIA RIFLE AND PISTOL
ASSOCIATION AND AN ARMY MEMBER.
IN STRONG OPPOSITION. THANK YOU
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT NINETY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ASSEMBLY MYERS
MEMBER OF- CALIFORNIA RIFLE AND
PISTOL CERTIFIED NRA INSTRUCTOR
STRONGLY OPPOSED TO SIXTY FOUR.
THANK YOU THANK YOU RAIMES FOR
THIRTY TO PLEASE GO AHEAD. FOUR
THREE TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MY NAME IS RON LANDER REMEMBER
THE CALIFORNIA RIVAL
DISASSOCIATION THE NRA AND ALSO
MEMBER THE NFPA THREE THOUSAND
ANTI INTO YOU. CITY ORDINANCE
AND ALSO- OPPOSED TO THIS THE
PROPOSAL. YOU NEXT WITNESS
THANK. THANK YOU I'M FOR TWENTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS ALICIA BREWER I WORK
FOR THE CALIFORNIA RIFLE AND
PISTOL ASSOCIATION AND I'M AN
NRA MEMBER AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL. THANK YOU
RIGHT FOR FORTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS JOSE
LOPEZ ALL GRINS I'M A MEMBER OF
ASSOCIATION NRA MEMBER AND
SECOND AMENDMENT FOUNDATION
CONTRIBUTOR I STRONGLY OPPOSE
SB. TWO SIXTY FOUR. THANK YOU
ALL RIGHT FOR ELEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME
IS PAT HURDEN CHAIR OF THE
TAKING MY COUNTY CHAPTER OF THE
CALIFORNIA RIFLE AND PISTOL
ASSOCIATION. AND I REMEMBER
RETIRED SERGEANT WITH
CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY PATROL AND I
AM IN STRONG OPPOSITION TO
SENATE BILL TWO SIXTY FOUR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT TO NINETY
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO THIS
IS JOE BLOGGS I'M A MEMBER OF
THE CALIFORNIA RIFLE AND PISTOL
ASSOCIATION GLOCK'S BOARD
SHOULDN'T ON VACATION AND DONE
OWNERS OF AMERICA. I AM IN
STRONG OPPOSITION TO S. B. TWO
SIXTY FOUR THANK YOU. THANK YOU
YOUR MIND FOR TEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS JENNIFER
SMITH I AM THE SECRETARY AT THE
CLINIC COUNTY CHAPTER OF THE
CALIFORNIA RIFLE AND PISTOL
pACCOUNT AGAIN OWNERS AND THE
NRA. AND I AM IN STRONG
OPPOSITION EVENTS B. TWO SIXTY
FOUR THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU BRIAN FOR FOURTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS
STEVE OVER NUMBER RESIDENT
EMERYVILLE CALIFORNIA MEMBERS
THE ALAMEDA COUNTY CHAPTER OF
THE CALIFORNIA RIFLE AND PISTOL
ASSOCIATION NAZARIAN MEMBER
NUMBER GUN WARS ON AMERICA.
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF GUN
RIGHTS MEMBER US TO STILL CARRY
ASSOCIATION MEMBER I AM A
STRONG OPPOSITION TO ASK YOU TO
SIXTY FOUR. THANK YOU RYAN FOR
EIGHTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES
MY NAME IS ROBERT WINDOWS AND
DIOP FOUR FOUR YEAR VOLUNTEER
FOR THE DEPUTY SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT STATION THIRTY HERE
IN SAN DIEGO I'M ALSO TWENTY
FIVE YEAR INSTRUCTOR FOR THE
NRA ANNUAL PROGRAM AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSED SB TWO SIXTY
FOUR. THANK YOU OF MINE FOR
THIRTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
WHEN HE WAS CALLING ME TO LIVE
IN THE RED BLUFF CALIFORNIA
BELONG TO THE CHAMBER COUNTY
GUN OWNERS- STEVEN COUNTY THAT
AIM A COUNTY MICHAEL.
ASSOCIATION SINCE AN IMMENSE
STRONG OPPOSITION TO SB TWO
SIXTY FOUR- WE ARE WORLD IN WE-
ARE. EXPERIENCING A LOT OF
PROBLEMS WE DON'T NEED THE ONE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU THANK YOU
FORTNITE THREE GO AHEAD. HELLO
CAN HEAR ME. YES PLEASE GO
AHEAD. OKAY GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS KRISTA GOT YOU MAN AND
I'M CURRENTLY A MEMBER AND
VOLUNTEER OF THE CALIFORNIA
RIFLE PISTOL SUBSTATION THE NRA
GUN OWNERS OF AMERICA AND
FIREARMS POLICY COALITION AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSED SB TWO SIXTY
FOUR AS THERE ARE SUFFICIENT
AMOUNT OF LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS AND SECURITY
SAFEGUARDING THE SHOW AND ALL
VENDORS FOLLOWED ALL.
REGULATIONS THANK YOU. THANK
YOU ALL RIGHT FOR TWENTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS
MELANIE WHO'D SIGNED A MEMBER
OF THE CALIFORNIA RIFLE PISTOL
ASSOCIATION I AM A LIFETIME NRA
MEMBER I AM INTERNING
INSTRUCTOR I'M A SECOND
AMENDMENT FOUNDATION
CONTRIBUTOR DANNER'S AMERICA I
USE INSTRUCTOR FOR SHOOTING
SPORTS STRONGLY OPPOSE SB.
THREE SIXTY FOUR. THANK YOU A
LINE FOR TWENTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS LLOYD
BRASH I'M A MEMBER OF THE TEAM
THE COUNTY CHAPTER OF THE
CALIFORNIA RIFLE AND PISTOL
ASSOCIATION. AND ALSO IN OUR A
MEMBER AND ON THE STRONG
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL THANK
YOU. THANK YOU OF MINE FOR
THIRTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YES MY NAME IS LLOYD DO LITTLE
I REPRESENT THE GRE RIVERSIDE
CHAPTER I'M ALSO A VICTIM OF
FELONY GUN VIOLENCE. AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSED TO SIXTY FOUR.
THANK YOU RYAN FOR TWENTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MR GERMAN MY NAME IS ROBERT M.
LEE JUNIOR AND THE CHAIRPERSON
OF THE WHOLESOME SLASH MORE
SACRAMENTO CHAPTER OF THE
CALIFORNIA RIFLE AND PISTOL
ASSOCIATION I'M A LIFE MEMBER
OF THE NATIONAL RIFLE
ASSOCIATION AND A FORMER RIFLE
INSTRUCTOR FOR THE BOY SCOUTS
OF AMERICA. I AM IN STRONG
OPPOSITION TO THE SP TWO SIXTY
FOUR THANK YOU. THANK YOU OF
MINE FOR FORTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS HUGH
CRUIKSHANK I'M A CO CHAIR OF
THE BAY AREA C. R. PA CHAPTER
AN NRA MEMBER UNITED STATES CAN
CONCEAL CARRY ASSOCIATION AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU. THANK YOU OF MINE FOR
TWENTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
COLLEEN BASTAR I'M A MEMBER OF
THE CALIFORNIA RIFLE AND PISTOL
ASSOCIATION THE NATIONAL RACK
RIFLE ASSOCIATION AND UNITED
STATES CONCEAL CARRY
ASSOCIATION I AM ABSOLUTELY
OPPOSED TO SB. SIX FOUR THANK
YOU. THANK YOU OF MINE FOR
THIRTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
KEVIN LEAST SMALL BUSINESS
OWNER FROM ORANGE COUNTY
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG OPPOSITION
S. B. TWO SIXTY FOUR. THANK YOU
ALL RIGHT FOUR FIFTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. FIFTY FOUR HI
THIS IS JAMES WESTFALL- FORMER
STATE EMPLOYEE I'M A MEMBER OF
C. A. R. P. A. AND SECRETARY OF
THE ALAMEDA COUNTY GUN OWNERS
CHAPTER- BELONG TO IN OUR A AND
THE CALIFORNIA GUN OWNERS
ASSOCIATION. I'M STRONGLY
OPPOSED TO THIS BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AS A REMINDER IF YOU
WISH TO MAKE A COMMENT IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND WEBER
TWENTY FOUR FIFTY SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YES MY NAME IS SANDRA
MCMAHON. NUMBER OF THE
SACRAMENTO CHAPTER OF THE WELL
ARMED WOMAN IN STRONG
OPPOSITION OF SENATE BILL. TWO
SIXTY FOUR. THANK YOU AND I DO
HAVE ONE MORNING HERE TO JUST
BE ONE MOMENT FOR THAT LINE.
THE LION FOR SIXTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY NAME SAID HE DID ON
THE COCHAIRMAN OF THE ALAMEDA
COUNTY CHAPTER OF CALIFORNIA
RIFLE AND PISTOL ASSOCIATION
AND LIFE MEMBER OF THE NRA AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSED SB. TWO
SIXTY FOUR. THANK YOU THANK YOU
I HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENTS
THANK YOU AT THIS TIME. I WOULD
YOU SAYS ONE MORE TIME IF
THERE'RE ANY POTENTIAL
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION-
MODERATOR YOU DON'T MIND. THANK
YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. I
DO HAVE ONE THAT JUST STORING
THE QUEUE FOR EIGHTEEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS THANK
YOU MEMBERS AND I'M A MEMBER OF
AARP APRIL NINTH SAN DIEGO
CHAPTER AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THE SALE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
I HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT THANK
YOU AT THIS TIME THANK YOU
MODERATOR I WILL BRING IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS
BYE COMMITTEE CENTER WINNER NOW
OKAY IF A AYE AYE- JUST WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING
THIS FORWARD- HI WE HAVE A LONG
HISTORY ON THE CAL PALACE AND
IT'S GOING SHOWS. WHERE JACKIE
SPEAR WAS THE FIRST TO TRY TO
BAN THEM AND MARK LANA PICKED
IT UP AND THEN- HIGH ALONG WITH
TILTING WE TOOK UP THE TORCH
AND ULTIMATELY NEVER QUITE GOT
THE BILL PASSED VETOED VARIOUS
TIMES AND ALL THAT BUT WE
FINALLY WERE ABLE. TO MAKE THE
POINTER CAL PALACE AVE REALLY
SHOULDN'T BE HAVING GUNS SHOWS
AND THEY FINALLY COUNCIL THE
GUN SHOWS BUT I KNOW THIS IS AN
ISSUE IN VARIOUS PARTS OF THE
STATE AND THE REALITY IS THAT
WE SHOULDN'T BE SELLING GUNS ON.
STATE LANDS THIS COUNTRY. IS
AWASH IN GUN THAT TO SERVER
WILL AWAY FROM CRIME- NO REASON
FOR THEIR- OF GUN FOR K. THAT
WE HAVE IN THIS COUNTRY. MORE
GUNS MEANS MORE PEOPLE GET
SHOT. AND WE HAVE AN ABSOLUTE-
PARKS CLOSE ENOUGH PEOPLE
GETTING SHOT IN THIS COUNTRY
INCLUDING CHILDREN'S SCHOOL SO.
I SUPPORT THIS LEGISLATION- AND
I MOVE THE BILL. THANK YOU. ANY
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS REQUESTED
BY COMMITTEES. CENTER- CHOI
BOGUE. HELLO SENATOR MAN THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR BRINGING THIS
FORTH I HAD A QUESTION WELL A
COUPLE OF POINTS OUT QUESTIONS
AND COMMENTS- BOTH THE
AGRICULTURAL THE COUNTY FAIRS
CURRENTLY- DECIDE. WHAT TYPE OF
SHOWS ARE GOING TO HAVE IN THE
COUNTIES RIGHT. YES SO IT'S I'M
A HUGE PERSONAL ON LOCAL
CONTROL SO THAT'S IMPORTANT.
AND THESE BOARDS ARE APPOINTED
HOW AND BY WHOM- TYPICALLY BY
THE GOVERNOR'S MY
UNDERSTANDING. SO THE GOVERNOR
APPOINTS THE BOARD MEMBERS FOR
THE AGRICULTURAL DISTRICT IN
THE COUNTY FAIRS WHO DECIDE
WHICH- WHICH- WHICH SHOWS TO
HAVE IN THERE. OKAY SO ON THAT
LEVEL. I'M I'M HESITANT TO PASS
A ONE SIZE FITS ALL BECAUSE I
ALSO UNDERSTAND- AND THEN GIVEN
THE CONTEXT OF WHERE I'M COMING
FROM- CULTURALLY THERE'S A LOT
OF- I KNOW PERSONALLY MANY MANY
PEOPLE WHO- BUYING GUNS AND
COLLECTING GUNS IS A CULTURAL
FAMILY AFFAIR- AND IT'S THESE
ARE GOOD PEOPLE WHO ARE-
EMOTIONALLY HEALTHY BE HERE
REALLY HEALTHY AND- IT'S A-
SENATE. PASSAGE IT'S A BECAUSE
THAT IS THE CULTURAL FAMILY
ENDEAVOR- AND I'M- THIS IS JUST
A PERSONAL OPINION- BUT IT IT
IT MAKES ME A LITTLE HESITANT
TO. MAKE IT APPEAR COME ACROSS
AS THESE PEOPLE ARE- IN THE
WRONG. ST I'M VERY RESPECTFUL
ABOUT CULTURAL ESPECIALLY WHEN
IT'S DONE THE HEALTHY
ENVIRONMENT. SO HAVING SAID
THAT- DO YOU THINK THAT TE-
THE AGRICULTURE IN THE COUNTY
FAIRS HAVE THE ABILITY TO- MEET
THE NEEDS OF THEIR- OF THEIR
CONSTITUENTS AS FAR AS
LISTENING AND HEEDING TO WHAT
THEIR CONSTITUENTS WANT IN
ORDER TO BE ABLE TO SHOW IN
THEIR IN THEIR COUNTY FAIRS.
I'M A QUESTION. FIVE YES- AND
SO TO ANSWER YOUR FIRST POINT I
ALSO APPRECIATE THE CONCEPT OF
LOCAL CONTROL I THINK THERE'S
ALWAYS A BALANCE OF COURSE AND
I THINK YOU QUESTION FIRST OF
ALL SENATOR- I THINK THERE'S A
BALANCE OF COURSE BETWEEN
STATEWIDE. POLICY PRIORITIES
AND THIS IS ONE WHERE I THINK
IT THE DATA IS CLEAR WE HAVE A
GUN VIOLENCE EPIDEMIC IN THE
STATE IN IN THIS COUNTRY. AND I
GUESS THE ANALOGY I WOULD USE
WOULD BE TO SEAT BELTS AND CAR
SAFETY AND AIR BAGS BACK IN THE
SIXTIES AND SEVENTIES- THE
AUTOMOBILE MANUFACTURERS DIDN'T
WANT TO DO IT PEOPLE DIDN'T
WANT TO HAVE MANDATORY SEATBELT
LAWS- THIS WAS SOMETHING THAT
WAS- MUCH LIKE WHAT WE'RE
DISCUSSING TODAY- YOU KNOW. PUT
DOWN ON LOCAL CONTROL SO TO
SPEAK BUT IT SAVES LIVES- AND
THERE WAS A- OBSTINANCE AND- A
REAL. PUSH BACK AGAINST THESE
TYPES OF REGULATIONS- WHAT I'M
PROPOSING I DON'T THINK IS
TOTALLY UNREASONABLE
PARTICULARLY GIVEN THAT AS I
UNDERSTAND I'VE BEEN TOLD BY MY
LOCAL FAIR BOARD. THAT THEY
DON'T FEEL LIKE THEY ARE
SUPPOSED TO RESPOND T
CONSTITUENCIES THEY'RE SUPPOSED
TO MAKE SURE THEY'RE SOLVING
QUOTE UNQUOTE RIGHT AND I HAD
TO DRESS THAT POINT WE'RE NOT
TALKING ABOUT A LOT OF MONEY
FOR FAIRGROUND SO MY FAIRGROUND
SAID THEY NEEDED THE MONEY- WE
LOOKED INTO WHAT THEY WERE
ACTUALLY MAKING IT WAS POINT
TWO THREE PERCENT. OF THEIR
ANNUAL REVENUES- BUT OF COURSE
IF YOU FEEL LIKE YOUR
OBLIGATION I THINK MANY FAIR
BOARD MEMBERS TO FEEL THIS WAY.
IS TO MAXIMIZE YOUR REVENUE
INTAKE THEN YOU'RE GONNA TAKE
WHATEVER YOU CAN NOW THE ONE OF
THE CHALLENGES I HAVE IT WITH
THIS REASONING FOR- DILEMMAS I
HAVE WITH IT IS. YOU KNOW THEY
ALSO DON'T TAKE PORN
CONVENTIONS OR MARIJUANA
CONVENTIONS WE ASK THEM I DON'T
DO THAT BECAUSE THAT WOULD BE A
LOT OF MONEY TO THEY SAY IT'S
BECAUSE THOSE ARE NOT FAMILY
FRIENDLY AND WE'RE SUPPOSED TO.
BE A FAMILY FRIENDLY VENUE WHY
I WOULD SUBMIT TO YOU ALL THAT.
GUN VIOLENCE IS MUCH MORE
FAMILY PROBLEMATIC AND ON
FAMILY FRIENDLY THEN PORN OR
CANNABIS AND THAT'S. NOT THE
CITY TO BE INDOORS ONE OF THOSE
TWO BUT OTHER TO SAY. BECAUSE
AT THE END. MECHANISMS I JUST
THINK THERE'S SOME WRONG. I'LL
SAY THAT MIGHT VERY OWN THIS IS
TRANSCEND. SO FRANCISCO. ACROSS
THIS. ARE NOT RESPONDING TO
WHAT I THINK SHE IS SEE. AN
OUTPOURING OF SUPPORT IN MY
DISTRICT IN ORANGE COUNTY FOR.
YOU KNOW GETTING GUNS OFF THE
STREET AND NONE OF THIS BY THE
WAY TAKES GUNS AWAY AWAY FROM
GUN STORES DOESN'T IN HIM
FRENCH UPON PEOPLE'S RIGHTS TO
LAWFULLY PURCHASING ON A GUN.
ALL IT SAYS IS THAT WE DON'T
WANT TAXPAYER VENUES TO BE USED
FOR THOSE PURPOSES. SO I DON'T
THINK THIS REALLY INFRINGES ON
PRINCIPLES- THAT YOU'RE
IMPLICATING BUT BUT I
UNDERSTAND THERE IS A
DIFFERENCE. IN HOW WE VIEW GUNS
AND I WOULD SUBMIT THAT. THIS
IS AN ATTEMPT TO KIND OF. THE
SORT OF BRIDGE THE DIFFERENCE A
LITTLE BIT IT'S NOT FORCING
ANYTHING IT'S SIMPLY SAYING
THAT. STATE OWNED PROPERTY
SHOULD NOT BE A CONDUIT. FOR
DISTRIBUTING MORE GUNS INTO
COMMUNITIES. SO TO THAT I WOULD
FOLLOW UP WITH ANOTHER QUESTION
ASKED TO. IF THESE WE
UNDERSTAND THAT THE- GUN
INDUSTRY IS VERY MUCH REGULATED
HIGHLY REGULATED IN CALIFORNIA-
THESE ARE IT LEGALLY OWNED AND
LEGALLY. LEGALLY A BITING. OUT
BUSINESSES FUNCTIONING IN THESE
ENDEAVORS. WHAT IN YOUR BEING
SENT TO YOUR ATTORNEY SAM I
RESPECT I RESPECT YOUR BUT YOUR
YOUR OPINION ON THIS BUT WHAT
TO- WHAT GROUNDS COULD WE HAVE
IS A STATE TO MANDATE NOT BE
ABLE TO HAVE THESE BUSINESSES.
OUT FUNCTION OR DO BUSINESS ON
ON ON THE PUBLIC- PUBLIC LANDS
OR PUBLIC VENUES. BECAUSE THE
STATE PROPERTY I DON'T THINK
THE COMMITTEES EVER RAISED AN
ISSUE AND I KNOW THAT- THE HEAD
OF- THE- LIAISON- MISTER
GRIFFIN FROM CPC RPA REYES
STATE CONSTITUTIONALITY ISSUE.
I DON'T THINK THAT'S WELL
FOUNDED NIGHT THAT THE C. R.
P.'S LAWSUITS. AGAINST SAN
DIEGO AND HAVE NOT GONE
ANYWHERE BOB THIS IS EVEN MORE
WELL GROUNDED BECAUSE WE'RE NOT
TALKING ABOUT PEOPLE DISCONNECT
YOUR TALKING ABOUT. THE STATE
SAYING THAT WE DON'T WANT
CERTAIN ACTIVITIES DONE ON
STATE PROPERTY IT'S OUR
PROPERTY. AND AS MUCH AS I DO
RESPECT THE SECOND AMENDMENT I
WOULD ALSO POINT OUT THAT THE
TENTH AMENDMENT. GIVES THE
STATE'S INCLUDING THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA SIGNIFICANTLY WAY TO
MANAGE OUR OWN AFFAIRS NOW WE
CANNOT TELL GUNNED IT STORES
YOU KNOW YOU CAN'T SELL GUNS WE
CAN'T WE CAN'T WE CAN'T TELL
GUN OWNERS YOU CAN'T OWN GUNS
THE SECOND AMENDMENT. AS
INTERPRETED BY THE SUPREME
COURT UNITED STATES HAS MADE
THAT CLEAR. BUT NEITHER CAN THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT OR ANYONE
ELSE TELL THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. WHAT WE CAN OR
CANNOT DO WITH OUR PROPERTY.
OKAY. AND JUST SO HIS WORDS
WERE CLEAR THESE ARE LEGAL
ACTIVITIES- THAT ARE GOING ON
WITH- AND PERSON BECAUSE I KNOW
MANY OF THE FAMILY MEMBERS AND-
AND INDIVIDUALS THAT ATTEND
THESE EVENTS- WITH HEALTHY MIND
SAID SPEAR REALLY WHILE DOING
IT A CULTURAL FAMILY THING
ATTENDING THESE THEY FOLLOW THE
LAWS THEY DO EVERYTHING THAT
THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO BE DOING IT
AND AS THE GENTLEMAN THE
WITNESS. STATED EARLIER THERE
ARE NO GUNS THAT ARE ACTUALLY
BEING TRANSMITTED OR BEING SOLD
RIGHT AT THAT TIME THEY STILL
HAVE TO GO TO THE TEN DAY
PROCESS RIGHT ALTHOUGH IT'S HAS
BEEN DESCRIBED BY NUMEROUS
PEOPLE AND I'M NOT REALLY AND
IT'S UNFORTUNATE THAT MR
LINDLEY WAS NOT ABLE TO TESTIFY
BECAUSE HE WAS GOING TO SPEAK
AT THIS POINT- BUT WHAT HE'S
GOING TO DESCRIBE WAS A CIRCUS
OR A CARNIVAL LIKE ATMOSPHERE
AND SO THERE ARE LOTS OF GUN
SALES THAT HAPPENED JUST IN THE
PARKING LOT FOR A HAPPEN
THROUGH VAN KNOW WHERE THE GUN
IS DELIVERED LATER AND SO- WHAT
HE'S GOING TO TESTIFY TO IS
THAT HE HAD PERSONALLY
WITNESSED. A NUMBER OF DEALERS
BEING WILLING TO ENGAGE IN SO
CALLED STRAW SALES WHICH IS I'M
GOING UP THERE IN PURCHASING ON
BEHALF OF SOMEONE ELSE IS VERY
CLEAR ON PURCHASING FOR SOMEONE
ELSE A NUMBER OF GUN DEALERS
APPEARED WILLING TO ENGAGE IN
THOSE TYPES OF TRANSACTIONS
OTHER TYPES OF UNLICENSED SALES
APPEAR TO BE OCCURRING AS WELL
SO I WOULD TAKE DISPUTE WITH
THAT- CLAIM THAT YOU KNOW FIRST
OF ALL IT'S KIND OF TOUGH TO
SAY THERE'S A 100% OF ANYTHING
RIGHT. BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT
PEOPLE DON'T ALWAYS FOLLOW THE
LAW- BUT JUST GIVEN THE
ATMOSPHERE- IT'S BEEN I THINK
WELL DOCUMENTED THAT THAT THERE
ARE A LOT OF- UNSEEMLY ILLICIT
PURCHASES AND SALES THE CURRENT
THESE GUN SHOWS EVEN IF THAT WE
REGULATE AWAY AND SO THIS IS
KIND OF A HOT BED OF STUFF LIKE
THAT ACCORDING TO A NUMBER OF
STUDIES AND TESTIMONIES OF
FOLKS LIKE MISTER LINDLEY. DO
WE HAVE ANY DATA THAT. HAS A-
BETWEEN- IN GUNS OR- WHATEVER
YOU CAN PURCHASE- RIFLES OR SO
FORTH IT. DON'T KNOW ALL THE
AT. ALL THE DIFFERENT YPES OF.
GUNS PER SE BUT- DO WE HAVE ANY
DATA THAT STIPULATE OR
CORRELATE- HOW MANY OF THOSE
THAT ARE BOUGHT AT GUN SHOWS
ARE ATTRIBUTED TO CRIMES. IT IS
TOUGH TO TRACK THEM WHAT WHAT
HAS BEEN STATED IS THAT- I
THINK IT WAS LET ME SEE HERE IT
WOULD MIGHT BEEN THE- FBI OR
ATF HAS SAID- THAT GUN SHOWS OR
THE CRITICAL MOMENT IN THE
CHAIN OF CUSTODY FOR MANY GUNS
THE POINT AT WHICH THEY MOVE
FROM THE SOMEWHAT REGULATED
LEGAL MARKET. THE SHADOW WE NO
QUESTIONS ASKED THE LEGAL
MARKET- LET'S SEE HERE. 80% OF
FIRE ARMS AND SEIZED BY MEXICAN
AUTHORITIES IN LAST FIVE YEARS
HAVE COME TO THE UNITED STATES.
AND IT IS BELIEVED I GET IT
THIS IS A IT'S HARD TO FIND
DATA BECAUSE WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT A BY DEFINITION.
SOMETHING THAT'S ILLEGAL RIGHT
SO WE DON'T KNOW WHERE THEY
ORIGINATE FROM BUT THERE IS A
THERE'S CLEAR EVIDENCE THAT
THERE ARE. PURCHASES AND SALES
OF THESE TYPES OF GUNS AND THEN
THE QUESTION IS HOW MANY MOVES
INTO THAT. STREAM OF ILLICIT
GUNS AND- YOU KNOW JUST TO BE
PERFECTLY HONEST I DON'T THINK
ANYONE HAS THAT DATE I'M NOT
SURE IF IT'S REALLY SOMETHING
YOU'RE ABLE TO GOING TO BE ABLE
TO QUALIFY- BUT IT DOES. PEOPLE
HAVE BEEN CONCERNED THAT THIS
DOES HAPPEN. OKAY AND IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING AND CORRECT ME IF
I'M WRONG BECAUSE I DON'T KNOW
BUT- DID THEY HAVE UNDER COVER-
OFFICERS ON THE GROUNDS WHEN
THEY'RE THEY'RE SELLING- GUNS
AT THE GUN SHOWS. I'M SURE THEY
DO OF UNDERCOVER OFFICERS THEY
CERTAINLY OF UNIFORMED
OFFICERS. AND- BUT YOU KNOW
AGAIN. IT'S JUST KIND OF THE
NATURE OF THE TRANSACTION RIGHT
AND SO- FOR EXAMPLE AGAIN THERE
HAVE BEEN NUMEROUS PEOPLE THAT
HAVE GONE TO GUN SHOWS AND IT
TRIED TO ENGAGE IN ILLEGAL.
TRANSACTIONS AND THEY HAD
DOCUMENTED THAT IN FACT THERE
WERE SAILORS DEALERS WILLING TO
ENGAGE IN THESE THESE WERE NOT
LAW ENFORCEMENT BUT BUT BACK
NAY JUST GIVE YOU SOME CONTEXT
INTO WHAT'S HAPPENING THAT
INCLUDED VENTURA. AND MY
GROUNDS IN ORANGE COUNTY. SO
AGAIN I WILL TELL YOU WE DON'T
HAVE DATA ANALYST OF BECAUSE
IT'S TOUGH TO FIND DATA. YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT SOMETHING THAT'S
ILLEGAL THAT PEOPLE ARE NOT
GOING TO REPORT GREAT SO THE
REASON I WAS ASKING IS BECAUSE
THAT THERE'S INDUSTRIES THAT
HAVE WHAT THEY CALL SHOPPERS
WHO GO UNDERCOVER TO SEE
WHETHER OR NOT PEOPLE ARE
FALLING RULES ARE BEING. AT
SERVE LIKE THE M. SELLING.
CIGARETTES TO MINORS OR ALCOHOL
TO MINORS SO THERE'S UNDER
COVER. SO I'M JUST KIND OF
CURIOUS IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING
AND- IT COULD BE CORRECTED ON
THIS BUT IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING
THAT THEY DO THE SAME THING AT
GUN SHOWS AND I'M NOT SURE
THAT. ANYONE WITH THE WITH THE
NOTION OF HAVING A BUSINESS AND
BE ABLE TO PROVIDE FOR THE ONE
SOUTH. WOULD PURPOSELY BREAK
THE LAW- IN THAT ENDEAVOR- JUST
SO HAT THEY CAN LOSE THEIR
LIVES. I'M THINKING AS A REAL
ESTATE LICENSE- THAT. REALTOR
BEFORE I WOULDN'T. DO SOMETHING
ILLEGAL. AND RISK YOU KNOW THE
ABILITY TO PROVIDE FOR ME. FOR
MYSELF FOR MY FAMILY. AND SO
I'M JUST THINKING OF. GUN
OWNERS AND- PEOPLE WHO WHO SELL
GUNS. I'M JUST TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT IF THEY WOULD PURPOSELY.
SELLS GUNS NOT FOLLOWING THE
PROTOCOL THAT THEY'RE SUPPOSED
TO BE FALL I WILL CONFESS TO
I'VE NEVER BEEN INVOLVED IN THE
ILLEGAL OR ATTEMPTED AND- TALE
TOLD IS THAT THERE'S TWO TYPES
OF TRANSACTIONS THAT ARE
PROBLEMATIC AND KEEP IN MIND
WE'RE IN THE ERA OF ANIMAL PAY
PAL. YOU KNOW A WHOLE BUNCH OF
WAYS YOU KNOW BIG COIN
CRYPTOCURRENCY I DON'T WANT TO
WASTE TO TRANSFER MONEY- AND
CREATE TRANSACTIONS- YOU KNOW
THAT THAT GO UNDETECTED- BUT MY
UNDERSTANDING IS YOU HAVE SOME
OF THE UNSCRUPULOUS DEALERS AND
I DON'T KNOW THEIR MOTIVATIONS
IF THERE MAYBE. I DON'T KNOW
HOW ROBUST THE UNDERCOVER
POLICE PRESENCES MAYBE THERE'S
NOT THAT WORRIED ABOUT BEING
CAUGHT. AND THEN THERE'S ALSO
JUST PEOPLE WHO GO TO THESE
THINGS YOU KNOW IN IN YOU KNOW
JUST GO OUT IN THE OFFICE
PEOPLE TALKING ENGAGING WITH
EACH OTHER- AND HAVING THAT
TYPE OF SECONDARY TRANSACTION.
IT'S NOT NECESSARILY THE
LICENSED DEALERS THAT THAT'S
KIND OF MY UNDERSTANDING OF THE
TYPES OF TRANSACTIONS THAT
OCCUR. BUT I WOULD EMPHASIZE AS
I SAID EARLIER IN MY OPENING
EVEN IF WE HAD ZERO ILLEGAL
TRANSACTIONS SO WE COULD GET IT
TO THAT POINT. I STILL THINK
THERE'S A GENERAL PRINCIPLE
HERE. WE HAVE AND MY
UNDERSTANDING SOMETHING LIKE A
HUNDRED TWENTY GUNS PER HUNDRED
PEOPLE ADULTS IN THIS COUNTRY-
THAT TO ME IS YOU KNOW IT'S
EXPONENTIALLY HIGHER THAN ANY
OTHER COUNTRY I THINK THE NEXT
CLOSEST IS LIKE THIRTY GUNS PER
HUNDRED PEOPLE. OUT WE HAVE AN
EPIDEMIC OF GUNS AND NOT
WITHSTANDING THE FAKE STUDIES
OUT THERE WHAT'S VERY CLEAR IS
MORE GUNS AS YOU WOULD EXPECT
LEAD TO MORE GUN VIOLENCE MORE
GUN HOMICIDES MORE GUN
INJURIES. MORE SUICIDES MORE
CRIME TO. ANSWER AS MUCH AS WE
ALL LIKE TO THINK I HAVE A GUN
I'M GONNA BE ABLE STOP THE
CRIMINAL. YOU KNOW I HAD
SOMEONE TELL ME THE OTHER DAY
THAT DOMESTIC VIOLENCE VICTIM
SHOULD GET GUNS TO PROTECT
THEMSELVES AND IT'S SOMEONE
WHOSE WIFE WORKS IN A CERVANTES
THINKING THAT'S INSANE. YOU
KNOW BECAUSE THE FIRST THING
YOU SAID WOULD DO IS TAKE YOUR
GUN FROM YOU AND USE IT AGAINST
YOU- AND GUNS IN A DOMESTICALLY
ABUSIVE HOUSEHOLD ARE A TOTALLY
CORRELATED THING WITH WITH THE
LIKELIHOOD OF GUN. DEATHS AND
SO I THINK THERE'S A PRINCIPLE
HERE THAT. I RESPECTFULLY
TAXPAYERS YEAH I'M NOT NEED
LIKE UTILIZING TAXPAYER ON THEN
YOU SHOULD NOT FINALIZED ALL.
PROMULGATE THE. THE
DISTRIBUTION MORE GUNS IN OUR
AND- HE- THAT'S CORRECT ALL
THANK YOU GET A THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- WHY. ALL OKAY WELL THANK
YOU VERYMUCH FOR YOUR CONCERN
AND I JUST WANT IS JUST STATE
pHAS A VERY DEEP RESPECT FOR
GUNS I UNDERSTAND- YOU KNOW
THEIR POTENTIAL AND SO FORTH
AND I DO ALSO WANT TO STATE.
EVER HEALTH AND MENTAL HEALTH
IN- EXASPERATING THE ISSUES
THAT WE HAVE WITH GUN VIOLENCE
SO I DO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THAT
THAT RESPECT BUT I ALSO WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT ONCE AGAIN-
FOR MANY PEOPLE IT IS A
CULTURAL AND FAMILY AFFAIR-
WHERE THERE IS WHERE I THINK
WHERE THERE'S A HEALTHY MINDSET
AROUND IT AND- AND WE HAVE TO
BE SENSITIVE AND RESPECTFUL TO
THAT AS WELL- YOU KNOW I'M NOT
OK WITH USING GUNS IN A IN AND
IN A HARMFUL WAY TOWARDS ANY
HUMAN BEING I JUST ABSOLUTELY
I'M APPALLED BY BYE SUCH A
FACTOR BUT I DO RECOGNIZE THAT
FOR SOME PEOPLE. IT IS A
TRADITION- AND WITH NO- ILL
INTENT TO OTHER HUMAN BEINGS
BUT MORE OF A JUST A JUST
STATE- CULTURAL ENDEAVOR IN FOR
SOME- IT'S ALSO MODE OR A WAY
OF PROVIDING FOR THEMSELVES-
AND WITH AND WITH THAT I JUST
WANNA FINALIZED MY. LAST POINT
IS THAT. I REALLY WANTED CREDIT
TO THE- AGRICULTURE DISTRICTS
IN THE FAIR BOARD SAID- TO.
HAVE THE A TOP TO DECIDE. WHAT
IS REFLECTIVE OF THEIR
COMMUNITY AND WHAT WORKS BEST
FOR THEIR COMMUNITY. AND THAT
THOSE BOARDS ARE APPOINTED BY
THE GOVERNOR. JUST WANT TO
STATE THOSE BUT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR FOR PRESENTING
THIS BILL IMPROVE AND BRING IT
FOR. RECEIVE YOUR PERSPECTIVE
CENTER. THANK YOU ANY
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS QUESTIONS
COMMITTEE MEMBER. NINETEEN
NINE. SERMON ALLOWED TO CLOSE.
YES YOU THE TERM- SO I WANTED
TO- CLOSE BY FIVE AGAIN MAKING
SURE WE'RE NOT LOSING SO THE
BIGGER PICTURE- THE EVIDENCE IS
OVER THAT GUY IN OUR COMMUNITY
CREATES ONE VIOLENCE AND I
THINK IT WAS BROUGHT EARLIER BY
THE REPRESENTED FROM R. P. THE
THIS BILL WOULD LEAD TO MORE
LAW I SUBMIT TO YOU ALL RESPECT
FOR. THAT IF WE KEEP WITH THE
STATUS THERE WERE BE COSTLY
LAWSUITS BECAUSE AT SOME POINT
THERE WILL BE A CLEAR LINKAGE
BETWEEN GUNS SOLD AT GUN SHOWS
AND THE NEXT GUN MASSACRE AND
WHILE WE WERE ALL SPEAKING
THERE IS YET ANOTHER GUN
MASSACRE IN THE SUBURBS OF
ATLANTA WHERE SEVERAL PEOPLE AT
LEAST HAVE DIED SO FAR IN THIS
SERIES OF SPAS AND SALONS. ARE
IN AS WE OPEN UP MORE WE'RE
GONNA START HEARING MORE ABOUT
ACTS OF MASSIVE GUN VIOLENCE
NOT JUST THE HOME SHOOTINGS OR
HOMICIDES AND SUICIDES THAT YOU
KNOW KIND OF WENT UNDER THE
RADAR LAST YEAR BUT WE'LL START
SEEING A LOT OF MASS SHOOTINGS
AGAIN THIS MAY BE UNFORTUNATELY
THE HARBINGER OF MANY MORE- WE
IN THIS STATE HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO TAKE AN ACTION
THAT I THINK IS APPROPRIATE.
IT'S SYMBOLIC BUT IT IS NOT
OVER REACH ON BEHALF OF THE
STATE IT SIMPLY STATES THAT WE
THE STATE DO NOT WANT TO GIVE
OUR ENDORSEMENT AND IMPRIMATUR
TO OUR TAXPAYER OWNED VENUES
BEING USED TO SELL MORE GUNS IN
OUR COMMUNITIES TO ME THIS IS A
STATEMENT OF STANDING UP TO GUN
VIOLENCE AND TRYING TO DO WITH
THE PUBLIC HEALTH PROFESSIONALS
ARE TELLING US WE NEED TO DO
WHICH IS REDUCE THE AMOUNT OF
GUNS THAT ARE IN OUR SOCIETY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH COMMITTEE
MEMBERS AND CHAIRMAN I
RESPECTFULLY. ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. Q. WHO. WE HAVE A BUY
RECOMMENDATION A TO PASS TO THE
COMMITTEE ON RURAL. WE'RE SICK
A MOST ON B. SIX FOUR. MORE
OVER. SPIN MOVE BY SO. SCANNER
MISS MISS WILL YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL ON S. B. TWO C. FOUR
PASS TO COMMITTEE ON RULES SB
TWO SIX FOUR DEEP. COMMITTEE ON
RULE BRADFORD OUR BRADFORD AYE
CHIU ABOVE NO. TROUBLE NO
LONGER. AMARGA SKINNER. SKINNER
AYE WIENER RIGHT WIENER I'VE.
ONE IN ORDER OUT FOR THE THANK
YOU FOR YOUR- LAST BUT NOT
LEAST WE HAVE SO. WIENER WITH
THOSE B. TWO SEVEN ONE MISTER
CHAIRMAN IF I MAY UM WE OUR
CENTER GROVE'S. THANK. TWENTY
PEDICEL SHOWER CAP ON. RIGHT
HOW YOU DO IT K. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR M. SO I UNDERSTAND
THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS ARE
CONCERNED THAT THE BILL MAY
HAVE UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES SB
THIRTY NINE IS THE BILL WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT- THAT INMATES
HAVE ALREADY BEEN RELEASED FROM
PRISON MAYBE FLAT FOR
FRAUDULENT CLAIMS EVEN THOUGH
THEY ARE NO LONGER SERVING A
PRISON TERM. THE LANGUAGE IN SB
THIRTY NINE SPECIFICALLY STATES
AND I QUOTE THAT THE DEPARTMENT
OF CORRECTIONS AND
REHABILITATION SHALL PROVIDE
THE NAMES AND SOCIAL SECURITY
NUMBERS CONSISTENT WITH FEDERAL
LAW OF CURRENT INMATES. SO IT'S
THEIR THIRD LANGUAGE SAYS THAT
IN THE BILL THAT THEY WON'T
PROVIDE ANY LANGUAGE OUTSIDE
ARE THEY WON'T PROVIDE ANY SAW
SECURITY NUMBERS OF PEOPLE HAVE
BEEN RELEASED- I AGREES THAT WE
NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT
EVERYBODY. M. WHO. WHO IS. IN
THE PRISON SYSTEM I DON'T WANT
TO HURT ANYBODY LIKE IF THEY'VE
WORKED IN. THEIR THERE AND
THEY'RE ENTITLED TO BENEFITS
FOR THE PREVIOUS TIME THAT THEY
WORK AND WE DON'T WANT TO
WRAPPED UP IN THIS IF. THEY GET
OUT DESERVE SERVE THEIR TERM
AND THEY GET A JOB WE DON'T
WANT THEM WRAPPED UP IN THIS
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO IS
PREVENT. AND I DO HAVE AN
UPDATED NUMBER FOR YOU ALMOST
TWO BILLION DOLLARS WORTH OF
FRAUD THAT HAS BEEN PAID INTO.
THE PRISON SYSTEM AND I DID
TALK TO DA'S TO FOLLOW UP WITH
ANOTHER QUESTION THAT YOU HAD
EARLIER TODAY. THEY ARE- SOME
OF THEM ARE USING PEOPLE'S
NAMES LIKE DIANNE FEINSTEIN.
BUT A LOT OF THE DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS THROUGHOUT THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA ARE PROSECUTING
INMATES BECAUSE THAT MONEY FROM
THE EDT IS GOING TO THEIR
BOOKS. IN THERE- WHATEVER
FINISHED FIRST RIVER PRESENTER.
PLACE THAT THEY'RE SERVING OUT
SO I DID CONFIRM THAT AS WELL
AND. I HAVE LANGUAGE ON. OR
WHAT IS REQUESTED SO THIS BILL
SAYS IN THE EXACT LANGUAGE
NOTWITHSTANDING ANY LAW. OR
DEPARTMENT OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS AND REHABILITATION
SHALL PROVIDE THE NAMES ANSEL
SECURITY NUMBERS. CONSISTENT
WITH FEDERAL LAW OF CURRENT
INMATES THE EMPLOYMENT
DEVELOPMENT DEPARTMENT FOR THE
PART TO THE DEPLOYMENT
PURPOSES SET FORTH IN SECTION
THREE TWENTY ONE POINT FIVE AND
EMPLOYMENT INSURANCE COAT. THE
DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE IN
CORRECTIONS AND REHABILITATION
CHAU PROVIDE THE INFORMATION TO
THE EMPLOYMENT DEVELOPMENT
PERMIT PURSUANT TO THIS
PARAGRAPH UPON THE REQUEST OF
THE EMPLOYMENT DURING THE
DEVELOPMENT DEPARTMENT. ONLY
FOR CURRENT INMATES. THE
LANGUAGE- ON AN AMENDMENT THAT
I'M ASKING TO TAKE IN ALL WORK
WITH ANYBODY ON IN A MINUTE SO
THAT WE CAN NARROW THIS DOWN I
DON'T I ON'T HAVE AN ISSUE. I
DON'T KNOW WHAT THAT AMENDMENT
LOOKS LIKE THE CLOSEST OF
LANGUAGE THAT I HAVE IS THAT.
AND I UNDERSTAND THAT THERE'S
CONCERNS AND- THE WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE DATA FROM
CDC ARE AN EDT USES LIKE
UTILIZES CURRENT. CURRENT AND
IS CURRENT AND REPRESENTS
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE CURRENTLY
INCARCERATED. SO AND- DOES THAT
HELP OR NOT THE ORIGINAL YES
MA'AM SENATE- ED CENTER GROVE
GREATLY APPRECIATE YOUR COMING
BACK AND GREATLY APPRECIATE
THAT THE BILL ALREADY SAYS THAT
CDCR MUST. REVISED CURRENT DATA
HOWEVER WE KNOW THE PART OF
THIS PROBLEM IS BECAUSE
UNFORTUNATELY MANY OF OUR STATE
AGENCIES HAVE VERY ARCHAIC
SYSTEMS. AND YOU KNOW THEY'RE
NOT UP TO DATE IT EVEN EDT
ITSELF HAS CLEARLY ITS OWN
ARCHAIC SYSTEMS HAS LED TO MUCH
OF THIS SO. THE BILL NOW STATES
THAT CDC ARE MOST SUPPLY
CURRENT BUT NOT THAT E. D. D.
MUST ONLY USE CURRENT SO IN
OTHER WORDS LET'S FACE CDCR
SUPPLIES THE LIST. THERE TO
YEAR TO LATER BEFORE RUNS. THAT
LIST AGAINST IT'S YOU KNOW IT
IT'S A- APPLICANTS FOR SO IT'S
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO ACHIEVE IS
pCDC ARE ONLY SUPPLY CURRENT
LIST BUT THAT D. D. D. ONLY
USES A CURRENT LIST SO IT'S
KIND OF THAT. SO WORK WITH YOU
AND YOU YEAH MAN MAN IF WE CAN
GET THAT AMENDMENT IN LABOR
THAT WOULD BE GREAT THEN IT
WOULD MAKE ME FEEL COMFORTABLE
THAT WE ARE THEN ADDING ON AND
I KNOW IT'S NOT YOUR INTENTION
TO MAKE ANYONE WHO. IS INNOCENT
HAVE TO FIGHT A FRAUD CHARGE
BECAUSE THAT IS TERRIBLE AND A
CERTAINLY IF YOU ALREADY HAD
IDENTITY THEFT WHICH WE KNOW.
SOME OF THESE INDIVIDUALS HAVE
JUST LIKE WE KNOW THAT DIANNE
FEINSTEIN'S NAME THERE WERE
NICK NAMES OF PEOPLE WHO ARE
INCARCERATED. SO THEY WERE
EXPERIENCED IDENTITY THEFT SO
WHAT THEY'RE TRYING TO DEAL
WITH IDENTITY THEFT WE DON'T
ALSO THEM TO BE CHARGED WITH
FRAUD. DO I NIGHT I COMPLETELY
UNDERSTAND THAT SO I'LL I'LL
WORK WITH YOU I MISS SKINNER.
AND MR PERRIN OR SENATOR
SKINNER- WE ARE ON- WHATEVER
AND THEN WE WORK OUT TO COME
FORWARD TO MAKE SURE THAT
DOESN'T HAPPEN IT'S NOT MY
INTENT. TO NOT ALLOW PEOPLE WHO
ARE ENTITLED TO BENEFITS TO
HAVE BENEFITS MY INTENT IS TO.
STOP THE FRAUDULENT BENEFITS
BEING PAID OUT THAT'S THE
INTENT. OF THE BILL AND- SO I
WOULD APPRECIATE YOUR AYE THAT.
THIRD WINNER THANK YOU A FOR
YOUR FOR HER COMING BACK
SENATE- YEAH I THINK- WHAT
WE'VE LEARNED OVER THE LAST
YEAR AND I PAINS ME TO SAY THIS
BECAUSE THERE ARE A LOT OF GOOD
PEOPLE WORKING IN TV BUT THE
SYSTEM ITSELF IS NOT ABOUT THE
INDIVIDUALS IT'S A SYSTEM. THIS
IS PROGRAM PERHAPS BEYOND
REPAIR- AND WE WE'VE LEARNED IN
THE LAST YEAR IS THAT IF YOU DO
HAS AN OPPORTUNITY TO GET
SOMETHING WRONG UNFORTUNATELY
IT'S LIKELY THAT THEY WILL AND
IT AGAIN SOMEONE HAS BEEN IN
GOVERNMENT FOR A LONG TIME
REALLY PAINS ME TO SAY THAT BUT
WE'VE ALL SEEN IT IN OUR
DISTRICTS THE DISASTER- AND SO.
I DON'T HAVE A LOT OF
CONFIDENCE IN E. D. IN THE DATA
TRANSFER OR WILL GET A RIGHT
AND THERE'LL BE PEOPLE WHO GOT
FROZEN ON SUSPICION MASS AND SO
I GUESS WHAT I WOULD JUST ASK
IS THIS COSTA LABOR NEXT TO BE
GOOD- AND- I DON'T THINK WE
HAVE THE VERSION GOALS WE WANT
TO HAVE GUARD RAILS. IN THE
BILL TO REALLY ENSURE THAT DDT
IS NOT JUST TAKING DATA AND
SLOPPING IT AND THAT THERE ARE
ACTUALLY YOU KNOW MAKING SURE
THAT IT'S ACCURATE- SO IF YOU
COULD JUST CAN MESS THAT IN
LABOR- YOU'LL TAKE A MOMENT OR
WILL WORK WITH YOU ON A WORK
WITH A COMMITTEE ON. TIME TO
GET TO OUR SHARED GOAL THAT I'D
BE HAPPY TO GO UP IN THE BILL
BASED ON THAT REPRESENTATION NO
ABSOLUTELY I JUST I DID MAKE
THAT COMMITMENT THAT I WOULD
WORK WITH YOU BECAUSE WE HAVE
THE SAME GOAL IN MIND IT'S NOT
MY INTENT. TO HURT ANYBODY WHO
IS QUALIFIED AND ELIGIBLE FOR
BENEFITS WHETHER THEY'RE IN
CARS THEY HAVE BEEN
INCARCERATED OR NOT IT'S-
MICHAEL TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
PEOPLE WHO ARE ENTITLED TO
BENEFITS GET BENEFITS BUT THOSE
THAT ARE NOT ENTITLED TO
BENEFITS DON'T GET BENEFITS- SO
ABSOLUTELY I'LL WORK WITH YOU
ON AN AMENDMENT TO TAKE IN A
MINUTE AND LABOR ONCE WE WORK
OUT WHAT THAT IS- BUT WE HAVE
THE SAME GAL. AND. AT THE
OTHER THING IS THAT. HE HE- SO
THERE DOING THAT. LIKE THIRD.
THE THERE SHERRY THAT DATA NOW-
BUT I WANNA MAKE IT INSTEAD.
SHE TOOK. AND SO I DO FIND OUT
TILL AFTER THE- THAT- EARLIER
SEPARATE JUST FY I. IT WOULD BE
GOOD IF WE GOT THIS INTO LINE.
IT'S A GOOD AGAIN AND- WE CAN
HOLD EIGHTY ACCOUNTABLE THEY
DID YOU SEE AN CORRECTOR NOT
NOT GOOD DATA. THE SCRIPT. FROM
YES SO- I KNOW THE ROLE BE OVER
THE BASED REPRESENTS. ALL THE
VOTING ON THE BILL. THANK YOU
SIR I WISH TO FEW LATER- WE WAS
RICH THE RIGHT TO BRING BILL
BACK COMMITTEE IN FACT IT
DOESN'T ADDRESS THE CONCERNS
THAT. WE'VE ASKED FOR AND LABOR
COMMITTEE AND A MEMBER. IS THAT
FAIR WITH EVERYBODY. ALL RIGHT-
SOME CLERK MEAN CONSULTANT
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLE ON S. B.
THIRTY NINE THIRTY NINE SKINNER.
ALL RIGHT SKINNER AYE WIENER
AYE WIENER AYE VOTES FOR ZERO.
FOUR ZERO THAT MEASURES OUT
HERE SHOULD WE LEAVE IT ON CALL
FOR. NO LATER NO WISH. IT'S NOT
CAMARGO WAS NOT VOTING SMOKING
GUN OKAY THANK YOU THE MEASURES
OUT NOW SENATOR WIENER WE'RE
READY FOR THE FINAL ITEM S. B.
TWO SEVEN ONE. THIRTY ONE WITH
THE CALL ON CONSENT WHILE HE'S
WALKING AND WILL LOOK TO CALL
ON THE CONCERT CALENDAR.
SKINNER OUR SKINNER AYE IN THE
CONSENT CALENDAR SOUTH FIVE
ZERO SIX CALENDARS OUT FIVE
ZERO THANK YOU. SAVE THE BEST
FOR LAST. OKAY THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN THE ON DRUG. PARKWAY
TODAY- SURVIVE MISTER CHAIRMAN
AND COLLEAGUES SOUGHT- SENATE
BILL TWO SEVENTY WINE IS A
IMPORTANT CRIMINAL JUSTICE AND
POLICE REFORM BILL- THE
PROMOTES DIVERSITY IN THE MOCK
CHRISSY AND SHERIFF ELECTIONS
THAT'S TWO TO SEVENTY ONE WILL
GIVE VOTERS AN ACTUAL CHOICE
COOPER WHO SHOULD REINER WHO
CAN RUN WHAT IS FREQUENTLY A
LARGE GOVERNMENT AGENCY
ENGAGING NOT SYSTEM POLICING
BUT ALSO MENTAL AND PHYSICAL
HEALTH CARE DEATH
INVESTIGATIONS ANOTHER WAS
CORNER- AND OTHER
ADMINISTRATIVE FUNCTIONS IN
ADDITION TO OVERSEEING A LARGE
GOVERNMENT BUDGET. THE SERVICE
FREQUENTLY THE MOST POWERFUL
ELECTED POSITION IN A COUNTY
WHICH HUGE AND VARIED
RESPONSIBILITIES IT ONLY ONE
PARTICULAR LIMITED DEMOGRAPHIC
LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS WHO'VE
WORKED AS AN OFFICER AT SOME
POINT IN THE LAST FIVE YEARS
ARE ELIGIBLE TO RUN LET'S
REMEMBER THE SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENTS AREN'T JUST ABOUT
POLICING FOR EXAMPLE THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY JAIL IS THE
LARGEST MENTAL HEALTH PROVIDER
IN THE ENTIRE UNITED STATES OF
AMERICA. AND YET ONLY LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS ARE
ELIGIBLE TO LEAD THAT
DEPARTMENT AND THAT MASSIVE
MENTAL HEALTH SYSTEM NOT
SURPRISINGLY GIVEN THE
STRANGULATION OF REAL
COMPETITION CALIFORNIA SHERIFFS
ARE OVERWHELMINGLY WHITE MEN
FORTY NINE OUT OF FIFTY EIGHT
WITH ONLY FOUR WOMEN AND ZERO
BLOCK PEOPLE SERVING A
SHERIFF'S IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA NOT SURPRISINGLY
SHARP ELECTIONS ARE VERY OFTEN
UNCONTESTED BECAUSE THERE'S
ONLY ONE SLIVER OF. A
DEMOGRAPHIC THAT'S ELIGIBLE TO
RUN. THE DOESN'T HAVE TO BE
THIS. AND INDEED FOR LARGEMENT
OF CALIFORNIA HISTORY IT WASN'T
THIS WAY FROM EIGHTEEN FIFTY
THE FOUNDING OF OUR STATE UNTIL
NINETEEN EIGHTY NINE HUNDRED
AND THIRTY NINE YEARS. ANYONE
COULD RUN FOR SHERIFF AND THE
SKY DID NOT FALL. IN TWENTY
FOUR STATES ALMOST HALF F THE
STIFFNESS COUNTRY ANYONE IS A
REGISTERED VOTER CAN RUN FOR
SHERIFF. ONLY FIFTEEN STATES
INCLUDING CALIFORNIA REQUIRES
THAT THE SHERIFF BE A LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICER BECAUSE
MOST STATES NOW FOR THE SERVICE
ISN'T JUST ABOUT POLICING. SO
WHY DID CALIFORNIA AFTER A
HUNDRED AND THIRTY NINE YEARS
CHANGE IT'S SHERIFF ELIGIBILITY
REQUIREMENTS TO SAY THAT
INSTEAD OF ANYONE BEING ABLE TO
RUN ONLY LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICES CAN RUN. THAT'S BECAUSE
IN NINETEEN SEVENTY NINE MY
COUNTY SAN FRANCISCO ELECTED A
PRISONER RIGHTS ATTORNEY BY THE
NAME OF MICHAEL HENNESSY TO BE
SURE- AND JUST TO BE BLUNT THE
SHERIFF'S FREAKED OUT. FREAKED
OUT THAT SOMEONE WAS IMPINGING
ON THEIR TURF. EARLIER
PROGRESSIVE REFORMER SO THEY
CAME TO THIS BUILDING AND THEY
GOT A LAW PASSED TO CORNER THE
MARKET AND CREATE A MONOPOLY SO
THE ONLY BETTER PEOPLE COULD
RUN AND SO THERE WILL BE NO
MORE MICHAEL HENNESSY'S IT'S
NOT PARTICULARLY DEMOCRATS
CREDIT. FOR THE RECORD MICHAEL
HENNESSY SERVED AS SHERIFF OF
SAN FRANCISCO FOR THIRTY TWO
YEARS REAL IT WAS ELECTED EIGHT
TIMES HE WAS UNIVERSALLY
RESPECTED IN OUR CITY EVEN BY
THE PEOPLE WHO WERE SKEPTICAL
OF HIM AT THE BEGINNING HE
INSTITUTED TRENDSETTING
EDUCATIONAL. PROGRAMS HE
ESTABLISH A CHARTER HIGH SCHOOL
IN SAN FRANCISCO COUNTY JAIL
THE FIRST IN THE COUNTRY A
GROUNDBREAKING MENTAL HEALTH
AND REHABILITATION PROGRAMS THE
SKY DIDN'T FALL WHEN SHERIFF
MIKE HENNESY BECAME SHERIFF IN
SEARCH FOR THIRTY TWO YEARS.
BUT IT DID TRIGGER A
REACTIONARY BACKLASH THE
OPPOSITION SITES CERTAIN
POSITIONS THAT HAVE PARTICULAR
QUALIFICATIONS AND USES THOSE
pAS EVIDENCE THAT THEY BALK YOUR
QUALIFICATIONS FOR SOME OFFICES
MAYBE SHOULD HAVE
QUALIFICATIONS FOR OFFICES BUT
REMEMBER THAT THE CHIEF LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICER OF
CALIFORNIA. ATTORNEY GENERAL
DOES NOT. HAVE TO BE A LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICER. THE
DIRECTOR OF FBI. DOES NOT HAVE
TO BE A LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICER
THE SECRETARY OF CDCR DOESN'T
HAVE TO HAVE BEEN A PRISON
GUARD. THE SECRETARY OF DEFENSE
NEVER HAD TO SERVE IN THE
MILITARY AND ALL THESE
POSITIONS WE HIRE THE PERSON
THAT WE BELIEVE. AS MOST
COMPETENT TO RUN THE AGENCY AND
NOT QUITE TWENTY FOUR STATES DO
IT THE WAY THAT SB TWO SEVENTY
ONE PROPOSES. NINE IT IS A
STRONG ARGUMENT THAT IF WE
BELIEVE IN CIVILIAN OVERSIGHT.
AND MAKES SENSE TO ALLOW A WIDE
VARIETY OF PEOPLE TO RUN.
RESTORING BROADER ELIGIBILITY
REQUIREMENTS TO SHERIFF WILL
ALLOW BROADER POOL OF
CANDIDATES TO RUN. WITH MORE
DIVERSE SKILL SETS. AND MORE-
JUST DIVERSITY TO PRESENT TO
THE COMMUNITY- SO WE KNOW THAT
WE HAVE DYSFUNCTION SOME OF OUR
SERVICE DEPARTMENTS WE HAVE
SHERIFFS TO. VIOLATE STATE LAW
BY COOPERATING WITH ICE WE HAVE
SHERIFFS WHO REFUSED TO ENFORCE
COBIT HELP ORDERS WE HAVE
SHERIFFS. THIS IN ALL SERVICE
WE HAVE SHERIFFS WHO RUNNING.
JAILS ARE VERY PROBLEMATIC WITH
A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE DYING. FROM
THE SHERIFFS ARE OFTEN RUNNING
FOR REELECTION UNOPPOSED
BECAUSE ONLY LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS CAN RUN AGAINST THEM.
WE KNOW THAT WE'RE IN A RACIAL
RECKONING IN THIS COUNTRY I'M
POLICING HAS TO CHANGE AND THIS
IS A COMMONSENSE REFORM. TO
BROADEN THE POOL OF PEOPLE
ELIGIBLE TO BE SHERIFF. AND TO
BRING OUR SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT
INTO THE MODERN WORLD. BUT OF
COURSE NOTHING PROHIBITS A LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICER IN THIS
BILL FROM RUNNING FOR SHERIFF.
SO WITH ME TODAY TESTIFIED OUR
ORAL THOMAS WHO THE GOVERNMENT
AFFAIRS DIRECTOR I CALIFORNIA
IMMIGRANT POLICY CENTER. AND
CHRISTIAN CONTRAIRE US TO THE
LOS ANGELES BASED CIVIL RIGHTS
ATTORNEY AT JUSTICE ACTS AND WE
SAW HENDERSON AND CARRASCO LD I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FROM RIVALS.
THANK YOU FIRST WITNESS ON THE
TWO PRIMARY WITNESSES WILL
PROVIDE YOU TWO MINUTES EACH
FOR YOUR TESTIMONY. AND
DEPENDING ON WHO'S GOING FIRST
WE'RE READY FOR YOUR TESTIMONY
IT'S DISHONEST OKAY OR BILL
THOMAS IF YOU'RE READY THANK
YOU. THANK YOU CHAIRMAN BRAD
BIRD AND THANK YOU FOR SAYING
OUR BILL WITH THE BEST BILL AT
THE LAST BILL I APPRECIATE YOU.
MY NAME IS CORPORAL THOMAS AND
I'M THE DIRECTOR OF GOVERNMENT
AFFAIRS THE CALIFORNIA
IMMIGRANT POLICY CENTER CITY
IDC IS ONE OF SEVERAL CO
SPONSORS SB TWO SEVENTY ONE.
THIS YEAR TOMOGRAPHY AND
DIVERSE THE ACT SHARE FULL
THICKNESS TO GET POWER IN
CALIFORNIA AND THEIR POLICY
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTS LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES OF COLOR.
INCLUDING IMMIGRANT COMMUNITY.
SHARES CONTROL HOW COUNTY JAILS
ARE OPERATED AND INCLUDE
DECISION OVER WHO GOES TO JAIL
AND WAS RELEASED. WORK WITH THE
POLICE DEPARTMENT TO DECIDE HOW
NEIGHBORHOODS ARE BELIEVED AND
THE SHERIF'S DEPARTMENT
OVERSEES ADDICTION ENFORCEMENT
ORDERS FOR IMMIGRANT COMMUNITY
SHARES ARE ALSO THE GATEKEEPERS
DEPORTATION. AND MOST PEOPLE
WHO ARE TRANSFERRED TO ICE
CUSTODY COME FROM COUNTY JAILS.
THE CURRENT SYSTEM ISN'T
WORKING OPTIMALLY FOR
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR AND PLEASE
INDULGE ME AS I READ SOME
HEADLINES OF NOTE AS IT RELATES
TO SHARES IN VARIOUS CALIFORNIA
COUNTY. AND WILL BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE THE STAFF THAT PASSED.
FROM EAST BAY TIMES ALAMEDA
SHERIFF ACCUSED OF VIOLATING
STATE SANCTUARY LAW SHERIFF'S
DEPUTIES ALLOWED ICE AGENTS
IT'S A LOCKED AREA IN SANTA
RITA JAIL WHO RESTED IMMIGRANT.
WOMAN WHO COMMITTED NO CRIME.
ON THE L. A. TIMES. CALIFORNIA
ATTORNEY JAVIER BECERRA. I NOW
DO YOU WANT A CIVIL RIGHTS
INVEST. IN THE L. A. COUNTY SHE
TO. AN AGENT BE BY OUR- THAT IT
BEING THIS CALL. CONTROVERSIAL
SHOOTING AND RESISTANT TO
OVERSIGHT FROM SHAREBUILDER WEB
ALSO FROM THE L. A. TIMES KERN
COUNTY SHERIFF IS CAUGHT ON
TAPE SAYING IT COSTS LESS. TO
KILLED. TO WOUND THEM. FROM THE
SACRAMENTO BEE SACRAMENTO
COUNTY SHERIFF REFUSES TO
ENFORCE KOBE NINETEEN
RESTRICTION DESPITE RECEIVING A
MAJORITY OF THE CARE ACT MONEY
FROM THE COUNTY. NOT SHOCKING
THAT KAEPERNICK CAL THE WENT UP
AFTER RESTRICTIONS WERE NOT
ENFORCED. AND FINALLY PERCENT
OR SKINNER FROM THE EAST BAY
EXPRESS YOU MIGHT BE FAMILIAR
WITH THIS ONE SENATOR CALLS FOR
AUDIT OF ALAMEDA COUNTY
SHERIFF'S. OFFICE AFTER
TROUBLING REPORT. OPPONENTS
SHOULD WILL THAT THERE ARE
PLENTY OF OTHER LAW ENFORCEMENT
CANDIDATES THAT CAN RUN AGAIN
THE UNQUOTE BAD SHARE. BUT DE
SUGGESTED HAVE. TWO THOUSAND
AND TWO HALF SHARE HAVE RUN
UNOPPOSED DURING THE REELECT.
BILL ALSO DOES NOT STOP LAW
ENFORCEMENT FROM COULD TO RENT
OR SHARE. IN OUR CURRENT MOMENT
OF RECKONING WITH RACIAL
INJUSTICE AND INEQUITY. SB TWO
SEVENTY ONE EMPOWERS OUR
COMMUNITY MEMBERS PARTICULARLY
THOSE MOST IMPACTED BY SHARES
QUALITY. TO ORGANIZE AROUND
CANDIDATES. WILL ADDRESS THEIR
NEEDS BY ALLOWING THE
DIVERSIFICATION OF CANDIDATE
POOLS IF THE KEY WAS ALLOWED TO
RUN WE MIGHT SEE CANDIDATES PER
SHARE. THAT FOCUS ON MENTAL
HEALTH TREATMENT INSTEAD OF
CRIMINALIZATION. HOUSING
SOLUTIONS INSTEAD OF OBJECTION.
YOUR TIED THE COMMUNITY
INVESTMENT INSTEAD OF OVER
FORTY SIX. FOR ALL OF THESE
REASONS AND MORE I ASK FOR YOUR
I. BOATS THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. THANK YOU. OUR COUNTRY
CONCERTS PLEASE. GOOD AFTERNOON
CARE BRADFORD GOOD AFTERNOON
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
CHRISTIAN CONTENT OUT I AM A
CIVIL RIGHTS ATTORNEY WITH
GUITAR THINK ABOUT WHAT WE
CURRENTLY HAVE FORTY FIVE ACT
INCREDIBLE RIGHTS CASES AGAINST
DIFFERENT MUNICIPALITIES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND BOXERS BUT ALL
CALIFORNIANS I'M ALSO A CO
FOUNDER OF JUSTICE ACT SUCH AS
BACK TO THE COALITION OF BLACK
AND BROWN MOTORS ABANDONING
BLACK AND BROWN INTERESTS AND
THE INTERESTS. OF MARGOLYES
AMENITIES. WE PUBLIC SAFETY.
THE ONLY WAY WE'RE GOING TO RE
PUBLIC IS BY STARTING AT.
CHINESE LEAD. SHERIFF DEPUTIES
THE CALIFORNIA AND LEADERSHIP
OF OUR- THE MOST. PROBLEM WITH
BONTA AGENCIES AND POLICE
OFFICER IN THE MIDDLE CULTURE
THE TOXIC COAL WHICH- SHERIFF
DEPUTY GOING TO IT'S US VERSUS
THEM CULTURE IT'S A BLUE LIGHT
THE PERSON THAT CULTURE THAT
MUST CHANGE. THE PRIMARY ISSUE
WITH THE TOPICS. IS THAT ARE
LESS BY. WHO INTO INTO THEM
THEY- AND A BILL. AND INDEED
THE COMMUNITY IS BEING HIGH
MUCH THE STRIP PART. THE
COMMUNITY CONTACT THE INTEREST.
OF SO WE NEED. NUMBER AND WE
NEED MEMBERS OF CALIFORNIA WHO
COULD ACTUALLY LEAD A SERVICE
DEPARTMENT THAT COULD CHANGE
THAT. I CAN REIMAGINE HOW WE
THINK ABOUT PUBLIC THEY THINK
CALIFORNIA. NOW I KNOW THIS
FIRSTHAND AS A LATNO MAN IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AS A CIVIL
RIGHTS ATTORNEY I EXPERIENCED
FIRSTHAND THE CULTURE WHICH
TOOK THE POLE THE SHERIFF'S
DEPUTIES AGAINST. THE COMMUNITY
I REPRESENT THE FAMILY OF AT
ANY BARGAINS NATALIE BARGAIN
PUSH SHOT THIRTEEN TIMES. TEN
TIMES IN THE BACK TWO TIMES IN
THE BACK OF THE HEAD AND ONE
TIME THE ARMED BY TWO SHERIFF'S
DEPUTIES WERE DOCUMENTED
PROSPECT IF NOT MEMBERS. OF THE
DEPUTY GANG CALLED THE
BANDIDOS. NOW THE MERE
EXISTENCE OF A DEADLY GANG
SHOWS THAT THIS CULTURE IS
PERMEATING. THROUGHOUT THE
DEPARTMENT. NOT ONLY DID THE
THAT WE- SHOOT AND KILL AT THE
MARKET. WHEN WE HELD A
ANNIVERSARY YEAR AFTER IS THAT.
BAD WHICH STATION WERE
PRESENTED BY TWO FORTY
CHARACTER P. IN RYE. ONE PICK
YOUR AGAIN FAMILY THEY SHOWED
UP IN A FULL RIGHT HERE. READY
WHEN THEY OTHER A. R. FIFTEEN
GOOD K. FOURTEEN. ASSAULT AND
LYFT. ON THE ROOF TO COMBAT AN
ANGEL. THAT'S CLEAR EXAMPLE HOW
THE SIR DEPUTIES. COMBAT THE
COMMUNITY AND THE ONLY WE'RE
GOING TO CHANGE THE- IS TO TRUE
LEADERSHIP. AND SB SOME ONE IF
SOMETHING WOULD COULD BE A STEP
GOAL. THROUGH TWO REFORM. SO I
AM ON THE POINTS ASPIRIN ON SB
ONE. I AM OPEN TO ADDITIONAL
QUESTION OR ANY FROM THE CA
MEMBERS. AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. THANK YOU HOW ARE GONNA
NOW GO TO THE ROOM FORTY TWO-
OH THREE TWO IF THERE'S ANY%
WITNESSES HERE WHO WANT. TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. SHE NINE
WE'RE LET'S MOVE NO TO ROOM
TWENTY FOR. ANY JUSTICE IS AND
SUPPORT OF THE SPEECH SEVEN.
SEEN ON THEIR WE'RE GOING TO GO
BACK OUR MODEL. WILL RUNNING
TOP OF. MADAM BIRDCAGE CAN YOU
QUEUE UP ALL THOSE WITNESSES
WHO. ARE IN SUPPORT I'M GOING
TO HASH MY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
TO BE VERY TO SYNC STATE YOUR
NAME AND YOUR POSITION. SO WE
CAN GET AS MANY FOLKS AND
BEFORE THE CLOCK RUNS OUT TILL.
IF YOU READY MATAMATA READY-
QUEUE UP THOSE WITH THIS ISN'T
SUPPORT. THANK YOU IF YOU WISH
TO MAKE A COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF
S. B. TWO SEVEN ONE PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. I HAVE ABOUT TWENTY IN Q.
OR TO LINE FOR SIXTY ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOING WITH THE
CALIFORNIA NURSES ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
LINE FOR SIXTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MY GOD DOCTOR OFF ON BEHALF OF
THE ACLU OF CALIFORNIA AND
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU RYAN
SIXTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
SACRAMENTO FOR THE PROSECUTORS
ALLIANCE OF CALIFORNIANS FOR
JUSTICE CALIFORNIANS STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU OF MINE FOR
THIRTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE
BROWN WITH WIDENING GROUP ON
BEHALF OF NEXT IN CALIFORNIA
COULD SPONSOR TO THE BILL TRUMP
BEFORE. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT TO
SEVEN FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
BURGO GEORGE ON THE HALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION AND STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU I'M FOR
SIXTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MELISSA LACK I'M AT THE ARE YOU
THANK ONE IMPORT. THANK YOU I'M
FOR SIXTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO THIS IS JIM LINDBERG ON
BEHALF OF A FRIEND COMMITTEE ON
LEGISLATION TO CALIFORNIA IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU ALL RIGHT TO FORTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. CANNAGROW DARN
ON BEHALF OF THE SAN FRANCISCO
PUBLIC DEFENDER'S OFFICE IN
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU RYAN
THREE FIFTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THE BILL YELLOWSTONE PARK.
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT ONE TWENTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. ANYWAY
WHAT AT THE END CALIFORNIA
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU OF MY
NINETY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
RIGHT NINE THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. FIVE FIVE NINE NINE NINE
FONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT FOUR THIRTY NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO THIS ISSUE THE
STATE SAY ON BEHALF OF THE
WELCOME DEMOCRATIC RENEWAL CLUB.
SPONSORED THIS BILL THAT HAVE
BEEN WORKING FOR THIS BILL FOR
SEVERAL YEARS WE ARE AN
ENTHUSIASTIC SUPPORT. URGENTLY
NEEDED IN ALAMEDA COUNTY THANK
YOU. THANK YOU OF MINE FOR
SIXTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
JENNIFER ROBERTS WITH
INDIVISIBLE COLUSA COUNTY IN
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU FOR
SIXTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. AS
SOON AS WITH THE ANTI
RECIDIVISM COALITION IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
RYAN SIXTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. PROBABLY THOMAS WITH
SEIU LOCAL FIVE TWENTY ONE IN
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU YOUR
MIND THREE FORTY THREE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. NINE THREE FOUR THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. BLIND TO
NINETY PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
JENNIFER TO A RESIDENT OF
OAKLAND- IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU APPLYING FOR TWENTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE FOUR
TWO NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
FRANCESCO LONGER INDIVISIBLE
SAN FRANCISCO IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU OF MINE FOR FIFTEEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. BRIAN FOR AMBIENCE OF
SECURE JUSTICE A CO SPONSOR
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU AND
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF S. B. TWO
SEVEN ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
ZERO AT THIS TIME THERE WERE
TWENTY FOUR SIX NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU. NINE FOUR SIX
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
THIS IS ALLISON MONROE IN
OAKLAND I SUPPORT THIS BILL
BECAUSE PEOPLE SHOULD BE ABLE
TO SELECT THE SERVICES THEY
WANT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU WE
HAVE ONE MORE IN Q. IT'LL JUST
BE ONE MOMENT. LINE FOR SEVENTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. DEBORAH
PERKINS COLLAMER MEMBER OF
CALIFORNIA NURSES ASSOCIATION
AND DEMOCRATIC WELL BOTH FROM
DEMOCRATIC CLUB IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF S. B. TWO SEVENTY
ONE. THANK YOU I HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENTS THANK YOU AT
THIS TIME THANK YOU IN THE
INTEREST OF TIME WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE TO- THOSE WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION- WE HAVE TWO PRIMARY
WITNESSES WERE THEY'LL BE
GRANTED TWO MINUTES EACH WE
HAVE COREY SELLS LOL. AND WE
HAVE NICK- DEATH- ZERO FOUR
WITNESSES ARE. ALREADY I WILL
START WITH MISTER CELLS ALL.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
CORY CELLS L. ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION EXISTING LAW
REQUIRES A CANDIDATE FOR THE
OFFICE OF THE SHERIFF TO HAVE
EARNED AN ADVANCED CERTIFICATE
FROM THE COMMISSION ON PEACE
OFFICER STANDARDS AND TRAINING
OR DEMONSTRATE A COMBINATION OF
FULL TIME LAW ENFORCEMENT WORK
EXPERIENCE AND EDUCATION. THIS
BILL BELIEVES THAT REQUIREMENT
AND REPLACES IT WITH NOTHING IN
A TIME WHEN MORE ACCOUNTABILITY
AND PROFESSIONALISM ARE BEING
SOUGHT FROM LAW ENFORCEMENT
LEADERS MAKES NO SENSE TO RAISE
THE STANDARDS. FURTHER ALLOWING
ANY REGISTERED VOTER TO RUN
WILL ACTUALLY REDUCE
ACCOUNTABILITY BECAUSE
CANDIDATES WITHOUT LAW
ENFORCEMENT EXPERIENCE WILL NOT
HAVE GONE THROUGH A RIGOROUS
PEACE OFFICER BACKGROUND CHECK
QUITTING A PSYCHOLOGICAL EXAM.
IN COMPARISON AS THE AUTHOR
NOTED IT'S WORTH NOTING THAT
OTHER ELECTED COUNTY OFFICES
HAVE EXPERIENCE AND EDUCATION
REQUIREMENTS AND STATURE THIS
BILL DOES NOT ADDRESS THOSE.
THE COUNTY AUDITOR MUST HAVE
FIELD EXPERIENCE TO BE A
CERTIFICATE ACCOUNTANT THE
DISTRICT ATTORNEY MUST BE
ADMITTED TO PRACTICE. BEFORE
THE CALIFORNIA SUPREME COURT
AND INDEED THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S NOT REQUIRED TO BE A
PEACE OFFICER. BUT THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL IS REQUIRED TO BE AN
ATTORNEY. WE DISAGREE THAT THE
OFFICE THE SURE SHOULD BE
SINGLED OUT AND HAVE STANDARDS
FOR THE JOB LOWERED. RELATEDLY
THERE'S AN ONGOING DISCUSSION
ABOUT HAVING RANK AND FILE
PEACE OFFICERS HAVE MORE
EDUCATION BE ELIGIBLE SERVICE.
THIS BILL SEEMS TO MOVE IN THE
OPPOSITE DIRECTION. SHARES OF
MANY DIFFERENT RESPONSIBILITIES
INCLUDING OFTEN DIRECTING OR
SERVING AS CORNER PUBLIC
ADMINISTRATOR. USUALLY
COORDINATOR- AND SEVERAL OTHER
ROLES AN ELECTED SHERIFF
WITHOUT LAW ENFORCEMENT
EXPERIENCE WILL INCREASE THE
LIKELIHOOD OF THE DELIVERY OF
POOR DIRECTIVES AN INCREASE
COUNTY LIABILITY. MUTUAL AID
AVAILABILITY AND RESPONSE WILL
SUFFER IF THERE ARE AGENCIES
HOMES BY PERSONS WITHOUT LAW
ENFORCEMENT EXPERIENCE. PERHAPS
MORE SPECIFICALLY IN EVERY
COUNTY SHERIFF'S MAKE CRITICAL
DECISIONS THAT KIND OF LIFE AND
DEATH OUTCOMES THERE ARE MANY
SMALL COUNTIES WHERE THE
SHERIFF IS IN THE FIELD DOING
PATROL WORK OR WORKING IN THE
JAIL. CONTRARY TO THE
PROPONENTS ASSERTIONS THE
SHERIFF IS MORE THAN JUST A
MANAGER OF AN APARTMENT. IN
RECENT COURT CASES RELATED TO
THE STATUTE IN QUESTION. THE
SIX DISTRICT COURT OF APPEAL
SAID QUOTE THERE CAN BE NO
DOUBT THAT THE STATE HAS A
STRONG INTEREST IN ASSURING
THAT A PERSON WITH ASPIRATIONS
TO HOLD OFFICE IS QUALIFIED TO
ADMINISTER THE COMPLEXITY THAT
OFFICE. FOR THE CLARIFYING AND
ROLLS. THE COURT SAID THIS
SECTION DOES NOT SIGNIFICANTLY
IMPAIR ACCESS TO THE BALLOT
THERE ARE FIVE BROAD
QUALIFICATIONS. WHICH EMBRACE
PEOPLE OF VARYING EXPERIENCE
THIS SECTION DOES NOT STIFLE
SPEECH FOR DICTATE COLLECTOR
OUTCOMES IN ANY SENSE FOR THESE
REASONS WE RESPECTFULLY.
REQUEST YOUR NO VOTE. THANK YOU
MATATUS. THANK YOU CHAIR AND
NOT COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME'S
NICO NOW TO HAVE NEARLY
NINETEEN YEARS OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT EXPERIENCE WITH THE
TRI COUNTY SHERIFF'S OFFICE.
WHAT THE PRESIDENT AND- THEN
CHECK ANY DEPUTY SHERIFF'S
ASSOCIATION AND EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR FOR THE PEACE OFFICERS
RESEARCH RESEARCH ASSOCIATION
OF CALIFORNIA. I'M HERE TODAY
REPRESENTING THE PEACE OFFICERS
RESEARCH ASSOCIATION IN
CALIFORNIA. I CONCUR- WITH MR
CELL DEALS POINT ENOUGH- BILL
TWO SEVEN ONE. BUT TODAY I
WANTED TO PROVIDE YOUR
PERSPECTIVE- AND THE IMPACT OR
RANK AND FILE DEPUTIES. THERE
REALLY TWO PRIMARY ISSUES WITH
ABOUT TWO SEVENTY ONE AT THAT
APPLIES THE RANK AND FILE
DEPUTIES. FIRST IS THE SAFETY
THE SAFETY OF RANK AND FILE
OFFICERS. SHERIFF'S IS
DESIGNATED TO MAKE CRITICAL
DECISIONS THAT THAT RELATES TO
TACTICS AND RESPONSIVE. IN
SERIOUS INCIDENTS INVOLVING
DEPUTY RESPONSES. SHERIFF WITH
NO REAL PEACE OFFICER
EXPERIENCE CREEK INSTITUTION IN
WHICH DEPUTIES COULD BE NEEDED
NEEDLESSLY PUT IN HARM'S WAY.
IN A RANK AND FILE SYSTEM THE
SHERA MUST MAKE CRITICAL
DECISIONS THAT NOT ONLY ALLOWED
DEPUTIES THE ABILITY TO SAFELY
CARRY OUT THERE FIND OUT. BUT
IT CAN ALSO CREATE A SITUATION
IN WHICH- COMPROMISED THE
SAFETY OF THE PUBLIC. I CAN
ISSUES RELATED TO TRAINING
TRAINING RANK AND FILE
OFFICERS. SHERIFF'S DECADES
TRAINING AND BUDGET RELATING TO
TRAINING FOR THE DEPUTY WHICH-
UNDER FOR HIS WATCH THE
TRAINING OF POLICE OFFICERS IS
VITALLY IMPORTANT. AND I'M SURE
THAT WE CAN ALL AGREE WITH THAT
THERE IS ALSO A WIDE ARRAY OF
TRAINING FOR PEACE OFFICERS IN
THIS PROFESSION. HOWEVER WITH
SENATE BILL TWO SEVENTY ONE IT
CREATES ISSUES IN WHICH ELECTED
SHERA. MAY HAVE LESS TRAINING
AND EXPERIENCE THAN EVEN THE
NEWEST DEPUTIES WITH THE
SHERIFF'S OFFICE OUR
DEPARTMENT. IT ALSO CREATES IN
MICHIGAN WHICH THEY SHARE. WITH
NO REAL PEACE OUT THERE AT THE
TOP SEARCH EXPERIENCE HAS
NOTHING TO DRAW FROM WHEN
DETERMINING A TRAINING
PRIORITIES. AND TRAINING
BUDGETS. THIS FEASIBLY COULD
CREATE A WORKFORCE ADEPT LASTRA.
AND ALL- IMPORTANT CAN YOU
ISSUE. AND THEN FIND I'D LIKE
TO POINT OUT THAT THE SECOND
DISTRICT COURT OF APPEALS SPOKE
TO THIS ISSUE IN A TWENTY
NINETEEN RULING. LAWYER V.
VAREN VENT ABERCYNON VENTURA
COUNTY. IN THIS CASE MISTER
BOYER WHO HAD NO PRIOR PEACE
TALKS YOUR EXPERIENCE DESIRE TO
RUN. FOR SHERIFF IN VENTURA
COUNTY. IN THE CALL WILL MADE.
THAT THERE IS A GOOD WHY THE
LEGISLATURE HAS IMPOSED AN
EXPERIENCE REQUIREMENT FOR
SHARE OF. TO GET A FEEL FOR LAW
ENFORCEMENT TO COME DO A TRUE
UNDERSTANDING OF THAT YOU MUST
LEARN ABOUT IT IN THE FIELD BY
DOING THAT. THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA HAVE BEEN WELL
SERVED BY PERSONNEL WHO HAVE
WORKED THEIR WAY UP THE CHAIN
OF COMMAND AND LEADERSHIP. SUCH
PERSONNEL HAVE BEEN YEARS OF
PRACTICAL EXPERIENCE.
EXPERIENCE IS THE BEST TEACHER.
IN CLOSING I BELIEVE THE
EXISTING LAW WIRING ELIGIBILITY
FOR SHARE SELECTIONS ARE
IMPORTANT FOR THE RANK AND FILE
DEPUTIES ABOUT IT SUBMITS THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. LET'S GO TO OUR
ROOM HERE FORTY TWO OLD THREE
AND SEE IF THERE'S ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF S. B.
TWO SEVEN ONE. SHEEN NINE IN
THE ROOM LET'S GO NOW TO ROOM
TWENTY FORTY ANY WITNESSES
THERE IN SUPPORT OF TWENTY
FORTY SEEN NINE THAT'S OUR GO
TO OUR MODERATOR. DO WE HAVE
CALLERS IN Q. AND- OPPOSITION I
SHOULD SAY- SB. TWO SEVEN ONE.
THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO MAKE A
COMMENT IN OPPOSITION OF S. B.%
TWO SEVEN ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND I DO
HAVE A COUPLE IN Q. NINE FOUR
SEVEN THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MEMBERS OF THE ANTILLES CHARLIE
HALF OF THE CALIFORNIA FACULTY
ASSOCIATION WE ARE ACTUALLY CO
SPONSORS AND SUPPORT OF THE
BELGIAN. BERNIE ABOUT TO GET
EARLIER THANK YOU. Q. THANK YOU
ALL RIGHT ONE THIRTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YOUR MEMBERS
LINE SHERMAN WITH THE RIVERSIDE
SHERIFF'S ASSOCIATION IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL THANK
YOU. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT ONE
FIFTY SIX PLEASE CALL HAS. MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS BRENDA THAT
REPRESENT THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY SHERIFF IN OPPOSITION
THANK YOU. THANK YOU AS A
REMINDER IF YOU WISH TO MAKE A
COMMENT IN OPPOSITION OF S. B.
TWO SEVEN ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND I
HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENTS IN
QUEUE AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU.
ARE BRINGING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS OR
CONCERNS. RAGE HERE BY THE
COMMITTEE. REALLY SENATOR- TO A
BOWL IN THE ESSENCE OF TIME-
JUST JUST A COMMENT I AM I
THINK IT JUST WANNA POINT OUT
ONCE AGAIN THE OBSERVATIONS
THAT FIRST OF ALL I ATE I HAVE
A 8% A DISTRICT WHOSE SHERIFFS
ARE. VERY WELL APPRECIATED AND
I WOULD SAY LOVED BY MANY OF
OUR COMMUNITY MEMBERS VERY WELL
RESPECTED MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEES AS WELL AND NUMBER
TWO. I THANK YOU SOMETHING HAS
TO BE SAID WITH REGARDS TO
HAVING- EXPERIENCE IN HOLDING
THIS OFFICE- JUST LIKE THE
COUNTY AUDITORS DO THE DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S TO TREASURE TAX
COLLECTORS WHO HAVE TO HAVE
SOME THAT EXPERIENCE WITHIN
THAT FIELD IN ORDER TO SERVE IN
THOSE CAPACITIES. I FEEL WITH
THEIR LEVEL OF RESPONSIBILITIES
SUCH AS BEING AT OUR DIRECT IN
THE CORNER AT THE PUBLIC
ADMINISTRATOR EMERGENCY
OPERATIONS COORDINATOR MUTUALLY
COORDINATOR ANIMAL SERVICES
COURSERS AS EXETER EXETER I
JUST A LINE OF THINGS THAT THEY
OVERSEE. THAT IT DOES BEHOOVE
HAVING SOME SORT OF- EXPERIENCE
IN THE FIELD- WOULD YOU AGREE
DISAGREE. OF COURSE WE WANT
PEOPLE A GREAT EXPERIENCE TO
RUN IMPORTANT AGENCY. AND
SERVING AS A LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICER KEEP IN MIND YOU DON'T
TO BE A DEPUTY SHERIFF. YOU
COULD BE A- PARK POLICE OFFICER
WHO'S NEVER SET FOOT IN A
COUNTY JAIL. THANK YOU ARE THEN
ELIGIBLE TO RUN TO BE THIS TO
RUN THE JAIL. IT'S ABOUT
SOMEONE WHO'S NEVER EVEN WORKED
IN DETAILS. REMAIN ARBITRARY
DISTINCTION THAT THESE PEOPLE
CAN RUN THE CIVIL CARE. BUT IN
TERMS OF EXPERIENCE IN THE
REASON WHY TALK TO THE
BEGINNING THIS IS MY VOICE ON
ABOUT ALL THE THINGS THAT ARE
SURE OF DOGS. IN TERMS OF BEING
A MAJOR HEALTH CARE PROVIDER
LIKE IT'S A YOU KNOW AN INQUIRY
IT'S AN INDICTMENT OF OUR
SYSTEM THAT THEY'D BETTER
RESULTS HAVE TO BE OUR LARGEST
MENTAL HEALTH PROVIDERS MAJOR
HEALTH CARE PROVIDER. YOUR THE
CORONER. THAT NUMBER CAN TALK
ABOUT WHETHER IT SHOULD BE BUT
THAT'S THE LAW CALIFORNIA RIGHT
NOW. ON YOUR AGENCIES SERVING
PROCESS EVICTION. SO MANY
THINGS SO THERE ARE DIFFERENT
KINDS OF EXPERIENCES YOU COULD
IMAGINE. SAYING OKAY WE HAVE A
MAJOR MENTAL HEALTH PROBLEMS IN
OUR JAILS WE WANT TO SERVE
RIGHT NOW. WHOHAS A MAJOR
BACKGROUND A MENTAL HEALTH.
ISSUE TO THE VOTERS WANTING TO
DO THAT AND SO YOU HAVE A VERY
COMPETENT ADMINISTRATOR HO
KNOWS HOW TO RUN A MAJOR
ORGANIZATION. WITH AN EMPHASIS
ON THE THINGS OF THE VOTERS. I
THINK OUR- IS IMPORTANT AND SO
YES EXPERIENCE MATTERS BY BEING
A LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICER ISN'T
THE ONLY KIND OF EXPERIENCE I
COULD SET YOU OUGHT. TO BE- A-
YOU KNOW A SHERIFF AND YES
THERE ARE SOME POSITIONS THAT
HAVE REQUIREMENTS. BUT YOUR
SHERIFF IS A POWERFUL POSITION
YOU KNOW WE COULD MAKE A
DECISION THAT TO RUN FOR THE
LEGISLATURE THE ONLY PEOPLE
ELIGIBLE TO RUN FOR THE
LEGISLATURE. ARE PEOPLE. WHO
HAVE SERVED AS LEGISLATIVE
AIDES. RIGHT NOW NOT FOR CENTER
LONGER. WE WOULD YOU KNOW WE
WOULD. PROBABLY NOT PASS A LAW
IT'S GREAT TO HAVE FORMER
LEGISLATIVE AIDES IN THE
LEGISLATURE. BUT WE ALSO WANT
TO HAVE A DIVERSITY OF OTHER
KINDS OF PEOPLE AS WELL AND-
AND THAT LEADS TO GOOD
OUTCOMES. AND SO WE YOU KNOW I
IN THE SAME IS TRUE THIS IS A
MAJOR POSITION- WE DESERVE TO
HAVE DIVERSITY. OF PEOPLE WHO
ARE ELIGIBLE TO RUN. THANK. I
CENTER CENTER. THANK YOU ARE
CHAIR- SENATOR WIENER I'M
PREACHED OF THAT YOU BROUGHT
THIS BILL AND I THINK WHILE THE
POINTS MADE BY CERTAIN OF THE
OPPONENTS WITH CONCERN-
REGARDING THE- YOU KNOW THAT.
SOMEHOW IT'S DOWNGRADING THE
POSITION I THINK YOUR REFERENCE
TO THE FACT THAT. DEAR THE
SHERIFF IN SEARCHES GO FOR WHOM
THIS BILL. WHAT I MEAN THE
REASON THAT WE HAVE THE
REQUIREMENT OF A PEACE OFFICER
TO BE A SHERIFF WAS DUE TO
MISTER HENNESSY SELECTION AND
THEN. HIS SERVICE OVER DECADES
WHICH WAS THEN SUPPORTED BY LAW
ENFORCEMENT GROUPS ACROSS THE
STATE SO- IT'S- AND YOU ALSO
MADE THE POINT JUST NOW ABOUT
THAT YOU THAT THERE'S ALL KINDS
OF DIFFERENT CATEGORIES OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND THOSE
CATEGORIES DON'T NECESSARILY
EQUATE TO HAVING THE SKILL SET
THAT MANY OF THE OPPONENTS
RAISED WAS NECESSARY IN ORDER
TO BE A SHERIFF. SO I THINK THE
KEY THING THAT THIS DOES IS
GIVE COUNTY TO CHOICE CLEARLY
DID FOR BY PREDOMINATE
CANDIDATES WILL CONTINUE TO BE
LAW ENFORCEMENT EVEN IF WE ARE
SUCCESSFUL WITH THE STATUTE.
BECAUSE THERE WILL BE MANY
COUNTIES THE PREFERRED THAT BUT
FOR THOSE COUNTIES FOR WHOM
THEY SEE THE JOB AS A
ENCOMPASSING A MUCH LARGER ROLE
AS YOU POINTED OUT WHICH IT
DOES IN- MANY MANY COUNTIES. IT
GIVES HOSE COUNTIES THEN THE
CHOICE AND THE VOTERS THE
CHOICE AND WE OBVIOUSLY HAVE
VERY SUCCESSFUL EXAMPLES OF.
EXTRAORDINARILY COMPETENT
SHERIFFS WHO DID NOT MEET THE
QUALIFICATIONS THE CRITERIA
THAT IS NOW STATUTES. SO- HI I
THINK IT'S A GOOD BILL ARE YOU
ARE WHO REALIZE THEIR- THERE
WILL BE LOTS WHO- WHO- TRADE
INDICATE THAT SOMEHOW IT'S
DILUTING THE IMPORTANCE OF THE-
OF THE POSITION. BUT I DON'T
THINK THAT IT DOES THAT SO.
PRECIADO SUPPORTED BE
SUPPORTING IT TODAY. THANK YOU
SENATOR CALM WATER THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR SO I EIGHT TWO I'M
GOING TO BE SUPPORTING THIS
BILL- I ACTUALLY YOU KNOW I
DON'T KNOW IF THIS IS GOING TO
ENCOURAGE CHANGE AGENTS TO RUN
BUT IT STANDING THE POOL IS
NEVER A BAD THING- I SUPPORT
THAT. I ACTUALLY THINK
ESPECIALLY IN LISTENING TO YOUR
ARGUMENTS- I WOULD ENCOURAGE US
TO KIND OF FIND A WAY TO WRITE
RAISE THE BAR ON THE
QUALIFICATIONS I MEAN
PERSONALLY AND AT AT THE RISK
OF OFFENDING ANYONE IN THIS
ROOM INCLUDING MYSELF I THINK
THE BAR IS INCREDIBLY LOW FOR
RUNNING FOR OFFICE- AND WE TEND
TO BE- VICTIM OF CULT OF
PERSONALITY CANDIDATES. YOU
KNOW WHAT I DON'T EVEN KNOW IF
WE SHOULD BE ELECTING SHERIFFS
QUITE FRANKLY YOU KNOW DO WE
HAVE A DISCUSSION AROUND
APPOINTING THEM I HAVE REAL
CHALLENGES WITH SHERIFF
CORONERS- SO I WOULD HOPE THAT
THERE'S A WAY TO KIND OF YOU
KNOW RAISE THE BAR BECAUSE I DO
THINK THAT WHOEVER IS RUNNING
FOR THIS INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT
POSITION SHOULD HAVE SOME
UNDERSTANDING OF THE JOB YOU'VE
REALLY SHARED FOR US HOW
EXPANSIVE THE SCOPE OF THE JOB
IT IS- AND SO HOW DO WE MAKE
SURE THAT WE'RE- SORT OF-
SCOPING OUT THIS IN A WAY THAT
ELEVATES FOLKS WHO REALLY COULD
BE QUALIFIED CHANGE AGENTS. TO
RUN FOR THESE PARTICULAR SEATS
I THINK THE PAST TWO YEARS HAVE
SHOWN AN ESPECIALLY IN MY
COUNTY THAT WE DO OURSELVES A
DISSERVICE- WHEN WE- DON'T
REALLY FOCUS ON HOW TO CHANGE.
YOU KNOW THE PLAYBOOK TO ALLOW
FOR- DIFFERENT KINDS OF
PERSPECTIVES- TO SPEAK OF THE%
POSITION. OF SHERIFF SO I JUST
WANTED TO SHARE THAT. AND I
WILL BE SUPPORTING THE BILL.
THANK YOU AND I WANT TO THANK
CENTER WINNER FOR AGAIN A
COMMON SENSE MEASURE AGAIN I
ALL WE HAVE TO DO IS LOOK TO
THE CAREER OF HERE TENNESSEE TO
KNOW THAT THE SKY DID NOT FALL
INTO WILL NOT FALL IF WE GO
BACK TO WHAT WAS ALREADY IN
PLACE FOR. ALMOST A HUNDRED
OVER A HUNDRED THIRTY YEARS
HERE IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
WITH NO INCIDENT AND IT IT'S IS
NOT A DONDE ME THAT AT ONE
POINT YOU COULD BE APPOINTED A
JUDGE AND NOT BE A LAWYER. WE
HAD FORMER SENATOR RALPH DEALS
WHO WAS ON THE BENCH FOR A
NUMBER OF YEARS AND IT NEVER
GONNA LAW SCHOOL ANYBODY WAS
APPOINTED AS A JUDGE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA SO YOU WILL
AND TRUST FOLKS TO INTERPRET
THE LAW FOR MORE FAR MORE THAN
PEOPLE TO ENFORCE IT- I THINK
WE NEED TO GO BACK TO
COMMONSENSE APPROACH. TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT BECAUSE IT SAYS
PEACE OFFICER AND ARE YOU YOU
CAN MET. OUT PIECE WITHOUT
BEING A- THE SCHOOL. OFFICER IN
WHAT THE REAL ON FORCE IS BY
MAINTAIN PEACE. AND AGAIN I
THINK CENTER COM ARE CLEARLY
ARTICULATED ISSUE. RAISE THE
BAR OF ELECTED OFFICIALS I MEAN
WE HAVE FOLKS WHO PRICE CERTAIN
THE LEGISLATURE THAT DIDN'T
EVEN GRADUATE FROM HIGH SCHOOL
BUT THEY'RE RESPONSIBLE FOR A
MYRIAD OF ISSUES. THAT IMPACT
EVERYBODY'S LIFE NOT TO NARROW
ISSUE SUCH AS LAW ENFORCEMENT
BUT WHITES WHAT THE ISSUES THAT
WE DEAL WITH ON A DAILY BASIS
AND CLEARLY- EIGHTY EIGHT EARLY.
HI TO OF UNDERSTANDING HAS
NEVER BEEN A BARTON ARE BERRIER
FOR. A LOT OF OFFICES IN ALL I
WOULD SAY IS LOOK TO THE LAST
FOUR YEARS AT A WHITE HOUSE ME
BE CLEARLY SHOWS THAT ANYBODY
CAN BE PRESIDENT SO- I WOULD
SAY. IT WE COULD TRUST. THAT
INDIVIDUAL TO BE PRESIDENT WE
SHOULD BUILD TRUST JOHN Q.
CITIZEN WHO ASPIRES TO BE. THE
SHERIFF OF ANY OF THESE
COUNTIES THE RIGHT TO DO SO- HI
I HAVE A FORMER- PUBLIC WORKS
DIRECTOR. WHO HAD NO PUBLIC
WORKS EXPERIENCE- BUT HE WAS
APPOINTED. BECAUSE SOME ICE IS
ALL YOU HAVE TO DO IS BE A GOOD
MANAGER HE WAS A FORMER SHARE.
BUT IT NEVER ORDER ASPHALT IN
HIS LIFE BUT SOMEBODY SAW HIM
FIT TO BE A POP AND I WAS
TOTALLY AGAINST IT. CAN I SEE
YOU GOT LEAST OF SUN ABOUT
ROADS AND HIGHWAYS WITH THAT
THOUGHT YOU REALLY DID THIS NOT
YOU GOT TO BE A- GOOD MANAGER
AND HE WAS A GOOD ADMINISTRATOR.
YEAH WE GOT OUR ROADS FIXED AND
THINGS OF THAT NATURE SO OFTEN.
SURE CAN BE A PUBLIC WORKS
DIRECTOR THAN A PUBLIC GROUP
DIRECTOR OF PUBLIC WORKS
DIRECTOR SHOULD BETTER BE SURE
SO. I THINK WE HAVE A MOTION TO
MISTER- A CENTER WE WOULD LIKE
TO CLOSE. THANK YOU COLLEAGUES
FOR THE REALLY THOUGHTFUL
CONVERSATION HOWEVER PEOPLE UP
ON THE ISSUE I JUST WANT TO
SAY- CENTER COMEDY THANK YOU
FOR RAISING THE ISSUE OF
WHETHER SERVE SHOULD BE ELECTED
OR APPOINTED THAT IS. AN ISSUE
THAT HAS COME UP A LOT IN THE
KRIPAL SINGH ONE WHICH IS NOT A
LIKE THEM AT ALL. THAT'S A BY
YOU PERFECTLY. ON APPROPRIATE
TOPIC OF CONVERSATION THAT
WOULD OF COURSE REQUIRE A STATE
CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENT- AND-
IT'S CONVERSATION APPROACH
SHOULD HAPPEN. BOB WHAT I WILL
SAY THIS IS A- I THINK AS YOU
AS YOU RECOGNIZE THAT THE
FIFTH. THIS BILL AND I PRESUME
BECAUSE WILL MATTER BECAUSE IF
YOU HAVE A COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS. SAYING OH MY GOD
OUR JAILS ARE MASS SOMETHING
SAYS ON RATTLED HERE AND PER
MASS. AND THE RUNNER SPENDING
MONEY THEY DON'T HAVE AND THIS
IS A MESSAGE WE NEED A GOOD
MONEY MANAGER. TO THE SHERIFF
AND TO SET THE SHIP RIGHT. YOU
COULD SEE A BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS SAYING FOR THE NEXT
FEW YEARS AT LEAST WE WANT
SOMEONE WHO'S NOT A LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICER AND WHO
KNOWS HOW TO TURN AROUND.
TROUBLED AGENCIES AND SO WE
WOULD WANT THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS. TO HAVE THAT
FLEXIBILITY WHETHER IT'S A
VOTERS OR THE BOARD.
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. ARE YOU-
TO FINANCE BY- YES HAVE A HIGH
RISK DO TO GO FIND BOUND
CONCERT PLEASED THE ROLL
BRADFORD HI BRADFORD I THE CHAU
BOKE NO FOR ABOVE NO K. LONGER
I AM LONGER SKINNER. SKINNER I
WIENER ALL RIGHT WIENER AYE
FORTY. THANK YOU DOLLARS HI
THAT MEASURE OUT FOR THE ONE.
THE YEAH YES WE CONSIDER WOULD
CONSIDER. OF CORRECT THAT CAN.
OUR BUSINESS FOR TWO DAYS
HEARING I WANT TO THANK ALL THE
INDIVIDUALS WHO PARTICIPATED IN
THE PUBLIC TESTIMONY TODAY IF
YOU WERE NOT ABLE TO TESTIFY
TODAY PLEASE SUBMIT YOUR
COMMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS IN
WRITING TO THE PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE OR VISIT OUR WEBSITE.
YOUR COMMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS
ARE IMPORTANT TO US AND WE WANT
TO INCLUDE YOUR TESTIMONY AN
OFFICIAL HEARING RECORDS THANK
YOU FOR THANK YOU AND WE
APPRECIATE YOUR PARTICIPATION I
WANT TO THANK EVERYONE AGAIN
FOR YOUR PATIENCE AND
COOPERATION WE HAVE CONCLUDES
TODAY'S AGENDA OF THE SENATE
PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE WE
STAND ADJOURNED.